CAUCUSES SO WILL BE SLIGHTLY
DELAYED THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
JUST BROKE THIS SO THEY SHOULD
BE HERE SHORTLY SO I'D
APPRECIATE IT IF YOU WOULD STAY
ON THE FLOOR SO WE CAN BEGIN
PROCEEDINGS MOMENTARILY
. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
I'LL. YES BRADFORD COUNTY AT
ALL. CHANG DALLY DOT THE ROUTE
SO GAL JOHNNY GLAZER UNS OUT
LESS. HERTZBERG HILL WAY SO
TADO JACKSON JONES. LLEVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONEY LOCKED
MERRELL NELSON AND FORTINO ROCK.
SKINNER STERN STONE NUMBER BY
KELSEY WINNER WILL. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT THE MEMBERS IN OUR GAS
BEYOND THE RAILING IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LET
IN FOR THIS MORNING BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AS WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR. BY CASKEY. LET
US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. GRACIOUS GOD OF MERCY
AS WE FACE THE CHALLENGES OF
THESE TIMES WE DESIRE TO SPEAK
WORDS OF COMFORT TO OUR
SUFFERING WORLDS. WE STAND AS
KEEPERS OF THE DOOR OF MERCY
ATTUNED DISPOSED. WE WILL HOLD
THE DOOR AJAR FOR THE DESPERATE
AND THE DISRUPTIVE THE STRAYING
THE STRANGE THE WOUNDED WISE
AND THE CHILD'S TOO SOON OLD.
WE WILL NOT CLOSE THE STORE OF
MERCY. THERE WILL BE ROOM S. R.
IN AND SPACE AT THE TABLE.
WHERE THE COOKING POT HOLES
AMPLE. THROUGH THE DOOR IS
FEAST AND SAFETY HOPE AND
SHELTER. AS YOUR DOOR OF MERCY
WE ONLY HAVE TO KNOCK ONCE AND
WE ONLY HAVE TO KNOCK LIGHTLY.
BECAUSE YOU GOD OF MERCY ARE
ALWAYS HOME A MAN. ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF. STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC.
AND THE GUY THAT IS ALL WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MOVING THE PRIVILEGES THE FLOOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED TO
READ. HE JUST FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED DREAD REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED DREAD
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOVING
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. PURSUANT TO RULE
TWENTY NINE TEN THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM SEVEN A. B. ONE
ONE ONE EIGHT ITEM THREE FORTY
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN.
PURSUANT TO SET ROLE TWENTY
NINE TEN C. THE FOLLOWING BILLS
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
ITEM SIXTEEN A B. TWELVE FIFTY
ONE. AS A REMINDER MEMBERS WERE
STILL EMOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES THIS IS THE PROPER TIME
TO MOVE ITEMS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ALL RIGHT SEEING NO
MIKE'S UP WILL MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION THE DAILY FILE.
PER SECOND READING FILE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. A
SIMILAR BILL TO NINETY WITHIN
MOMENTS. EIGHT FORTY NINE SIX
HUNDRED FIFTEEN FORTY EIGHT
FORTY NINE ELEVEN TEN ELEVEN
EIGHT
SECRETARY THE SECOND READING
FILE WILL BE DEEMED RAT. MOVING
TO FINISH BUSINESS FIRST ITEM
UP FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN.
SENATOR BRADFORD. MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY FIVE A SENATOR BRADFORD
AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY.
MISTER BRADFORD THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT THIS IS A VERY
SIMPLE MEASURE AS BEEF ONE FIVE
FIVE DISTURBANCE ACCOUNTABILITY
INTERIORS ARE P. AS- AN I. R.
P. PROGRAM AT THIS SOMEONE
MOMENTS ARE JUST CLARIFYING THE
NATURE AND I SIMPLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. AT MEMBERS WE HAVE A
COUPLE MEMBERS THAT THAT ARE
RUNNING LATE SO WERE YOU PUT
EVERYTHING ON CALL SO WE'RE
ONLY GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO PLACE IT ON CALL. SO
SEEING NO. FURTHER COMMENTS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. PART I ARCHULETA I ADKINS
BATES HI BILL BY BURGESS HI
BREVARD I CAN BE AT ALL. CHANG
HI DOLLY HI DOG HI THERE ALSO I
GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER. GONZALEZ.
GROWTH I HEARD THE WORD. HI
HILL I WAS SO BY TADO. JACKSON
JONES. THEY HAVE A. TIME
ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL BY MONEY.
BUY MORE LOCK I'M A REAL.
NELSON PAN HI FORTINO. HI RALPH.
I RUBIO I SKINNER BY STERN BY
STONE I AMBERG OUR COUNTY. I
WINNER. WILK HI. HELLO HI. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NO ZERO SENATOR
MOVES THE CALL. OKAY CENTER
MOVES CALL MOVING ON IT WE'RE
GONNA RETURN ACTUALLY TWO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTION SENATOR
HILL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT PLEASE MOVE
FILE ITEM. TWO ZERO SIX EIGHTY
THREE ZERO TWO TWO THE INACTIVE
FILE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTH. DULY NOTED THANK YOU.
WHILE I'M THREE SIXTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE NINETEEN FROM
SPECIAL CONSENT FOR PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SIR AND
ONE MORE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM THREE SEVENTY EIGHT B.
NINE TWENTY FROM CONSENT AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU SIR DULY NOTED. THANK YOU.
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO. SENATOR
UMBERG. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SIX SIXTY FIVE
A SENATOR UMBERG ACKERLEY
MIDDLE HEALTH MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE AND
CLICKING THERE TO THE RIGHT TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CENTERED AROUND BERT THANK YOU
MISS PRESENT MEMBERS SP SIX SIX
FIVE MAKES A SMALL CHANGE IN
LAW WHICH CAN RESULT IN GREAT
BENEFIT BOTH TO THE COMMUNITY
IN THE INDIVIDUAL WHAT IT DOES
IS IT PROVIDES FOR MORE OF. A
USE FOR MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
IN JAILS THIS IS. DESIGNED TO
MOVE THIS OVER TO THE ASSEMBLY
TO BE CONCLUDED IN JANUARY
URGENT I VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
AMBERG ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BAIT.
HI BILL HI BRIDGES BY BRADFORD
I COVER YET ALL. CHANG I DAILY
BY DODD HI THERE ALSO I GOT
JOHNNY. I GLAZER. GONZALES BY
GROWTH HERTZBERG I HILL HIGHWAY
SO. I TITLE BY JACKSON BY JONES.
LABOR I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL
BY MORNING I'M MORE LARK EMERIL.
HI NELSON. PAN HI FORTINO HI
ROSS I RUBIO I SKINNER. BY
STERN BY STONE. I AMBERG OUR
CASKEY BY WINNER I WILL BUY.
SENATOR BRUCE A CALL NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO AN
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FIRST
UP IS FILE ITEM. WELL I'M SORRY
I MISSED ONE YES WE'RE WE'LL
STAY ON SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE SENATOR
HER TADO. YOUR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY
FOUR BY SENATOR TADO RELATIVE
TO THE INTERNATIONAL DAY FOR
THE ERADICATION OF POVERTY.
CENTER HER TADO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION
SIXTY FOUR WHICH WOULD
DESIGNATE OCTOBER SEVENTEENTH
AS INTERNED INTERNATIONAL DAY
FOR THE ERADICATION OF POVERTY.
ON OCTOBER SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE UNITED NATIONS
DECLARED INTERNATIONAL DAY FOR
THE ERADICATION OF POVERTY. ON
THIS DAY POVERTY WAS PROCLAIMED
AS A VIOLATION OF HUMAN RIGHTS
AND THE NEED WAS A FIRM TO COME
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT THESE
RIGHTS ARE RESPECTED. OCTOBER
SEVENTEENTH PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
EFFORT AND STRUGGLE OF PEOPLE
LIVING IN POVERTY AND A MOMENT
TO RECOGNIZE THAT POOR PEOPLE
ARE THE FIRST ONES TO FIGHT
AGAINST POVERTY POVERTY IS A
PROBLEM RELATED NOT TO
FINANCIAL RESOURCES AND ALSO TO
A LACK OF OPPORTUNITY. POVERTY
ERADICATION IS CLOSER TO
ANSWERING HEALTH ACCESS TO
QUALITY EDUCATION FOR ALL AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EMPLOYMENT.
IN AN EFFORT TO CONTINUE RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE NEED RADIC POVERTY THIS
THIS RESOLUTION WITH THE
OCTOBER SEVENTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN AS INTERNATIONAL FOR
THE REVOCATION. POVERTY SPEC
FULLY ASPIRIN VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR TITLE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES HI BILL I PURCHASED BY
BRADFORD I CAN BE YELLOW HI
CHENG I. DELI. HI DOT. HAIDAR
ALSO. I GOT A JOURNEY I GLAZER.
GONZALES I GROVE HERTZBERG. HI
GROW BY. HILL BY WAY SO HIGHER
TADO. HI JACKSON BY JONES. HI
LABOR TIME ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
BY MORNING BUY MORE LOCK TIME
REAL BY NELSON PAN. HI FORTINO
BY ROSS BY RUBIO I SKINNER BY
STERN BY STONE I AMBERG HI IRA
CASKEY BY WINNER BY WILL HI.
CENTER TOGGLE MOVES A CALL. NOW
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLIES THIRD READING. FIRST
ITEM UP IT IS FILE FIFTY ONE
CENTER GLASER'S IS NOT ON THE
FLOOR. WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST
WITH US TODAY A FORMER A FORMER
COLLEAGUE IN THE SENATE AND IN
A MEMBER OF THE LA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS MISTER MARK
RIDLEY THOMAS
. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE. I SEE THEM
MISTER MERRETT CHOIRS READY SO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ A
SUM OF ELEVEN NINETY NINE BY
SOME MEMBER PETER NORRIS AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE REAL PROPERTY
CINEMA BUYER HEY GOOD MORNING
MISTER PRESIDENT THANKS FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK SIR PLEASE
PRESENT AT ELEVEN NINETY NINE
ON BEHALF OF THIS IN THE ONE
BETWEEN NORRIS. THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES TO HOLD A PUBLIC
MEETING ON THE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTS IN A PROPERTY IF
MORE THAN ONE STATE AGENCY
KATE'S AN INTEREST IN A SURPLUS
PROPERTY. EIGHT ELEVEN NINETY
NINE WILL PROVIDE AN INCREASE
OF TRANSPARENCY AND CANDIDLY
MEETING COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL THOSE RECEIVED
BY PARDON SPORT IS HAD NO
OPPOSITION. WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AIBO. THANK YOU SIR.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL BY BURGESS I BREVARD I CAN
BE A ROW BY CHANG. I DELI. DOT
I DOURADO I GOT JOHNNY. GLAZER
CAL JOHNNY I. GONZALEZ I GROW I
HEARD HER I HILL I WAS SO. HI
TACO I JACKSON. JONES BY LABOR.
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL. BY
MONEY HI. MORE LOCK HI. WHAT WE
CALL A CORRAL THE TICKET HI
NELSON. PAN HI FI FORTINO. HI
ROSS MY REVIEW THE RIGHT EYE
SKINNER. BY STERN BY STONE. I
AMBERG FIVE AKOWSKI BY WINNER
BY WILKE. HI WILL GUY. DELHI II
JACKSON I. THERE REQUIRE MOVES
THE CALL. NEXT UP FILE ITEMS
SIXTY NINE CENTER WHY CASKEY.
SOME FILE THERE'S AMENDMENTS
THAT THE DESK ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SIR MOVE ON MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
SENATOR BAITS ARE YOU PREPARED.
YOUR SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY ONE BY
SOME REMEMBER BRO AN ACT
RELATING TO FATAL VEHICULAR
ACCIDENTS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE RESENT
M. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY ONE
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRO EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY ONE
REQUIRES MORE DATA TO BE
COLLECTED IN FATAL VEHICLE
COLLISIONS. IT STANDARDIZES THE
U. I. TESTING PRACTICES FOR
CORONERS AND MEDICAL EXAMINERS
IN CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY LOCAL
ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO JUST TO
TEST THE SEAS DRIVERS AND
PASSENGERS FOR ALCOHOL CONTENT.
LEAVING MANY FATAL COLLISIONS
THAT MAY HAVE INVOLVED DRUGS
GOING UNDETECTED STATEWIDE
COLLECTING ACCURATE DATA
ESTABLISHING STATE WIDE
PRACTICES TO BE PERFORMED BY
OUR CORONERS AND MEDICAL
EXAMINERS WILL HELP CREATE
BETTER POLICIES TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES IN THE
FUTURE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR BATES.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN.
HI ARCHULETA I ADKINS BATES BY
BELL. BY BURGESS I BRADFORD I
CARRY AROUND HI CHENG I. DELI I
DODD. TIRADO I GOT JOHNNY BY
GLAZER. GONZALES I GROVE I
HEARD HER. HILL I WAS SO HIGHER
TITLE I JACKSON BY JONES BY
LABOR TIME ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MORNING BUY MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL I KNOW SOME PAIN I FORTINO
HI ROSS MY REVIEW. I SKINNER BY
STERN I STONE I AMBERG. I WORK
OUT SEE I WINNER I WILL LOOK HI.
SENATOR BATES MOVES THE CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
TWO. SENATOR UMBERG. CASE
REPAIR MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ A SUM OF ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE BY A SEMI MEMBER O'DONNELL
AND NECRO IN GREENHOUSE GASES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES ON PLEASE RESENT A
BE ELEVEN NINETY FIVE RESTRICTS
THE A. R. B. TO CONSIDER
ALLOWING OIL AND GAS COMPANIES
A CLAIM IN INNOVATIVE
PRODUCTION METHOD CREDIT FOR
USING RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
DELIVERED BY COMMON CARRIER
PIPELINE. PROVIDE THE SOURCE
REDUCES METHANE EMISSIONS WITH.
CALIFORNIA UP ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG. ANY
FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION
SAYING NOW MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS HI BRADFORD I CAN BE AT
ALL. HI CHENG I. DELI I DONT.
I'D RATHER I GOT A JOURNEY. BY
GLAZER GONZALES. GROVE
HERTZBERG. GROW BY. HILL I WAS
SO TIRED SADDAM. BY JACKSON.
JONES I LIVE A TIME ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI. MONEY. BUY MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL. BY NELSON PAN
HI FIVE FORTINO HI ROSS. REVIEW
HI BROTHER. SKINNER STERN.
STONE. HI AMBERG OUR CASSIE. I
WINNER BY WILL HI. MITCHELL I
DON'T KNOW. SENATOR UMBERG
MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS RIGHT
NOW REMOVED BACK TO SEND IT
THIRD READING FOR FILE ITEM
THIRTY FOUR CENTER JACKSON. ARE
YOU PREPARED BALL ITEM THIRTY
FOUR MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ
IN A RESOLUTION SIXTY FIVE US
SENATOR JACKSON RELATIVE TO
PAIN AWARENESS CENTER JACKSON
FLOORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. I THINK
EVERYONE IN THIS FLOOR HAS AT
SOME POINT IN THEIR LIFE EITHER
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
EXCRUCIATING PAIN OR KNOW
SOMEONE WHO HAS AND KNOWS HOW
DEBILITATING IT CAN BE. NO
MATTER HOW YOU TRY TO THINK
IT'S MIND OVER MATTER. IT JUST
ISN'T AND SO THIS IS A
RESOLUTION THAT RECOGNIZES AND
DECLARES THE MONTH OF SEPTEMBER.
AND AS PAIN AWARENESS MONTH AND
SPECIFICALLY ALSO RECOGNIZES
SEPTEMBER FIRST AS WOMEN IN
PAIN AWARENESS DAY. NOW WE KNOW
THAT MORE THAN A HUNDRED
MILLION AMERICANS LIVE WITH
CHRONIC PAIN CAUSED BY VARIOUS
DISEASES OR DISORDERS AND
NEARLY TWENTY FIVE MILLION
AMERICANS SUFFER WITH ACUTE
PAIN EACH YEAR. THOUGH WE NO
MEDICAL KNOWLEDGE AND
TECHNOLOGY EXISTS TO RELIEVE OR
GREATLY EASE SOME PAIN MOST
TRADE MOST PAIN IS UNTREATED
UNDER TREATED OR IMPROPERLY
TREATED AS WE HAVE NOTED BY
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES WE HAVE.
EXPERIENCE WITH THE OPIOID
EPIDEMIC THAT EXISTS BUT THE
PAIN IS REAL. THE PAIN IS REAL
AND WE KNOW THAT MANY
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS ARE
STILL UNAWARE OF HOW TO
EFFECTIVELY TREAT THAT PAIN.
WHO SUFFER FROM CHRONIC PAIN
OFTEN ARE STIGMATIZED
MARGINALIZED AND NOT INFORMED
OF THE RIGHT THAT THEY HAVE TO
TRY TO SEEK AFFECTED PAIN
ASSESSMENT AND MANAGEMENT. AND
MOST PEOPLE WITH PAIN INCLUDING
THOSE SHOULD END OF LIFE GET
LITTLE OR NO RELIEF WOMEN. HAVE
A HIGHER PREVALENCE THAN MAN OF
SYNDROMES AND DISEASES
ASSOCIATED WITH CHRONIC PAIN
THINGS LIKE FIBROMYALGIA
COMPLEX PAIN SYNDROME IN
OSTEOARTHRITIS AND WE KNOW
PEOPLE RESPOND DIFFERENTLY TO
CERTAIN ANALGESICS. WOMEN ARE
MORE FREQUENT TWO IN REPORTING
PAIN TO HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
BUT ARE ALSO MORE LIKELY TO
HAVE THEIR PAIN REPORTS
DISCOUNTED AS EMOTIONAL OR
CYCLE JANICK. AND THEREFORE NOT
REAL. THIS TIME WE RECOGNIZED
AND DO WHAT WE CAN TO ADDRESS
WHAT IS A DEBILITATING
CONDITION FOR SO MANY OF OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS AND ON
OCCASION OURSELVES THAT IS WHAT
THIS MEASURE DOES AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
IN IRAQ KNOWLEDGE IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS DAY IN THIS
MONTH N. WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. ACTION OR DEBATE.
CENTER STONE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
US ARE SIXTY FIVE AS A
PHARMACIST THAT IS SPECIALIZED
IN PAIN CONTROL NOW FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS THERE ARE A LOT OF
MODALITIES OUT THERE THAT DO
NOT INVOLVE NARCOTICS THEY CAN
PROVIDE FOR COMPREHENSIVE PAIN
CONTROL FOR PATIENTS AND THE
ISSUE IS EDUCATING PATIENTS
THAT. THERE ARE IN FACT
PROFESSIONALS OUT THERE THAT
CAN BE SEEN AND CAN RESPONSIBLY
ADDRESS THEIR PAIN ISSUES
NOBODY SHOULD BE LIVING IN PAIN
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE PLETHORA
OF PAIN CONTROL DOCTORS THAT WE
HAVE THESE ARE DOCTORS AND NOT
ONLY HAVE THEIR MD DEGREE MOST
OF IT ON THERE ANESTHESIOLOGY
DEGREE AND THEN DO ANOTHER
RESIDENCY. IN PAIN CONTROL. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF PROGRESS BEING
MADE IN THE PAIN AREA THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE THE UTILIZATION OF
NARCOTICS. WE HAVE NEAR
STIMULATOR CENTER USE
MECHANICAL DEVICES IN THE SPINE
THAT HELP PEOPLE HAVE SPINAL
CORD PROBLEMS THERE IS A DRUG
THAT'S BEEN UTILIZE IT HAS BEEN
SHOWING A LOT OF PROMISE.
COMMONLY KNOWN AS SNAIL SPIT IT
ACTUALLY IS THE VENOM OF THE
MOST POISONOUS NAIL FOUND IN
THE OCEAN WHERE THEY'VE
ISOLATED THE VENOM. THE DILUTED
THE VENOM AND THEY FIND THAT
HAS THE SAME PAIN RELIEVING
CAPABILITIES AS MORPHINE. BUT
WITHOUT ANY TYPE OF ADDICTION.
SO THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS THAT
WE HAVE PAIN CONTROL SPECIALIST
THAT EXISTS IN EVERY PART OF
CALIFORNIA AND IF ONE FINDS
THAT THEY'RE IN ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF PAIN THEY SHOULD GO
SEE THE APPROPRIATE
PROFESSIONAL THAT HAS A LOT OF
TOOLS THAT DON'T NECESSARILY
INCLUDE NARCOTICS AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I SUPPORT SR SIXTY
FIVE. THANK YOU CENTER STONE.
JACKSON WOULD YOU CARE TO CLOSE
YES THANK YOU ALWAYS A PLEASURE
TO BE ON THE SAME SIDE WITH MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE THE PHARMACISTS
FROM TO MACULA. NOT NECESSARILY
HAPPY TO FIND OUT WHAT SOME OF
THE ALTERNATIVES ARE IT BUT
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
GOOD PHARMACIST RECOGNIZES THAT
THERE IS. POTENTIALLY TREATMENT
OUT THERE. NOT ALWAYS BUT- WE
KNOW WE MUST RECOGNIZE THE PAIN
IS REAL AND CAN BE DEBILITATING
THAT'S WHAT THIS RESOLUTION
ATTEMPTS TO DO. I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT THE MEDICAL
STUDENTS NOW WE'RE GETTING MORE
TRAINING IN PALLIATIVE CARE AND
OTHER TYPES OF PAIN MANAGEMENT
WE NEED TO DO MORE AND WE NEED
TO RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN WOMEN
PRESENT WITH PAIN IT'S USUALLY
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN PAIN. NOT
PART SHOULD ALLIES OR DISMISS
THAT PAIN. BUT TRY TO FIND A
TREATMENT AND CURE THAT'S GOING
TO BE EFFECTIVE SO THAT WE CAN
ALL LIVE HEALTHY HAPPY THRIVING
AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES IN WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES HI BILL I PURCHASED HI
BRADFORD HI KELLY AT ALL. I
CHANGED BY DELI I DONT I'D
RATHER. I GUESS JOHNNY I GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI GROVE. I HURTS BERG.
HILL I WAS SO. HIGHER TITLE I
JACKSON HI JONES. I LIVE A I'M
ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL BY MORNING
I'M MORE LOCK I AM REAL BY
NELSON. PAN HI FORTINO HI ROSS
BY RUBIO. HI NIELSEN I SKINNER.
I STERN HI STONE. BY AMBERG OUR
COUNTY. BY WINNER BY WILKE HI
CENTER JACKSON MOVES THE CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NINETY
TWO SENATOR ALAN ARE YOU
PREPARED. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
THREE. A SUMMIT OF FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
GLORIA AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS. SENATOR ALAN THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT UNDER EXISTING
LAW ONLY PUBLIC PROSECUTORS MAY
FILE LAWSUITS CHARGING UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES. ARE THESE
ACTIONS MAY BE BROUGHT FORTH BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR THE CITY
ATTORNEY OF ANY CITY WITH A
POPULATION OF GREATER THAN
SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND. WHEN THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY BRINGS
FORWARD IN ACTION UNDER THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW THE YOU
SEE ALL. THAT COUNTY RECEIVES
ALL THE CIVIL PENALTIES AWARDED
BY THE COURT. HOWEVER. THE CITY
ATTORNEY BRING SUCH AN ACTION
THOSE CIVIL PENALTIES MUST BE
SPLIT EVENLY WITH THE TREASURE
OF THE COUNTY IN WHICH THE
JUDGMENT WAS ENTERED EVEN IF
THE COUNTY PROVIDED OBVIOUSLY
NO ASSISTANCE IN THE ACTION TO
THE CITY ATTORNEY THIS
DISCREPANCY HAS LEFT THOSE
ELIGIBLE CITY TURNS WITH A
DIFFICULT CHOICE BALANCING THE
PURSUIT OF LEGAL RECOURSE
AGAINST UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS
WITH THE REALITY. OF THEIR
FINITE RESOURCES. LEGAL MORAL
RESPONSIBILITIES ELIGIBLE. CITY
ATTORNEY'S HAS BEEN IT IS TO BE
UNDER THIS BILL TO PROVIDE
RELIEF FOR THE HARM CONSUMER.
HI THIS BILL REQUIRES PENALTIES
COLLECTED BY AN ELIGIBLE CITY
ATTORNEY FOR FROM AN ACTION
UNDER THE U. C. L. TO BE PAID.
TO THE CITY. THE BILL WAS
RICHLY AMENDED TO ALLOW THE
COUNTY TO STILL RECEIVE HALF OF
THE WORD A PENALTY IF THEY
PARTICIPATED IN THE PRE
LITIGATION. INVESTIGATION OF
THE ACTION. ADDITIONALLY RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO DELAY THE
EFFECTIVE DATE FOR THE CITY OF
LA. NOW PUSHED BACK TO JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BY
ENSURING AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF PENALTIES
AWARDED INTO THE YOU SEE ALL
THIS BILL. WILL EMPOWER THOSE
ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEYS TO
PROSECUTE AGAINST AND FOR
BUSINESSES. IN THE INTERESTS OF
CONSUMERS IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND I RESPECT FASTER I LOVE.
THANK YOU SAID AROUND ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
NO THAT CAN SPEAK BATES. BELL
HI PORGES NO BRADFORD. I CAN BE
AT ALL HI CHANGE NO DELHI. NO
DOT. I'D RATHER I GOT JOHNNY BY
GLAZER GONZALES HIGH GROWTH. HI.
OF GROVE NO GROWTH NO. HILL
WITH A. HILL I WAS A WIDER TADO.
BY JACKSON. BY JONES NO FLAVOR.
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL MY
MONEY BUY MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NO NELSON. NO PAN. HI FORTINO.
I ROTH I RUBIO. SKINNER. BY
STERN BY STONE. NO BERG OUR
CASKEY I WINNER HI WILL NO.
SENATOR ALAN MOVES THE CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NINETY
FIVE SENATOR WHY CASKEY ARE YOU
PREPARED PASS ON FILE YOU'RE
HAVING QUITE THE MORNING SIR.
MOVING ON TO A LOT OF ONE OH
FIVE. CENTER REQUIRE YOU ARE
PREPARED MR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL. EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT BY SME MEMBER LEVIN ANAK
RELATE TO CAMPUS. THEY REQUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT AT EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT BY SOME MEMBERS OF BEING
AT WOULD PROVIDE A TECHNICAL
FIX IN THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE FOR QUICK
CANNABIS CULTIVATION HERE'S THE
LONG STORY IN THE SHORT OF IT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SOME
MEMBER WOULD ROUGHT FORWARD TO
BUILD FOR TYPE ONE C. LICENSES
THAT ARE CALLED SPECIALTY
COTTAGE LICENSES. IN THIS
LICENSE TO IS ISSUED BY THE
CAPTAIN APARTMENT OF FOOD IN AG
UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF THE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA REGULATION
AND SAFETY ACT IT DID NOT
IMPOSE IT DID NOT IMPOSE A
CANOPY SIZE LIMIT. FOR THOSE
COTTAGE INDUSTRY GROWS THAT
MADE THE TYPE ONE C. LICENSE
INCONSISTENT WITH OTHER LICENSE
SALES. BY PLACING A TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT. CAN IT BE
LIMIT ON FOR AN OUTDOOR GROW A
TIGHT ONE C. LICENSE WILL NOW
CONFORM WITH ALL THE OTHER
LICENSE TYPES FOR OUTDOOR
CANNABIS. THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
MCGUIRE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN. I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS BATES. BELL
HI PORGES. BRADFORD I CARRY ERA
HI CHENG BY DELHI BY DODD I'D
RATHER I GUESS JOHNNY. I GLAZER
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG. HILL I WAS SO. I
TACO. NO JACKSON. JONES LABOR.
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL. MONEY.
HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE NO
NELSON NO PAIN FIVE FOUR TO DO
YOU KNOW BY ROTH I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN. STONE. NUMBER
OUR CASKEY I WINNER. WILK HI.
JONES NO STONE I. FOR JUST NO.
OKAY AS THE CENTER MOVES TO
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
OH SEVEN SENATOR HER TITLE. ARE
YOU PREPARED. OKAY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME
ABOUT THREE SEVENTY SEVEN BY A
SEMI MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA AND
ACKLINGTON RETAIL FOOD
FACILITIES INCLUDING THEIR
THREATS TAKE EFFECT MERELY.
CENTER TADO. I'M GONNA HAVE TO.
FILL OUT AN ASSIST. PASS ON
FILE SIZE RIGHT FASSEL FILE
MOVING ON TO FILE. ITEM ONE
TWELVE SENATOR UMBERG ARE YOU
PREPARED. THANK YOU SIR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ALSO MY
BILL FORTINO SEVEN BY SOME
REMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND ACT
REALLY NO VEHICLES CENTER I'M
BIRD. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES RECKLESS DRIVING IN
ILLEGAL STREET RACING OUR
PROBLEMS IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS. THIS SMART INSTABLE
BUILT BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN FRIEDMAN
CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW
CONCERNING THE IMPOUNDMENT OF A
VEHICLE AFTER SUBSEQUENT
CONVICTIONS FOR RECKLESS
DRIVING OR ILLEGAL STREET
RACING. IT DOES NOT PERMIT THE
DRIVER TO WOULD. BASICALLY
OBTAIN THE VEHICLE IN A SHORTER
THAN THIRTY DAY PERIOD ALSO
REQUIRES THAT ANY ILLEGAL
MODIFICATIONS BE REMOVED FROM
THE CAR BEFORE IT'S RELEASED I
URGE NO VOTE. THANK YOU SIR ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALAN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. HI BILL BY
BURGESS I BREVARD. COPYRIGHT.
HI CHENG I. DELI. DOT I'D
RATHER GO. I GOT JOHNNY HI
GLAZER GONZALES HI GROVE I
HURTS BERG. HILL I WAS SO.
AYATOLLAH I JACKSON. HI JONES.
THEY HAVE A. I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MORNING I'M MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL. HI NELSON BY
PAN I FORTINO BY ROSS BY RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN. STONE I AMBERG
HI OUR CASKEY I WINNER HI WILL
HI. WE ARE MEMBERS WERE NOT
GOING TO DO THAT WE'RE GOING TO
THE ROLE ONCE IF YOU DO IF YOU
DON'T CASH ABOUT AT THAT TIME
YOU HAVE TO WAIT TILL WE COME
BACK WE'RE GONNA. MEMBERS RINGO
BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN.
BRADFORD WE WERE PLACING. THE
MANDATE WHAT SO THAT'S ON CALL.
AS DIRECTED TO THE FAR CORNER
OVER THERE WHERE TO MOVE BACK
TO FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN
SENATOR HER TITLE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MEMBERS. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. A SOME OF THE THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
DAUGHTER GARCIA AND ACCORDING
TO RETAIL FOOD FACILITIES AND
CLAIM THEIR THROATS TAKE FACT
MERELY. THAN HER TADO. MISTER
PRESIDENT I APOLOGIZE ON BEHALF
OF MY COLLEAGUES TO THE LEFT OF
ME HERE BUT WANTED TO I STAND
UP AND I RISE TO INTRODUCE. TO
PRESENT A B. THREE SEVEN SEVEN
WHICH IS A CLEAN UP BILL TO AB
SIXTY SIX. WHICH ESTABLISHED
MICRO ENTERPRISE HOME KITCHEN
OPERATIONS AS A NEW TYPE OF
RESTRICTED FOOD FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. AB SIX TWO SIX
PROVIDE THE CRITICAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOUSANDS OF
COOKS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TURN MEANINGFUL
MEANINGFUL INCOME IN A MANNER
THAT IS LEGAL AND SAFE. DESPITE
AN EXTENSIVE THREE YEARS
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES HAVE COME TO
LIGHT. A SINCE THE AUTHOR IS
COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF A B. SIX TWO
SIX HE FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT
AND TIMELY FOR US TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES BEFORE
IMPLEMENTATION. LEAD TO
CONFUSION AMONG STAKEHOLDERS.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THE LAW IN
THE FOLLOWING WAYS IT. WHICH
JURORS WHICH JURISDICTION IS
ELIGIBLE TO OPT IN INTO THE
PROGRAM HOW STANDARDS FOR
HEALTH AND SAFETY SHALL BE
IMPLEMENTED TO PROTECT COOKS
AND CONSUMERS. HOW INSPECTIONS
WILL BE CONDUCTED. EXPECTATIONS
FOR ADVERTISING AND CLEAR
ARTICULATION OF THE FACT THE
HOME KITCHEN OPERATORS CAN ONLY
USE THIRD PARTY DELIVERY
SERVICES TO DELIVER FOOD TO THE
DISABLED. THE AUTHOR HAS HER
CONCERN FROM SEVERAL CITIES
AROUND THE STATE THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL WILL TAKE
AWAY THEIR LIGHT TOO OFTEN.
HOWEVER IT IS HIS POSITION THAT
SUCH A RIGHT WAS NEVER THE
INTENTION OF AB SIX TWO SIX.
ARE THESE CHANGES WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THE INTENT AND
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW ARE
CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD ACROSS ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN CARRIES AN
URGENCY COST INSURE IT TAKES
EFFECT IN TIME. TO ENSURE
PROPER IMPLEMENTATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. BOAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER HER
TADO. ANY OTHER DISCUSS OR
DEBATE. WE CONFIRM WHAT WHAT
BILL NUMBER YOU'RE TALKING ON.
EIGHTY THREE SEVEN SEVEN OKAY
GREAT THAT'S PERFECT CENTER
STONE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
TODAY I RISE IN OPPOSITION
MAYBE THREE SEVENTY SEVEN WHICH
SEEKS TO UNDO MUCH OF THE GOOD
WORK DONE LAST YEAR BY EIGHTY
SIX TWENTY SIX WHICH WERE
CREATED MICRO ENTERPRISE HOME
KITCHEN OPERATIONS. A TITLE
ONLY A BUREAUCRAT COULD LOVE.
HE'S IN GERMAN. WHEN WE WERE
KIDS BACK BEFORE CALIFORNIA
BECAME SUCH A NANNY STATE I'M
NOT SURE HOW WE DIDN'T JUST
KILL OVER AND DIE FROM MOM AND
DAD'S HOME COOKING. LAST YEAR'S
AB SIX TWENTY SIX RECOGNIZE THE
GROWTH OF HOME. BASED KITCHEN
INDUSTRIES ESTABLISH A NEW
CATEGORY. OF RETAIL FOOD
FACILITIES CALLED M. H. CASE
FOR SHORT. THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES WOULD HAVE THE
DISCRETION. TO AUTHORIZE AND
PERMIT. OR TO BE OPERATED BY A
PRIVATE A RESIDENT IN THEIR OWN
PRIVATE HOME. THIS BILL HAD
WIDE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HECK I
EVEN VOTED FOR IT BECAUSE IT
NOT ONLY SUPPORTED THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT. THAT
HAS MADE THIS COUNTRY GREAT BUT
IT ALSO LET. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES IF THEY WISH TO
ALLOW MH KAYS WITHIN THEIR
BOUNDARIES FOR INSTANCE. IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OF MERRY AT
OFFICIALS DECIDED PERMIT MH
CASE THEY COULD DO SO. AND OF
THE PEOPLE IN INDIO THREE HOURS
AWAY IN MY DISTRICT ALSO AND
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT. FOR
WHATEVER REASON THAT WOULD BE A
LOCAL DECISION. IT IS FOR GONE
TOO FAR OFTEN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT THE GOVERNMENT
THAT IS CLOSEST TO THE PEOPLE
THE GOVERNMENT OPERATES I THINK
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PEOPLE BUT I GUESS. AB SIX
TWENTY SIX WAS TOO MUCH OF A
GOOD THING SO A. B. THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN WAS CREATED TO.
CHANGE AB THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
TAKES AWAY REAL LOCAL CONTROL
BY REMOVING THE AUTONOMY. FOR
THE VAST MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES UNDER THIS BILL. IF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DECIDED TO
PERMIT MH CASE THE
AUTHORIZATION WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY APPLY TO. ALL
TWENTY EIGHT CITIES IN THE
COUNTY AND THE UNINCORPORATED
AREA. THE OPPOSITE IS ALSO TRUE
THAT THE COUNTY DECIDES. NOT TO
PERMIT MH CASE NONE OF THE
CITIES IN THE IN THE CORPORATE
AREAS OF A LOT OF PERMIT THEM.
AND VICE VERSA SO MUCH FOR.
LOCAL CONTROL. EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN ALSO AMENDS THE
DEFINITION OF INMATE CASE TO
PROHIBIT THE PRODUCTION.
MANUFACTURING PROCESSING
FREEZING. OR PACKAGING OF MILK
OR MILK PRODUCTS INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO. CHEESE ICE
CREAM YOGURT SOUR CREAM AND
BUTTER. IT ALSO PLACES
RESTRICTIONS ON WHO CAN
DELIVER. HOME BAKED GOODS HOW
THESE BUSINESS CAN PROMOTE
THEIR PRODUCTS AND ADDS
ADDITIONAL LABELING
REQUIREMENTS. I'M NOT SURE
GRAMOS TAMALES CAN SURVIVE ALL
OF THIS. WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO MAKE SURE THE FOOD
CALIFORNIANS PURCHASE NO MATTER
WHERE IT IS FROM A SAFE. AND
THE FACILITIES WORD IS PRODUCE
MEET THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS. BELIEVE ME THE
CITIES AND THE COUNTIES CAN
CERTAINLY OVERSEE. THIS BABY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN IS JUST
ANOTHER ATTEMPT. TO WRESTLE
LOCAL CONTROL AWAY FROM CITIES
IN OVER REGULATE A GROWING
INDUSTRY WHOSE ROOTS ARE BASED
IN HOME KITCHENS WE ALL GREW UP
IN. LET'S GIVE THE SMALL
ENTREPRENEURS IN OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN OPERON AN
OPPORTUNITY TO THRIVE. THESE
REASONS IN HONOR OF LOCAL
CONTROL THAT I'VE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED. PLEASE VOTE NO ONE
EIGHTY THREE SEVEN SEVEN. THANK
YOU CENTER STONE CENTER BOARD
IS A POINT OF CLARIFICATION
WITH THE FLOOR MANAGER OR
ANYONE ELSE WHO COULD OFFER
INSIGHT INTO THE CHAIR THROUGH
THE CHAIR. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN EVERY RESPECT OF
COUNTY THAT WE HAVE IS ALREADY
THE DULY AUTHORIZED ENTITY TO
ISSUE THE FOOD PERMIT. SO IT
UNLESS I'M MISTAKEN SIR
GORGEOUS I DIDN'T REALIZE IT
WAS TO BE A QUESTION SO CENTER
HER TAUGHT ARE YOU WILLING TO
TAKE THE QUESTION. ALL RIGHT
SHE SHE WELL IT NO. DID YOU.
GET OUT ON MY OWN TIME THEN
I'LL YES PUT THIS OUT. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE COUNTY IS
THE IS THE ENTITY THROUGH ITS
HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN OUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY SYSTEM THAT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ISSUING THE
PERMIT. AND SO IF UNLESS I
MISSED IT. EVERY COUNTY HAS TO
GIVE THE GREEN LIGHT TO THE MOM
AND POP OPERATIONS. SO IF
THAT'S THE CASE IT STILL IS
LOCAL CONTROL I FULLY SUPPORT
THE WHOLE NOTION OF THRIVING
HOME FOOD OPERATIONS AND SO I
WOULD EXPECT TO SUPPORT THIS.
KNOWING THAT THE COUNTY WOULD
HAVE TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
HOUSE. SO I DON'T SEE WHERE THE
CONTROVERSY IS ON THIS. THANK
YOU SIR BARGES. SEE NO OTHER
MIKE SUB CENTER TITLE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I VOTE.
WITH THAT MISTER SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL ALAN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. EIGHT NO BELL I PORGES
HI BRADFORD I COME HERE ALL. HI
CHENG I DELI. DOT HI I'D RATHER
I GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HILL I WAS SO. HIGHER TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES. LABOR I'M
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL HI MONEY.
BUY MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO
NELSON NO PAN. HI FORTINO BY
ROSS. HI REVIEW HI SKINNER. BY
STERN. STONE. NUMBER I ADDED BY
WHAT COUNTY. I WINNER I WILL
KNOW CENTER HER TADO MOVES THE
CALL. OUR STEAM TO SYSTEM
MAJORITY FLOOR LEADER HAS GIVEN
ME A NOTE THAT HE WANTED ME TO
PASS ON TO MEMBERS HE WANTED ME
TO REMIND YOU ALL THAT OUR
FLOOR UNIT IS WORKING VERY HARD
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
YOU TO PRESENT BILLS AND THAT
HE EXPECTS YOU TO BE PREPARED
WHEN YOUR TIME COMES UP. AND
WITH THAT TO MAKE IT EASIER I'M
GONNA LISTEN X. FIVE ITEMS THAT
ARE COMING BEFORE US FILE ITEM
TO ONE TWENTY FOUR. FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY NINE. FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE. ONE THIRTY THREE
AND ONE THIRTY SIX. HAVING SAID
THAT NEXT UP IS FILING ONE
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR JACKSON WHO
IS NOT AT HER DESK HELP HERE
SHE IS. ARE YOU PREPARED CENTER
JEFF. ALL RIGHT MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ONE TWENTY FOUR
YES SIR. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY
ONE BY A SEMI MEMBER GONZALEZ
AN ACT REALLY INTO EMPLOYMENT
CENTER JACKSON THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAN SOLACE TO PRESENT A
B. FIFTY ONE. OUR LEGISLATURES
PASSED SOME OF THE STRONGEST
WORKER PROTECTIONS IN THE
COUNTRY AGAINST SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PAY INEQUITY
DISCRIMINATION AND AGREE JUST
LABOR VIOLATIONS LIKE WAGE
THEFT. HOWEVER THOSE LAWS ARE
WORTHLESS IF THEY CANNOT BE
ENFORCED IN COURT OR BY STATE
AGENCIES BECAUSE AN EMPLOYER
HAS FORCED THEIR WORKERS TO
SIGN AWAY THEIR RIGHTS IN
ARBITRATION AGREEMENT.
MANDATING THAT EMPLOYEES GO TO
ARBITRATION IS A PRACTICE WHICH
ALLOWS COMPANIES TO FORCE
EMPLOYEE COMPLAINTS INTO
SECRETIVE HEARINGS WITHOUT ANY
COURT OVERSIGHT OR PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT. WHICH HIDES LABOR
VIOLATIONS FROM THE PUBLIC.
PROTECTS OUR SERIAL OFFENDERS
AND ULTIMATELY SILENCES
VICTIMS. SINCE THE RISE OF THE
ME TOO MOVEMENT WE'VE CONTINUED
TO CITY WORKERS WHO'VE BEEN
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
DISCRIMINATION ON THE JOB.
SPEAK OUT AGAINST US THIS
FORCED OUR RATIONS. EXCUSE ME.
FOR INSTANCE THROUGH COLLECTIVE
ACTION WORKERS SHOULD GOOGLE
EARLIER THIS YEAR WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN ENSURING THE
COMPANY ENDED ITS PRACTICE OF
MANDATING ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS NOW WE KNOW
ARBITRATION CAN BE A HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
TOOL WHEN BOTH PARTIES CHOOSING
FREELY AND HAVE EQUAL
BARGAINING POWER. IT IS FAR
LESS SUCCESSFUL HOWEVER WHEN
ONE PARTY'S ABILITY TO EARN A
LIVING DEPENDS ON SIGNING AN
AGREEMENT TO WAIVE THEIR
STATUTORY RIGHTS THAT IS WHY AB
FIFTY ONE IS A NARROWLY CRAFTED
BILL TO SIMPLY REQUIRE THAT
EMPLOYEES ARE ABLE TO CHOOSE
THE SITE TO SIGN SUCH
AGREEMENTS WITHOUT THE THREAT
OF JOB LOSS OR RETALIATION. THE
BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT
EMPLOYERS FROM USING THESE
AGREEMENTS TO RESOLVE WORKPLACE
THE DISPUTE BUT IT THE BILL
EXPRESSLY STATES IT'S NOT
INTENDED TO INVALIDATE EXIST
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS THAT ARE
OTHERWISE ENFORCEABLE OR REPLY
TO POSTS DISPUTE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS WERE NEGOTIATED
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS. TRUST.
REQUIRED THAT THE EMPLOYEE HAVE
A CHOICE WHEN IT COMES TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL BECOME
AN EMPLOYEE OF THAT COMPANY OR
CONTINUE IS SUCH THAT IT IS NOT
A FAIR AND EQUAL BARGAINING
POSITION. AND THAT IS THE
REASON THIS BILL IS BEFORE YOU
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER JACKS IN ANY FURTHER
DEBATER DISCUSSION SENATOR
STONE. THE PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I RISE
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AB
FIFTY ONE FIRST OF ALL. THIS
BILL VIOLATES FEDERAL LAW THE
U. S. COURT OF APPEALS AS WELL
AS THE U. S. SUPREME COURT. HAS
ESTABLISHED THIS RULING THAT
ALL STATES MUST FOLLOW FEDERAL
ARBITRATION ACT WHICH SIMPLY
PUT. PROHIBITS ANY STATE
STATUTE THAT SIX INTERFERE WITH
LIMIT. OR DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
ARBITRATION. THAT SEEMS PRETTY
CLEAR TO ME. IF WE PASS A B.
FIFTY ONE IT WILL BE INEVITABLE
THAT IT WILL FACE LITIGATION.
IF YOU WANT TO PASS A POLICY
LIKE THIS IT MUST HAPPEN AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR THE MORE.
THIS MEASURE COULD VERY WELL
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON LOW
WAGE WORKERS WHO'D BE FORCED TO
HIRE A TRIAL ATTORNEY. TO
SETTLE THEIR DISPUTES. ANY
POLICY THAT MAKES IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR EMPLOYERS TO USE
PRIVATE AND CONTRACTUAL
ARBITRATION. CLEARLY IS NOT
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE PICTURE.
BY DOING THIS TRIAL LAWYERS
WOULD INCREASE THEIR BUSINESS
AND OFFICE AT THE EXPENSE OF
LET IT. WHO WOULD HAVE TO PAY
MORE TIME IN THE PAST TO SETTLE
ANY DISPUTES. VIOLATES FEDERAL
LAW IT WOULD BE A GRAVE
DISADVANTAGE TO. LOW WAGE
WORKERS THAT MANY OF YOU
PROFESS TO WANT TO HELP I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE ON
THE B. FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU
CENTER STONE SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I AM
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL THIS BILL NOT ONLY
IS A ISSUE TO LIMIT. LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS AGAINST AN EMPLOYER
FOR FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION BUT IT
IS ALSO IS A BILL THAT WILL
EXPAND PAGA THE PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION THAT IS DETRIMENTAL
TO BUSINESS IN THIS STATE. SO
MANY CASES IN THE STATE THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND OF ACTUALLY BEEN
FILED AGAINST EMPLOYERS IN THE
STATE IN CAUSING AS TO BE NOT
RATED NUMBER ONE IS THE
LITIGATION HELL HOLE OF THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES I SO THIS
BILL HAS A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPAND THAT AGAINST. JOB
CREATORS IN THIS STATE WHERE
THE EMPLOYEES ARE NOT THE
WINNERS OF THESE ACTIONS DEBTOR
FILED ITS JUST THE TRIAL
LAWYERS THAT ARE THE WINNERS OF
THESE ACTIONS THAT DEBT
ACTUALLY GET LARGE. AMOUNTS OF
SETTLEMENTS SO MUCH SO THAT
EVEN A BILL WAS PASSED A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO TO EXEMPT TO
PEOPLE IN A CONTRACT LABOR
AGREEMENT OR PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT BECAUSE CONTRACT LAW
SUPERSEDES THE LABOR LAW AND
EXEMPTED IT WHICH CREATES AN
UNFAIR AND UNEQUAL PROTECTION
UNDER THE LAW. THIS BILL THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION AGAINST
TEMP YOURS IS JUST IN THE WAY.
THAT I'M A FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION
BE FILED IN THIS. TRYING TO
PULL UP A WEBSITE WHERE.
THEY'VE LISTED ALL THESE
ATTORNEYS AND ALL THE CASES
THEY HAVE A STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MEAN ONE ATTORNEY HAS SEVEN
THOUSAND CASES AGAINST
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S NOT ABOUT
THE CASE THERE'S NO WAY THEY
HAVE THE PERSONNEL IN THAT IN
THAT OFFICE TO REPRESENT. SEVEN
THOUSAND PLAINTIFFS BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THESE
PEOPLE ARE JUST LOOKING FOR THE
SETTLEMENT BECAUSE THE
PENALTIES ARE SO HIGH AND
THERE'S NO JUDICIAL DISCRETION
AND AUTHORITY FOR THESE
PENALTIES TO BE WAIVED OR
REMOVED AND THE POTENTIAL THE
PENALTIES ARE JUST ASTRONOMICAL
AND THEY'RE REALLY NOT EVEN
AFTER A- DISPUTED ISSUE LIKE
WAGING OUR MEAL AND REST PERIOD
WHETHERYOU SIGN AN ARBITRATION
AGREEMENT WHERE YOU'RE ASKED
THE DAY BEFORE THE DAY HAVE.
ANYTHING LIKE THAT THEY'RE
AFTER YOUR PAYCHECK STUBS WHERE
THEY GET HUGE PENALTIES ON
PERIODS COMMAS DASHES AND DATES
I SEE MY COLLEAGUE ON THE
THAT'S THE JOCKEY OF THIS BILL
SHAKING HER HEAD BELIEVE ME I
OPERATE IN THE BUSINESS WORLD
IN THE REAL WORLD AND- OUR.
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND PAGA
CASES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE TRACK. THE
DETRIMENTAL TO EMPLOYEES AT
ONLY PASS THE- LINING OF. IS
THAT PROCESS. THIS BILL IS THE
SAME THING IT PRIVATE ACTION
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS IT'S NOT
ASKING AN EMPLOYEE TO WAIVE
THEIR RIGHTS OR TO GET RID OF
ANYTHING THEY STILL HAVE THE
ODD THE OPPORTUNITY TO FILE A
LAWSUIT IF THEY ARE WRONG IN
THE CASE OF AN EMPLOYER THAT IS
DOING SOMETHING WRONG THESE
EMPLOYEES STILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FILE THEY JUST
CAN'T BUY A WITH A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION WHICH REALLY
SHOULD BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BECAUSE IT'S A SEPARATION OF
POWERS WHEN YOU HAVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND WHAT THIS
PARTICULAR LOT DID SEVERAL
YEARS AGO IS GO OUT DEPUTISE
OFFSEASON QUALIFIED PEOPLE TO
BE ATTORNEYS TO FILE LAWSUITS
SO THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS
WITH THIS P. SOLICIT
LEGISLATION I WOULD ASK YOU JOB
CREATORS NOT ANY SUCCEED. IN
THIS. AND ASK FOR A NEW VOTE.
YOU GROW UP TO SEE WHETHER MIKE
SET A CENTER JACKSON YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT AS A LAWYER. ONE WHO
PRACTICED LAW FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS. WHO HAS NOTHING BUT
RESPECT FOR THE JUDICIAL
PROCESS AS WE ALL SHOULD SINCE
IT IS A CO EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT I FIND MYSELF
SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATED BY HEARING
FROM THE EXPERTISE BY MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM TO MACULA WHOSE
PHARMACEUTICAL KNOWLEDGE I DO
NOT QUESTION BUT WHOSE LEGAL
SKILLS I WOULD QUESTION.
BECAUSE AS A LAWYER. IS SOMEONE
WHO HAS SPENT TWENTY TWO YEARS
IN THE COURTROOM I HAVE GREATER
CONFIDENCE IN OUR COURTS. ANY
EXPERIENCE GOES WITH IT AS I
THINK EVERY OTHER MEMBER OF
THIS HALL DOES WHO HAS
PRACTICED LAW. YOU KNOW WE CALL
TRIAL LAWYER LAWYERS THE BOOGIE
MAN HERE BUT THE FACT IS THAT
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA HAS ONE
OF THE TOUGHEST THING HIGHEST
BARS WHEN IT COMES TO FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS WE PROTECT AGAINST
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS BETTER THAN
ALMOST ANY OTHER STATE IN THE
COUNTRY. IF A FRIVOLOUS LAWSUIT
IS FILED IT IS GOING TO BE
THROWN OUT OF COURT. OUR JUDGES
RECOGNIZE TRUTH FROM FICTION
AND WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE TRUTH
FROM FICTION WITH THIS BILL.
BECAUSE WHAT IS THIS BILL DO.
THIS BILL IS IN ABOUT A
SEPARATION OF POWERS ANOTHER
INTERESTING ISSUE THAT HAS NO
NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS BILL.
THIS BILL HAS TO DO WITH
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
EMPLOYEES. YOU KNOW WE SIT HERE
AND WE MAKE ALL THESE LAWS
THINGS TO PROTECT AGAINST
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THANKS TO
PROTECT AGAINST WAGE THERE
THANKS TO PROTECT AGAINST THE
ABUSES THAT DO INDEED AND WE
ALL KNOW EXIST. IN THE
RELATIONSHIP SADLY BETWEEN
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS NOT EVERY
WORKER NOT EVERY EMPLOYER BUT
TO THE EXTENT WE KNOW THERE ARE
COMPANIES THAT DO NOT DO WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO WE HEAR SIT
ON THIS FLOOR AND PASS LAWS. TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEES. THIS IS A
BILL THAT TALKS ABOUT KEEPING
THAT PLAYING FIELD LEVEL FOR
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE IF THE
EMPLOYEES ARE FORCED TO GO INTO
ARBITRATION WE KNOW THAT THAT
PROCESS IS SECRETIVE. WE KNOW
THAT THAT THAT THE ARBITRATORS
DO NOT HAVE TO ABIDE BY ANY
LOSS OF EVIDENCE. THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE TO GIVE YOU A WRITTEN
EXPLANATION AND THE ABILITY TO
APPEAL IS ALMOST NON EXISTENT.
AS SOMEONE WHO IS GOING TO WORK
FOR A COMPANY. YOU SHOULD BE
HIRED ON THE BASIS OF YOUR
QUALIFICATIONS AND NOT REJECTED
BECAUSE YOU DO NOT WISH TO SIGN
AWAY YOUR RIGHTS. THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT SO I
WOULD APPRECIATE IF WOULD BE
CLEAR ON THAT AND NOT GOING
THROUGH THAT OLD TIRESOME MEME
ABOUT PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
AND BLAH BLAH BLAH NOT
EVERYBODY IS GOING TO GO TO A
LAWYER AND FRANKLY. YOU KNOW
SOME OF US IN THIS ROOM ARE
LAWYERS WE'RE NOT GONNA BITE
ANYBODY'S HEAD OFF. WE LOOK AT
OUR JOB IS PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF THOSE WHO OTHERWISE.
ARE NOT GOING TO BE PROTECTED
BY IMPLEMENTING THE LAWS THAT
WE STAND HERE ON THE FLOOR AND
DO OVER AND OVER AGAIN ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT A REMEDY. IS
NO RIGHT AT ALL. WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE IS GIVING
PEOPLE THE CHOICE WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WANT TO ENTER INTO
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS OR NOT.
THIS IS NOT A CONSTITUTIONAL
PROBLEM. WELL I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME WHO WOULD ARGUE THAT
THIS BILL WAS VERY NARROWLY
CRAFTED. IT DOESN'T DEEM
WAIVERS INVOLUNTARY
UNCONSCIONABLE AGAINST PUBLIC
POLICY OR UNENFORCEABLE AND IT
MAKES NO ALTERATION TO THE
EXISTING BURDEN OF PROOF. IN A
DISPUTE OVER ENFORCEABILITY OF
A WAIVER I COULD GO ON AND ON
AND BORE THE HECK ARE YOU.
TALKING ABOUT LEGAL ISSUES BUT
NOT HERE MAKES ENOUGH MONEY PER
HOUR TO GET INTO THAT ADULT.
STUFF I SHOULD TO SAY IT IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION. YEAH
RIGHT. IF THIS WERE A
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE THEN THE
ISSUE WILL BE RAISED IN COURT
MY ASK OF YOU IS TO LOOK AT
WHAT THIS BILL TRIES TO DO IT
TRIES TO PROTECT EMPLOYEES SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE A VOLUNTARY
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WANT TO ENTER INTO AN
ARBITRATION PROCESS WHEN AND-
IF. THEY HAVE A DISPUTE WITH
THEIR EMPLOYER. WITH THAT I
WOULD ACTUALLY ASKED FOR YOUR
IPHONE. CENTER JACKSON ARE YOU
DONE. SURGERY IS WAS AT YOUR
THIS OUT YOUR CLOSE OKAY WITH
THAT MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA ATKINS.
EIGHT NOBEL. HI GORGEOUS NO
BRADFORD I CARRY IT ALL. CHANGE.
DELHI NO DOT. HI THERE ALSO I
GOT JOHNNY I GLAZER. GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HI
HILL I WAS SO TIRED TACO.
JACKSON HEIGHTS JONES NO LLEVA
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL BY
MORNING I'M MORE LOCK NO RAIL.
NO NELSON NO PAN. FORTINO. PAN
I FORTINO I ROUGH. RUBIO
SKINNER. BY STERN I STONE NO
BERG. I WORK OUT SKI I WINNER.
WILL NO. THE SENATOR MOVES THE
CALL MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY NINE SENATOR BELL
ARE YOU PREPARED AND YOU ARE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SOME OF
THE ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY A SOME
IMMIGRATION AN ACT REALLY IN
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY I MEAN
SENATOR BELL. TO READ IT.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS
BILL PROMOTES THE SMARTER
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
REQUIRING DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE JOINT
MEETINGS. BETWEEN THE CAL FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IT WILL HELP US
TO WORK OUT THE TRIPLE
CHALLENGE OF HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY LIMITING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
MAINTAINING OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURES. OUR DRIVER ON
THIS. THANK YOU SIR ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES HI
BILL HI BARGES. BRADFORD. I
CARRY IT OFF HI CHENG I. DELI.
DOT I HI DOT I. DELI KNOWN
DOURADO. I GOT JOHNNY I GLAZER.
GONZALES HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HI HILL HIGHWAY SO HIGHER TITLE.
HI JACKSON. BY JONES KNOWS
LABOR I'M ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
MONEY BUY MORE LOCK. BURRELL NO
NO SIN. BY PM. I FORTINO I ROTH
BY RUBIO BY SKINNER. I STERN BY
STONE. NOVEMBER HI KATHY HI
WINNER. WILK HI. CENTRE BELL
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO FIGHT
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE SENATOR
HILL HE'S PREPARED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FORTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER COOPER AN ACT RELATING
TO WORKERS COMPENSATION CENTER
HILL THE FLOOR SHORES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT AS
HEARD IN THE SENATE LABOR
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FORTY SIX WILL CORRECT IN AN
EQUITY IN EXISTING LAW WHERE
MOST ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS
RECEIVE A WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFIT UNDER LABOR CODE
SECTION FORTY EIGHT FIFTY AND
OTHER SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS DO
NOT. COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS A
FORTY FIFTY TIME THIS TEMPORARY
DISABILITY BENEFIT PROVIDES
POLICE OFFICERS WITH UP TO ONE
YEAR OF PAID LEAVE IF INJURED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY SCHOOL
POLICE OFFICERS MUST RISK THEIR
LIVES TO PREDICTIONS AND THEY
SHOULD BE PROVIDED WITH THE
SAME BENEFIT IF INJURED ON THE
JOB THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS. BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU SENATOR
THE NO FURTHER DEBATERS
QUESTION MR SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA BY
ADKINS BATES. BELL BY BURGESS.
BY BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL I
CHAIN I DELI I DOG HI TORONTO I
YEAH JOHNNY I GLAZER GONZALES.
HI GROVE I HURTS WHERE I HILL I
WHISTLE. HIGHER TITLE I JACKSON.
JONES HI. LABOR. HI JACKSON I
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. I'M
MOANING I'M MORE LOCK MERRELL.
MERRILL. HI NELSON FIVE PM I
PORTS DINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN I STONE. I
AMBERG OUR CASKEY I WINNER.
WILK BY. THE SENATOR MOVES THE
CALL MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY SIX SENATOR UMBERG ARE
YOU PREPARED YOU ARE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SYMBOL
FOR SIXTY THREE BY SOME MEMBERS
ON THIS WELL I DON'T WANT. IS
ME BUT YET YOU. STILL ME IS
STILL YOU. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTY FIVE BY ASSUMING MEMBER
DAILY ENAK RELATED TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF CURRENTLY
ALL BUT FOURTEEN OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCIES OR TO THE JURISDICTION
OF THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD KNOWN AS PER
HIS NEXT FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES
NOT COVERED BY PER LABOR
DISPUTES ARE OFTEN CONTESTS IN
COURT CAN BE COSTLY AND VERY
TIME CONSUMING FOR BOTH THE
EMPLOYER AS WELL AS EMPLOYEE.
BY CONTRAST PROBES EXPERTISE
LIBERALIZATION'S OFFERS
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES AN
EXPEDITIOUS AND COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVE TO ADJUDICATING
WORKPLACE DISPUTES THIS BILL IS
A SIMPLE BILL IT SIMPLY ADDS
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY LIST OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES ALREADY
COVERED BY PER. I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY OPPOSITION I OR DRIVE A.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG. ANY
FOR FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER MORLOCK. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY BOARD I KIND OF
PERPLEXED AT THE NECESSITY OF
THIS BILL EVEN THOUGH IT MIGHT
BE DEEMED AS SIMPLE AND HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IT JUST DOESN'T FIX
THE PROBLEM THERE'S NO PROBLEM
HERE IT DOESN'T EXIST. SO WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGES AT O. C. T.
EIGHT. FIVE I'M JUST KIND OF.
PERPLEXED BY IT ALL BUT- YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO REFER. THESE
ISSUES TO PER BUT YET THE.
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD IS
UNDERMANNED SO WHAT WHERE'S
THAT WHERE'S THE EFFICIENCY
THERE IT IT MAKES SENSE THAT
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED A SIMILAR
BILL. ON THIS ISSUE LAST YEAR
IT SAID SETTING UP THAT
SACRAMENTO IS HARD ON SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS BUT TO ENCUMBER
AND BURDEN OF TRANSPORTATION
DISTRICT IT IS TO ME SEEMS TO
BE POOR FORM AND AFTER YOU GO
THROUGH PER AND YOU'RE STILL
NOT SETTLED YOU STILL GO BACK
TO SUPERIOR COURT SO WHAT HAVE
WE GAINED SO WITH THAT MISTER
PRESIDENT I. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE NO VOTE ON A. B.
THREE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU SIR
MORLOCK SCANNING THE FLOOR SNOW
FOR THEIR BIKES SO CENTER AMBER
YOU MAY CLOSE. I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEGE COM THE COMMENTS FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY I
AM NOT AWARE THE ORANGE K.
TRISTES. DISEASE OPPOSE THE
BILL I WOULD URGE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WITH
THAT MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. NO BELL HI PORGES NO
BRADFORD. I CARRY IT OFF. HI
CHENG I. DELI NO DOG I'D RATHER.
I GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER.
GONZALES HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI HILL I WAS SO. HI
TADO. HI JACKSON BY JONES. NO
LABOR TIME ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL
HI MONICA. I'M MORE LUCK NO
MORALE NO NELSON NO PAN HI
FORTINO. HI ROTH I RUBIO BY
SKINNER BY STERN BY STONE. NO
BERG IRAQ OWSKI HI WINNER. WELL
NO. CENTER BIRD MOVES THE CALL
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON UNTIL FIVE
FILE IN ONE THIRTY SIX FIRST
TEAM TO SYSTEM IT. OKAY
TEMPORARY PASS ON FILE I NOW
I'M GONNA GIVE OUT THE NEXT
FIVE ITEMS WILL BE DOING BY
LIGHT AND ONE FORTY ONE. ONE
FORTY FOUR ONE FIFTY THREE ONE
FIFTY EIGHT AND FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY NINE. INVALID ONE.
FORTY ONE. IS SENATOR ARCHULETA.
CENTER ARE SHORT ARE YOU
PREPARED. AND SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ
. OKAY
MISTER SMITH SECRETARY PLEASE
RE FILE I'M ONE FORTY SOME BILL
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN BY SOME NEW
MEMBER CALLED ROOM AND ACT
REALLY INTO INSURANCE. CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. ON BEHALF OF THE
MAJORITY LEADER CALDERON I'M
PRESENTING AB FIVE SIX SEVEN
MAYBE FIVE SIX SEVEN ESTABLISH
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE TASK
FORCE CONVENED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE PURPOSE OF THE
TASK FORCE YOU TO PROVIDE
EXPERT RECOMMENDATIONS THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER THE
LEGISLATORS. AND THE GOVERNOR
ON COMPONENTS NECESSARY TO
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE PROGRAM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA GIVEN THE GROWING
RECOGNITION OF CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFTS IT IS AN
OPPORTUNE TIME TO IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES AVAILABLE TO CHART A
SUCCESSFUL PATH TO LONG TERM
CARE STABILITY AND FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOAT.
THANK YOU SAID ARCHULETA ANY
FOR THE DEBATERS QUESTION
CENTER BOARD IS CALLED MORLOCK
SORRY. PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT YOU'RE DOING A- GOOD
JOB. I IT MISTER RICH PRESIDENT
THAT THE QUESTION COMES UP WHY
CANNOT THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER PUT TOGETHER HIS
OWN COMMITTEE WHY DOES IT TAKE
LEGISLATION WHY DO WE THINK
ABOUT MAYBE EMPOWERING THE
STATE AUDITOR OR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
MAYBE DO MORE OF THESE STUDIES
WERE GETTING A LOT OF BILLS
THIS YEAR THAT IS JUST YOU KNOW
PUTTING A LOT OF MANPOWER
TOGETHER PUTTING A LOT OF.
RESOURCES TOGETHER WHEN MAYBE
YOU WE HAVE ALL THE ABILITY TO
DO IT WITH OUR OWN STAFFING AND
EXPERTISE OR EVEN OUTSOURCING
IT THROUGH THOSE DEPARTMENTS SO
I'M I'M JUST BRINGING IT UP
MISTER PRESIDENT IS A CONCERN
ON HOW WE'RE ADDING TO OUR
BUDGET INCREMENTALLY AND WE
SHOULD BE TAKING A HARDER LOOK
I BELIEVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR ARE LIKE ANY OTHER FURTHER
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEE NOW I
MISS ARCHER LET US AN ARCH LET
ME MAKE CLOTHES I RESPECT FOR
YA AS FOR THE I. BOAT. THANK
YOU SIR MISTER SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL ALAN. BYERS LETTER I
ATKINS BAIT NOBEL. HI BURGESS
NO BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL. HI
JANE I DALLY. DOT HI TORONTO I
GOT JOHNNY. BY GLAZER. GONZALES
I GROW. HERTZBERG BY HILL I WAS
SO TIRED TADO. JACKSON HI JONES
NO LLEVA I'M ACQUIRE. MITCHELL
BY MONEY. BUY MORE LARK NO
MORALE. NO NELSON. NO PAN. HI
CHRISTINA HI ROSS. I REVIEW. HI
SKINNER. BY STERN BY STONE NO
NUMBER. I WORK OUT SEE I WINNER.
WILK HI BY. CENTER MOVES THE
CALL NOW MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR
CENTER MONEY HE'S PREPARED TO
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SOME OF THE SIX SEVENTY THREE
BY A SEMI MEMBER CORIO AN ACT
RELATING TO IMPLEMENT THEIR
MONEY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB SIX SEVENTY THREE
WILL PROVIDE AN EFFECTIVE
REMEDY FOR WORKERS WHO ARE NOT
PAID THEIR WAGES ON TIME FAR
TOO OFTEN CALIFORNIA WORKERS
ESPECIALLY IN LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES ARE FORCED TO WAIT
DAYS WEEKS OR EVEN MONTHS FOR
THEIR HARD EARNED WAGES. IN
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES THESE
EMPLOYEES WITH LIMITED OPTIONS
TO SEEK FINANCIAL RELIEF A B.
SIX SEVEN THREE WE'LL PROVIDE
WORKERS A CLEAR PATH OF
RECOURSE BY ALLOWING THEM TO
SEEK LATE PAYMENT PENALTIES
AGAINST THEIR EMPLOYER IN A
HEARING BEFORE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER MANY CALIFORNIANS
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND
DISTURBING EFFECTIVE
INEXPEDIENT REMEDY. WHEN THEIR
HARD EARNED PAY. WE'LL PROVIDE
THAT RECOURSE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR MONEY ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY RISE
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL AND WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER ON THE FLOOR I HAVE A
DEEP RESPECT FOR HIM BUT THE
TALKING POINTS YOU PROVIDED ARE
TOTALLY INACCURATE AND NOT
TRUE. AND THE REASON WHY I SAY
THAT IS BECAUSE THERE IS A
REMEDY UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING IN THE
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
BOARD FOR ANYONE TO FILE A
LAWSUIT INCLUDING A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION TO WHERE THEY
CAN BE THEIR OWN ATTORNEY TO
FILE A LAWSUIT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY'RE
EXPEDITIOUSLY IS HEARD IN THERE
ARE PROBABLY TWENTY ATTORNEYS
IN THE STATE WOULD TAKE THAT
PRO BONO AND FILE A LAWSUIT ON
BEHALF OF THEM INCLUDING THE
CONTRACTOR THE SUBCONTRACTOR
THE PRIME CONTRACTOR AND
EVERYBODY ELSE INVOLVED AND
ENGAGED IN THAT EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL
TO HAVE A JOB. AND THERE IS
ALREADY LIKE I SAID AT OF HUGE
REMEDY OF ACCESS TO RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO'S GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVE A JOB TO FILE
ANY GRIEVANCE WHATSOEVER AT NO
COST TO THEM. IS THAT A
QUESTION. COME IN OKAY SIR HAVE
A GREAT DAY. VICKI CENTER GROVE
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE CENTER.
SENATOR OSEM SORRY. I DO WANT
TO SPEAK FROM THE REAL WORLD OF
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO LIVE WORK AND
MANY MANY INDUSTRIES WHERE.
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN SIMPLY
TRIED TO GET PAID. THE MINIMUM
WAGE AND MAYBE SOME OVERTIME
THERE ARE BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
AND I MEAN THAT WITH THE BIG B.
OF DOLLARS IN WAGE THEFT IN THE
STATE BILLIONS THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN NEVER RECOVER. THE
MINIMUM WAGE THAT THEY HAVE
COMING TO THEM WAGE THEFT IS A
VERY MASSIVE PROBLEM IN THIS
STATE IN MANY INDUSTRIES. WE
WERE JUST ABLE. SENATOR
MITCHELL THE NIGHT THROUGH THE
BUDGET ABLE TO HELP. A SMALL
GROUP OF GARMENT WORKERS WHO
HAD NOT BEEN PAID AFTER THEY
HAD GOTTEN THE DECISION IN
THEIR FAVOR. WOULD NEVER PAID.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT SMALL
COMPARED TO EVERYTHING THAT
GOES ON IN THIS STATE EVERY
SINGLE DAY ANYTHING THAT WE
COULD DO TO HELP THOSE MEN AND
WOMEN RECOVER REMEMBER MINIMUM
WAGE. AND MAY BE OVER TIME IT
IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO DO SO
I STAND IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO SENATOR LLEVA.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
TOO HAVE TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
WHEN I WAS IN THE REAL WORLD
REPRESENTING WORKERS AND WHEN I
WAS AN HOURLY WORKER MYSELF I
USED TO SAY TO PEOPLE LOOK AT
YOUR PAYSTUB BECAUSE BY
ACCIDENT OR BY DESIGN MANY
TIMES EMPLOYERS DO NOT PAY
THEIR EMPLOYEES PROPERLY AND IF
YOU DO NOT CALL THEM ON IT
THOSE LOST WAGES ADD UP TO BEES
BILLIONS WITH A CAPITAL B. AND
IF YOU LOOK AT MOST PAY STUBS
NOW. OVER THE YEARS WE'VE SEEN
IT CHANGE IT USED TO DEALING IN
A WHAT YOU WERE BEING PAID FOR
NOW IT'S JUST ONE WAGE AND IT
MAKES IT MUCH HARDER FOR
WORKERS TO DETERMINE IF THEY
WERE PAID CORRECTLY SPECIALLY
FOR HOURLY WORKERS ESPECIALLY
FOR WORKERS WHO ARE PAID
MINIMUM WAGE. ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO MAKE SURE THAT WORKERS
ARE PAID WHAT THEY'RE OWED IT'S
OUR OBLIGATION TO DO IT AND IF
NOT US WHO AND IF NOT WHEN NOW.
WHEN I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR LEVEL SEEING NO
FURTHER MIKE'S NOTHER MIKE UP
CENTER AROUND. THANK YOU.
MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD JOB BY
THE WAY. WE LIKE BRADFORD
BETTER BUT HEY. ANYWAY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. YEAH I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS FIELD HI I GUESS ALL OF
US HAS WORKED IN THE WORLD REAL
WORLD BUT YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS. THIS BODY SEEMS
TO BEAT UP AND THINK EVERY
EMPLOYER WANTS TO SCREW SOMEONE
OVER I GOT A K. I AM I GET
TIRED OF HEARING AT THE SAME
OLD. SONG THAT YOU GUYS SAYING
HERE ONE OF THE REASONS HE'S
TRUCKERS ARE HAWKING OR HORNS
OUT HERE IS BECAUSE THEY ARE
HAPPY WITH THIS BODY. FOR THE
LAWS THAT ARE BEING PASSED HERE
YOU GUYS SEEM TO BE EMBRACING
SOCIALISM AND GOVERNMENT SEEMS
TO THINK THAT THEY CAN PUSH
BUSINESSES AROUND AND THAT'S.
REPORTS BY THE HOOVER INSTITUTE
ANOTHER BAD BILL OF MANY IT'S
WRONG AND I JUST WANT EXPRESS
MY OPINIONS HERE. AND I'M GOING
TO VOTE NO THANK YOU. VEGAS
EMERIL CENTER BATES. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT YES YOU'RE
DOING A GOOD JOB AND I DO LIKE
YOU HEAR MY SEAT MAXELL. ANYWAY
ARM WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
EMPLOYERS IN MY DISTRICT IS
WHAT IS REALLY TROUBLING WHEN
THEY MAKE AN HONEST MISTAKE AND
I DON'T LIKE TO THINK THAT
EVERY EMPLOYER ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SCREEN THEIR EMPLOYEES HANDED
THEY'RE BEGINNING TO BE SO
BURDENED BY THESE PAGO LAWSUITS
AND THEY HAVE NO WAY OUT AND
I'D LIKE TO QUOTE THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM SANTA BARBARA WHO
SAID A RIGHT WITHOUT A REMEDY
IS NO RIGHT AT ALL WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT EMPLOYERS HAVE
NO RIGHT TO REMEDY. BEFORE THEY
ARE HIT WITH THESE MASSIVE PAGO
LOSSES SO I THINK WE NEED TO
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AS
WE SEE MORE AND MORE OF THESE
BILLS COMING FORWARD THAT PUT
THE BALANCE IN THE HANDS OF THE
EMPLOYEES AND I BELIEVE
EMPLOYEES WANT THEIR MONEY ON
TIME IF THEY COULD GO TO AN
EMPLOYER IN THERE WITH A REMEDY
THAT WAS VERY QUICK AND FAST
ALL THOSE CORRECTIONS WILL BE
MADE IMMEDIATELY BUT INSTEAD
THE INTERFERENCE OF THE PAGO
LAWSUITS GET IN THE WAY WITH
BIG PROMISES YOU KNOW YOU
DIDN'T GET YOUR FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLAR CHECK BUT IF YOU WORK
WITH ME YOU'LL GET FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
ON OUT THERE AND WE CANNOT DENY
THAT SO I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE ON
THE US AND I'D LIKE US TO TAKE
A REALLY LONG HARD LOOK AT THE
THOUGH I CHARTERED THE
AUTHORITIES THAT WE HAVE GIVEN
TO PRAGUE AND MAYBE RETHINK
THAT. THANK YOU I URGE NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BATES. SEEING NO
OTHER MIKES UP. THEIR MONEY YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT. WELL I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE COLLEAGUES WHO ROSE TO
ADDRESS THIS I DO WANT TO OFFER
SOME CORRECTIONS. TO MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
SUGGESTING THAT. THIS ISN'T
NECESSARY BECAUSE THE LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES FOR IT
ACTUALLY. TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
MINORITY CAUCUS THIS PROVIDES
AN ALTERNATIVE TO A PAGA
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO
RECOVER UNPAID WAGES I WOULD
ALSO SUBMIT. THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT AFFECT LAW ABIDING
EMPLOYERS THIS BILL IS DESIGNED
TO GO AFTER AN EMPLOYER WHO
DOESN'T PAY WAGES TO THEIR
EMPLOYEE AND IT PROVIDES AN
ADMINISTRATIVE REMEDY SO THAT
THE EMPLOYEE WOULD RECEIVE THE
PENALTY THAT IS ALREADY IN LAW
CURRENTLY ASSESSED BY THE
STATE. THE PENALTY CURRENTLY
GOES TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
NOT TO THE EMPLOYEE WHO IN MANY
CASES HAS GONE WEEKS MONTHS OR
MULTIPLE MONTHS WITHOUT GETTING
THEIR LOW INCOME WAGES THAT ARE
OWED TO THEM SO WHAT THIS BILL
SIMPLY DOES IS GONNA REMOVE
FEWER CASES FROM A PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION AND A PAGA.
REMEDY TO AN ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDY AND INSTEAD OF THE
PENALTY THAT IS ALREADY
ASSESSED GOING TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL DIRECTS
THAT PENALTY THAT WORKER WHO
DIDN'T GET PAID AFTER DUE
PROCESS IS AFFORDED TO THE
EMPLOYER TO MAKE THEIR CASE. IN
OUR COMMISSIONER CAN DETERMINE.
WHETHER OR NOT AND BOARD YES.
IT PROVIDES FOR. THOSE REASONS
I WOULD JOIN THOSE WHO ARE
LOOKING OUT HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ENERGY HERE I VOTE.
THANK YOU SAID OR MONEY WITH
THAT MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ALAN. ARCHULETA ATKINS.
TAKES. BATES NOBEL HI PORGES NO.
PARTS THAT I. BRADFORD HI
CARRIE YELLOW HI CHENG. NO
DALLY NO DODD. I DOURADO I GOT
JOHNNY HI GLAZER. GONZALES BY
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. BY HILL.
WESSEL BUYER TADO I JACKSON I
JONES NO LLEVA I AM A CHOIR.
MITCHELL. HI MONEY BY MORE LOCK
NO MORALE NO NO ST. NO PAN. HI
PORCH DINO BY ROSS HI RUBY OF.
SKINNER STERN. STONE NO NUMBER.
IA CATHY HI WINNER. WELL NO NO.
THE CENTER PUTS THAT ON CALL
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO FILE ON
ONE FIFTY THREE. SEEMS TO ME OR
BEAT WE'RE LIVE WITH A LITTLE
CHIPPY THIS MORNING CONSIDERING
WE GOT A LONG WAY TO GO AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT THE BODY WOULD
IN BRACE THE CHERUB LIKE
DEMEANOR THAT I HAVE UP HERE AT
THE DANCE. AND BE KIND TO ONE
ANOTHER WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON THE FILE AT A. ONE
FIFTY THREE CENTER HERTZBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ. A
SUM OF ALL TEN NINETY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER PONCA RUBIO AND
ACT REALLY NO WATER QUALITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WITH
KINDNESS AND GRACIOUSNESS
MISTER PRESIDENT I ASKED YOU TO
TURN YOUR ATTENTION TO A BILL
BY THE OTHER RUBIO OF THE OTHER
HOUSE. THIS MEASURE DEALS WITH
STORM WATER SYSTEM COMPLIANCE
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T MAKE THE
FRONT PAGE OF THE BIGGEST
NEWSPAPERS IN THE STATE. BUT
SOMETHING THAT IS QUITE
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US. THE
STATE AUDITOR RECENTLY
CONCLUDED THAT WATER BOARDS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO COMPLY
WITH THE FEDERAL CLEAN WATER
ACT BUT THEY HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ADEQUATE GUIDANCE FOR ASSESSING
THE COST OF DOING SO. FOR THOSE
REPRESENT CITIES YOU KNOW ALL
THESE FINES COULD BE QUITE
HEFTY. THE RESULT IS THAT LOCAL
DEAREST JURISDICTIONS DON'T
HAVE A COMPLETE INFORMATION
WHEN ESTABLISHING THEIR
RESPECTIVE PLANS AMONG THEIR-
SCOPE AND THEIR THEIR OF THE
UNIVERSE IN THE UNDER A SEQUEL
UNDER HIS BITTER LAUGH KOS. AB
TEN NINETY THREE CORRECT THIS
BY REQUIRING THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO ESTABLISH FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY ASSESSMENT
GUIDELINES FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES DEGREES SMALLER
COUNTIES IN TO COMPLY WITH THE
FEDERAL CLEAN WATER ACT.
CERTAINLY HOLD OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MADE A BIG EFFORT
TO DO SO. WITH MUCH THIS IS A-
RATHER. IT INCORPORATES THESE
COST ASSESSMENTS DETERMINING
ALTERNATIVE COMPLIANCE. WITH
THESE AND RETRIEVAL SCHEDULES
FOR PERMIT TO USE IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH
I ASK FOR. YOUR SUPPORT FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO'S MAY.
THANKS TEN HERTZ BERG ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY OF
THE ROLE ALAN. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL I
PURCHASED BY BRADFORD I CAN BE
AT ALL HI CHAIN BY DAILY I DOG
I'D RATHER GO I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW BY
HERZBERG. I HILL. SO BY TADO I
JACKSON HI JONES BY LABOR I AM
A CHOIR. MITCHELL HI MONEY BY
MORE LOCK I'M A REAL HI NELSON.
I PAN HI FORTINO HI ROB. HI
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN DOWN I
AMBERG. IA CATHY BYE WINNER.
WILK HI CENTER HERTZBERG MOVES
THE CALL NOW WE MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT ONCE AGAIN
SENATOR HERTZBERG FLORES YEARS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE. READ A
SIMILAR BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY TWO
BY A SEMI MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
ACTUALLY INTO ELECTRICITY
CENTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH SOME REMEMBER
O'DONNELL. I RISE IN SUPPORT
AND TO PRESENT A B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY TWO. FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS WE HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WITH
AFFORDABILITY RELIABILITY D.
CARBONIZATION WHICH ARE CORE
PRINCIPLES OF OUR ENERGY POLICY
IT HAS BEEN CHALLENGING AS WE
HAVE SET THESE NEW STANDARDS ON
THE ONE HAND AND TRIED TO PUT
THE PRACTICAL TOOLS AVAILABLE.
INTO IMPLEMENTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SYSTEM CONTINUES TO
WORK IN A FAIR AND EQUITABLE
WAY. AT THE SAME TIME AS A
RESULT OF ALL THIS EFFORT NEW
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES HAVE
GIVEN RATE PAYERS MORE OPTIONS
FOR ENERGY DELIVERY THAN EVER
BEFORE WE SEEN THE TREMENDOUS
GROWTH. OF THE CCA'S STARTING
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE WHEN THE
SOME WE'VE EVER MAKE DINNER TO
USE THEM AND THERE'S BEEN A
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGE IN HOW
ENERGY IS DELIVERED. IN ORDER
TO FACILITATE THIS ROBUST AND
COMPETITIVE MARKET FROM ALL
THESE DIVERSE ENERGY SOURCES
CUSTOMERS NEED FULL ACCESS TO
ACCURATE PRICING INFORMATION
AND OTHER PROGRAM OFFERINGS.
THIS MEASURE PROVIDE WILL
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION BY
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION THE POST
TO THEIR WEBSITE ACCURATE AND
NON BIASED INFORMATION
CONSERVING CONCERNING A LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES ELECTRICITY
RATES. AND ENERGY PORTFOLIOS IN
THE WOODS HOW MUCH SOLAR WIND
OR OIL OR WHATEVER ELSE OR USE
AND I ASKED YOU I VOTE FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL'S
MEASURE. THANK YOU SAID HERS
BERG. ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATER
FASHION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS EIGHT HI
BILL. HI GORGEOUS. HI BRADFORD
I CARRY IT ALL HI CHENG I. DELI
I DONT. I DURAZO. I GOT JOHNNY
HI GLAZER I GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL.
WESSEL HIGHER TADO I JACKSON HI
JONES BY LABOR TIME ACQUIRE.
MITCHELL BY MONEY HI MORLOCK.
I'M A REAL. NELSON I PAN HI
PORTS DINO BY ROSS BY RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN. STONE I AMBERG
CASKEY I WINNER. WELL LOOK HI I.
CENTER HERTZBERG MOOSE THE CALL
NEXT ITEM UP HIS FILE AND ONE
SEVENTY ONE SENATOR GLAZER BUT
BEFORE WE PROCEED I WANNA NOW
SO THE NEXT FIVE FILE AND. ONE
EIGHTY FOUR ONE EIGHTY NINE ONE
NINETY SIX ONE NINETY SEVEN AND
FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE. WITH
THAT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ WHILE I'M ONE SEVENTY ONE.
SOME MAKING HER RESOLUTION
SIXTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
MCCARTY RELATIVE TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER
GLAZER THE FLOOR SHORES THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
THIS MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. I IT'S A RESOLUTION
THAT REQUEST THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
CONDUCT A STUDY ON THE
USEFULNESS AFFECTED NIS AND THE
NEED FOR THE S. A. T. AND THE
A. C. T. S. N. DETERMINING
STUDENT ADMISSION. THE
RESOLUTION IF DEEMED NECESSARY
AND I UNDERSCORE IF DEEMED
NECESSARY MAY INCLUDE A PLAN
FOR PHASING OUT THE SAT AND A.
C. T. AS A BASIS FOR ADMISSION.
STUDY CAN PROVIDE CAMPUS IS
ALREADY LOOKING FOR OTHER
ALTERNATIVES WITH IMPORTANT
INFORMATION AND DATA TO SUPPORT
THEIR DECISION THE BILL IS BI
PARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA I ADKINS BATES. HI
BILL BY BURGESS NO BRADFORD. I
CAN BE AT ALL I CHAIN I DELI.
BY DODD BUY THOUGH I GOT A
JOURNEY BY GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE. HERTZBERG BY HILL. SO
HIGHER TITLE I JACKSON HI JONES.
LABOR. TIME ACQUIRE MITCHELL.
BY MONEY. MORE LOCK MORALE.
NELSON BY HAND FIVE FOUR TO DO
YOU KNOW. HI ROSS BY RUBIO
SKINNER. STERN STONE. BAMBERG
OUR CASKEY HI WINNER. WILK HI.
RIGHT SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY FOUR CENTER FAN ARE YOU
PREPARED. SAYING SO MISSILE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SOME OF
THOSE SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
SOME IN THE MORASS AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH FACILITIES.
CENTER CAN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR BY SUMMER RACE ISN'T
IMPORTANT STEP IN ASSESSING OUR
CAPACITY PROVIDE HEALTH
SERVICES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL GAINES
FURTHER INFORMATION REGARDING
HOW LONG PATIENTS ARE WAITING
FOR. THIS CHARTER CHANCE FOR
SPECIALLY CASES WHERE THEY ARE
IN NEED OF PSYCHIATRIC CARE
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE IN NEED OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THEY
OFTEN SEE HERE THE NEAREST
EMERGENCY ROOM. IN MANY CASES
ONCE EVALUATED THE PATIENT NOW
NEEDS TO BE TRANSFERRED TO A
SEPARATE DEPARTMENT TO BETTER
ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS THIS BILL
ALLOWS US TO BETTER EVALUATE
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
TRANSFERS AND DISCHARGES
ESPECIALLY IN CASES WHERE
INDIVIDUALS ARE DEALING WITH A
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITION. THIS
DATA IS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE MAKE. EFFICIENT
USE OF OUR RESOURCES AND ALSO
TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE GET THE
PSYCHIATRIC. CARE THEY NEED IN
A TIMELY MATTER I STRICTLY
ASKED FOR AND I FELT. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN. ANY ANY FURTHER
DEBATERS QUESTION SING NINE
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES.
NOBEL HI GORGEOUS. BRADFORD. BY
KELLY AT ALL HI CHENG I. DELI.
DOT. BY DOURADO I GOT JOHNNY BY
GLAZER. CONSULTEZ HI GROVE.
HERTZBERG HILL. WESSEL HI FOR
TITLE BY JACKSON HI JONES.
LEVER I'M ACQUIRE. MITCHELL BY
MONEY I'M MORE LOCK. I AM A
REAL NO NELSON. NO PAN I PORTED
DINO. ROSS I RUBIO SKINNER.
STERN STONE NO NUMBER. BY KATHY
BY WINNER. WILK HI HI. NO
CENTER MOVES NEWS THE CALL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY NINE. S. SENATOR WEINER
NOT AT HIS DESK. SO MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SIX.
SENATOR BELL BE READY SIR YOU
ARE GREAT AT MIST MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME OF
THE ONE FORTY THREE BY ASSUMING
NUMBER QUIRKS OF A AN ACRYLATE
HOUSING AND KLINGER THREATS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. CENTRE
BELL. THANK YOU MISS PRESENT
MEMBERS THIS SO. THIS BILL
EXPANDS THE EMERGENCY HOUSING.
AS STATUES TO INCLUDE HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. WIN ORANGE
COUNTY ALAMEDA COUNTY. CITY
SOUNDS AS WELL AS OTHER
COUNTIES AND CITIES. ALREADY
INCLUDING THE CURRENT LAW
DECLARE A SHELTER CRISIS. THE
BILL WOULD CREATE FLEXIBILITY.
TO EXPEDITE THE CREATION OF
SHELTERS AND PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. THIS BILL
HAS BY FAR SUPPORTERS YOUR VOTE
ON THIS. THANK YOU CENTRE BELL
ANY FURTHER DEBATERS QUESTION.
SENIOR MIKE SET MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES
BY BILL BY BURGESS I BREVARD I
KELLY AT ALL I CHAIN. I DALLY
HI DON EITHER ALTHOUGH I GOT
JOHNNY. GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I
GROVE I HURTS BERG. HILL. WITH
SO HI TACO BY JACKSON. I JONES.
BY LEVA BY MCGUIRE. MITCHELL.
BY MONEY I AM MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL. NELSON. PAN I POURED INTO
YOU KNOW HI ROSS. I RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN STONE. I AMBERG
PAPA CASKEY. FIVE WINNER. WILL
HI. YES AND IT SAID BELL MOVES
THE CALL MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM. ONE NINETY SEVEN CENTER
BRADFORD ARE YOU PREPARED. PASS
ON FILE. MOVING TO FILE I'M
2100% OKAY CENTER LABOR ARE YOU
PREPARED FILE I'M TWO HUNDRED.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME
OF THE ONE NINETY SEVEN BY SOME
IN MEMBER WEBER AND NATURAL IN
KINDERGARTEN. CENTER LLEVA.
FIRST THANK YOU I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AT PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE NINETY SEVEN WHICH
REQUIRES THAT EVERY SCHOOL
WITHIN A SCHOOL DISTRICT
CHARTER SCHOOL THAT SERVE
PRIMARY GRADES TO IMPLEMENT AT
LEAST ONE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM ON CAMPUS. ACCORDING TO
THE EDUCATION COMMISSION OF THE
STATES FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
ATTENDANCE CAN HELP CLOSE
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS EARLY ON IN A
CHILD'S EDUCATION LONGER SCHOOL
DAYS ENABLE CHILDREN TO RECEIVE
MORE INDIVIDUALIZED
ACADEMICALLY FOCUSED. AND
MEANINGFUL INSTRUCTION FROM
TEACHERS AS WELL AS MORE TIME
INTERACTING WITH THEIR PEERS
THIS CAN LEAD TO INCREASED
SCORES AND GREATER LONG TERM
ACHIEVEMENT THE POSITIVE
EFFECTS OF A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN OR EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED. FOR MINORITY AND
LOW INCOME CHILDREN BECAUSE
MORE MORE CHILDREN PARTICIPATE
IN PRESCHOOL AND EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAMS KINDERGARTEN
IS NO LONGER THERE FIRST SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE MANY ARE USED TO A
FULL DAY PROGRAM AND ARE READY
FOR FULL. CANNING THE
DIVISIONAL OUR PROVIDED UNDER A
B. ONE B. SEVEN WHAT A BAND
INSTRUCTION TIME FOR STUDENTS A
GIVE TEACHERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE AN ACADEMICALLY RICH
EXPERIENCE FOR EVERY YOUNG
LEARNER. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
SIR LATER ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR%
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ADKINS BATES NOBEL
BY PORGES NO BRADFORD. CAN BE
ERA HI CHENG HI DELI. NO DOT HI
THERE ALSO I GOT A JOURNEY BY
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG. I HILL WITH SO.
FOR TITLE HI. WHY WAS I JACKSON
HI JONES. NO FLAVOR. TIME
ACQUIRE. MITCHELL HI MONEY BY
MORE LOCK. NO MORALE NO NELSON
NO PAN HI FORTINO. BY ROB HI
RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE
NOVEMBER. BY WHAT COUNTY BY
WINNER. WILL HI HI. THEIR LABOR
MOVES THE CALL I'M NOT GONNA
READ THE NEXT SIX ITEMS UP ITEM
TWO OH FIVE ITEM TWO OH SEVEN.
ITEM TO ELEVEN. TWO EIGHTEEN
ITEM TWO TWENTY EIGHT AND ITEM
TWO THIRTY. ITEM TWO OF FIVE
CENTER STERN NOT AS DESK ITEM
TWO OH SEVEN CENTER STERN NOT
AT HIS DESK. SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO. WHILE I AM TO ELEVEN
SENATOR BASE ARE YOU PREPARED.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ A
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY SEVEN
BY SOME IN NUMBER CHOW AN ACT
RELATING TO DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE CENTER BATES. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT A BEEF THREE NINETY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHILD IT WILL REQUIRE
THE ANNUAL REPORTING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OF
CONVICTION DATA RELATED TO.
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF
CANNABIS OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
LEGALIZED CANNABIS HAVE SEEN
INCREASES IN FATAL CRASHES
INVOLVING INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE THE
LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL UNDOUBTEDLY
CONTRIBUTED TO THE RISE OF
IMPAIRED DRIVING. WHILE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
STATE INDEPENDENTLY KEEP
STATISTICS ON CANNABIS RELATED
DO YOU I ARRESTS ARE STATE
LACKS THE UNIFORM MECHANISM TO
EVALUATE CANNABIS DRUG DRIVING
BY ESTABLISHING A STATEWIDE
REPORTING SYSTEM. THE STATE CAN
BETTER EVALUATE THE AMOUNT OF
CANNABIS DRUG DRIVING
CONVICTIONS AND WHAT POLICIES
ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS THIS
BEHAVIOR. EIGHTY THREE NINETY
SEVEN WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO
HAVE AN ACCURATE AND RELIABLE
DATA OF HOW MANY CANNABIS DO
YOU EYES OCCUR IN THE STATE AND
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL I BRIDGES BY BRADFORD.
ZERO HI JANE HI DAWALY BY DOG.
BY DURAZO. I GOT JOHNNY HI
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROW I
HEARD HER BY HILL WITH SO. BY
TITLE I JACKSON BY JONES I LIVE
A TIME ACQUIRE MITCHELL BY
MONEY BUY MORE LOCK. I'M A REAL
HI NELSON I PAY IN. WHAT DO YOU
KNOW. ROF BY RUBIO SKINNER
STERN STONE BUY HAMBURG IA
CASKEY I WINNER. WILK HI BY.
THE SENATOR MOVES THE CALL NEXT
UP FILE ITEM TO EIGHTEEN
SENATOR JONES ARE YOU PREPARED
SIR. ALL RIGHT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ A SOME OF THE FIVE
FIFTY SIX BY A SEMI MEMBER
CORIO AN ACT REALLY INTO PUBLIC
RESOURCES CENTER JONES THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'M
WITHHOLDING MY OPINION ON
WHETHER YOU'RE DOING A GOOD JOB
OR NOT TO THE END OF THE DAY
MISTER PRATT. TO I RISE AS A
PROD CO AUTHOR OF A B. FIVE
FIFTY SIX. WHICH WILL HELP
PROVIDE CRITICAL OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES TO DISADVANTAGED
YOUTH. MAYBE FIVE OF THE SIX
TASKS THE NATURIST SERVICES
AGENCY WITH CREATING A
COMMUNITY ACCESS PROGRAM. TO
ENABLE CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE
TO YOU KNOW YOU UTILIZE. OUR
STATE'S BEAUTIFUL NATURAL
INCLUDING A NATURAL RESOURCES
INCLUDING A GRANT PROGRAM. THAT
PROVIDES SUPPORT FOR INNOVATIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
FOSTER ACCESS. PROVIDING ACCESS
TO THE OUTDOORS CAN FOSTER
GREATER CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
UNDERSTANDING OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES AND TRADE ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDS WHILE ALSO PROMOTING
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL WELLNESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I.
VOTES TODAY. BUT THOSE NEW
GLASSES CERTAINLY HELP YOU I
HELP YOU READ THAT. ANY OTHER.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION. SEEING
NONE TO SECTOR CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. ARCHULETA I ADKINS BATES
HI BILL. BY BURGESS BY BRADFORD
I CARRY IT ALL. CHANG HI DAWALY
BY DODD I DURAZO. YEAH JOHNNY.
HI. GLAZER BY GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HILL. WITH
A HIGHER TITLE BY JACKSON.
JONES BY LABOR TIME ACQUIRE.
MITCHELL HI. MONEY BUY MORE
LUCK BY MERRELL. HI NELSON. PAN.
SPORTS DO YOU KNOW HI ROSS I
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN AFTER THE
TONE BY AMBER IOWA CASKEY BY
WINNER. WE WILL HI HI. OKAY
CENTER MOVES THE CALL WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY THREE CENTER
MITCHELL ARE YOU PREPARED. ALL
RIGHT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
THE MON AN ACT RELATING TO
CHILDCARE CENTER MITCHELL THE
FLOOR IS YOURS I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT A B.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT ON BEHALF
OF SOME REMEMBER LEE MOANED AND
THIS IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR
THE- LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
CREATES A SUSTAINABLE CAREER
PATHWAY AND SUPPORT. FOR THOSE
TO EDUCATE AND CARE FOR OUR
YOUNGEST CALIFORNIANS
CALIFORNIA'S EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION WORKFORCE IS
COMPRISED PRIMARILY OF WOMEN
AND PREDOMINATELY WOMEN OF
COLOR THIS IS THE WORK FORCE
THAT OFTEN DOES NOT EARN A
LIVABLE WAGE AND QUALIFIED FOR
THE SAME SUBSIDIES USE. BY THE
FAMILIES THEY SERVE. WE KNOW
THAT WITH ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PARENTS ARE MORE
PRODUCTIVE IN CHILDREN ARE. ARE
SET UP TO SIX FEET. THE
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
ON CHILDCARE RECOMMENDS THE
SUPPORT OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS FOR FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOME PROVIDERS BOTH
LICENSED AND LICENSE EXAM ALSO
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS FAMILY
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS. THIS
BILL CREATES STABILITY FOR
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BY
MAKING QUALITY TRAINING
AVAILABLE TO ALL PROVIDERS AS
WELL AS ALLOWING THEM TO ENGAGE
IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. A B.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PROVIDES A
HOLISTIC FRAMEWORK TO ADDRESS
BOTH PROVIDER PAY INEQUITY AS
WELL AS THE LACK OF A SET
ACCESSIBLE CHILDCARE. AGAIN THE
MEASURE IS A PRIORITY OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AS
WELL AS THE LATINO CAUCUS AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR MITCHELL
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. CENTER JACKSON. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE YOU KNOW WE
TALK WE TALK ABOUT TRYING TO
GIVE THOSE WHO MIGHT NOT
OTHERWISE HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE SUCCESSFUL
TO GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO BE AT
THE STARTING LINE IN THE IN THE
RACE IN LIFE AT THE SAME PLACES
ALL OTHER CHILDREN. AND THIS IS
A BILL THAT. RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION WHICH IS WHY TO
LEGISLATE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY. AND I THINK IF WE
WANT TO ADDRESS EARLY. SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN OUR
SOCIETY THAT WE NOT ONLY FAILED
TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS WHEN THEY
BECOME. ADULTS OF WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM OR WHAT HAVE YOU.
WHETHER IT'S CHILDREN WHO DROP
OUT OF SCHOOL OR WHO FIND
THEMSELVES WITHOUT WORK AS THEY
AGE BECAUSE THEY REALLY HAVE
NOT HAD A CHANCE. IT REALLY
STARTS EARLY AND THIS KIND OF A
BILL PROVIDING THAT OUR
YOUNGSTERS HAVE QUALITY CARE.
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
TO PROVIDE THAT CARE ARE
TRAINED TO UNDERSTAND THE
FUTURE UNDERSTAND OUR CHILDREN
UNDERSTAND DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
YOUNGEST RESOURCE IF THIS IS
THE PLACE WE SHOULD START AND
THIS IS A BOTH A PREVENTION
MEASURE THIS IS A DEVELOPMENT
MEASURE THIS IS THE KIND OF
BILL THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT SO THAT WE CAN STOP PROBLEMS
BEFORE THEY START ENCOURAGING
THESE WONDERFUL LITTLE HUMAN
BEINGS THAT ARE THE FUTURE OF
OUR SOCIETY IN OUR WORLD THEY
HAVE THE BEST OPPORTUNITY
POSSIBLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL. THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS THAT IS
GOING TO HELP US BOTH TAKE THE
LEAD IN THIS NATION WIDE AND
HELP OUR YOUNGSTERS BECOME THE
BEST THAT THEY CAN BE AND WITH
THAT I STRONGLY URGE AND I
VOTED AND THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE FLOOR. MANAGER FOR BRINGING
THIS MATTER FORWARD. THANK YOU
SIR JACKSON SENATOR STONE THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT WE ALWAYS
WANT. WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
BETTER EDUCATE OUR OUR CHILDREN
BUT THIS BILL LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN LET'S CALL IT WHAT IT
IS NOTHING MORE THAN. A UNION
GRAB THAT IT'S SUBSTANTIATED
AND SUPPORTED. BY THE DIRECTION
OF THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
WHICH WILL BE MANDATED TO
PROVIDE THE NAMES HOME ADDRESS
MOBILE. PHONE NUMBERS EMAILS
FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
WITHIN AN APPROPRIATE UNIT AND
MANIPULABLE ELECTRONIC FORMAT
ON A MONTHLY BASIS SO THAT
UNION REPRESENTATIVES CAN GO
OUT AND ORGANIZE SUCH GROUPS.
WHY WE LIMIT IT TO UNIONS
HAVING ACCESS TO THOSE THOSE
NUMBERS AT THIS IS TRULY ABOUT
BETTER EDUCATION WHAT GIVES THE
UNIONS. THE MONOPOLY ON THE
EXPERTISE TO BETTER EDUCATE OUR
KIDS. YOU KNOW. IT'S VERY CLEAR.
THAT THIS INSTITUTION IS
STRONGLY CONTROLLED BY LABOR
AND IT'S VERY CLEAR. THAT
CERTAIN MEMBERS ARE OWNED BY
LABOR UNIONS. ANNUAL AID BE
EXEMPLIFIED TODAY WHEN YOU SEE
WHO VOTES FOR THIS MEASURE WHO
DOESN'T OFFER THIS MEASURE
LET'S PLAY ON AN EVEN PLAYING
FIELD THIS SLANTS AT ALWAYS
TOWARD THE DIRECTION OF UNIONS
WHICH IS NOT ALWAYS IN THE BEST
INTEREST FORMULAS FOR THOSE
REASON. REASONS I RECOMMEND
OVER AN EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU CENTER STONE
ANY FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION
SEEING I MISTER. SENATOR
MITCHELL PLEASE CLOSE. LET ME
BEGIN MY CLOSE BY HELPING TO
CLEAR FIVE FOR MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM THE GREAT COUNTY
OF ORANGE. THAT I AM OWNED BY
NO ONE. WHATEVER COUNTIES FROM
ED TO MACULA. HE YOU KNOW WHO
I'M TALKING ABOUT THOUGHT AS
EVERYBODY ELSE WITHIN THE SOUND
OF MY VOICE. I'M OWNED BY NO
ONE. AND I HOPE THAT ALL OF US
WOULD BE RESPONSIVE TO THE OVER
FORTY THOUSAND FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. ACROSS THE
STATE BECAUSE ALL OF US
REPRESENT THEM. AND WHILE. IT
APPARENTLY IS EASY AND
CONVENIENT FOR MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE TO SIMPLIFY COMPLEX
ISSUES BY SIMPLY SAYING IT'S A
POWER GRAB BY LABOR AND THAT
HIS COLLEAGUES TO THE LEFT OF
HIM ARE WHOLLY OWNED
SUBSIDIARIES OF SUCH LET'S HAVE
A REAL CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT
CONSTITUTES HIGH QUALITY EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION. AND ALL THE
WORKING PARENTS WITHIN THE
SOUND OF MY VOICE RELY ON HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN PROVIDERS
TO ALLOW THEM TO COME TO THIS
PLACE OF WORK EVERY DAY. SHOULD
UNDERSTAND I WOULD CHALLENGE
ALL OF YOU. TO TELL ME WHAT YOU
THINK A FAMILY DAYCARE PROVIDER
EARNS HOURLY. DO YOU HAVE A
CLUE. I BET YOU DON'T. THE
WHOLE POINT OF THE BILL. IS TO.
NOT CLASSIFY CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS IS PUBLIC. PLEASE
THEY'LL REMAIN SMALL BUSINESSES.
IT IS TO CREATE AN EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
THE STATE. NOW THEM. TO ENGAGE
IN COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AND
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THEIR
REIMBURSEMENT. IT WILL NOT
ALTER THE RIGHTS OF FAMILIES TO
SELECT THE CHILD CARE
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S BEST FOR
THEM. GOVERNMENT GOT INVOLVED
IN THE CHILDCARE SYSTEM WHEN WE
ASK WORKING WOMEN BACK IN THE
SECOND WORLD WAR TO GO TO WORK
FOR THEIR COUNTRY. AND SOME
WOMEN HAVE REMAINED IN THE WORK
FORCE. AS YOU ALL WOULD SUGGEST
THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE TO BE
ABLE TO FEED CLOTHE AND HOUSE
THEIR FAMILY. AND SOME FAMILIES
JUST DON'T EARN ENOUGH. THAT'S
WHERE GOVERNMENT STEPS IN WITH
THE SUBSIDY PROGRAM THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH
COBB COUNTY'S OPERATES. THAT'S
THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FAMILY DAY CARE PROVIDERS
WHO PROVIDE CARE TO CHILDREN
WHO RECEIVE SUBSIDIES EVERY DAY.
AND THOSE WOMEN AND MEN
SHOULDN'T BE ASKED TO DO SOME
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT WORK IN
OUR COLLECTIVE LIVES. FOR THE
POVERTY WAGES THEY ARE
CURRENTLY EARNING. WELL IM
NOT. CHOOSING TO FLOOR JACKIE
THIS BILL BECAUSE I'M OWNED BY
LABOR. I'M CHOOSING TO FLOOR
JACKIE THIS BILL TO HELP
EDUCATE THOSE WHO NEED IT.
ABOUT WHAT QUALITY CHILDCARE
LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT QUALITY
CHILDCARE RELIES UPON. QUALITY
CHILDCARE RELIES UPON A TRAINED
COMMITTED CHILDCARE PROVIDER.
WHO IS CONSISTENT IN HIS OR HER
CARE FOR CHILDREN. WHO WANT TO
BE IN THIS SECTOR IN THIS
BUSINESS AND CAN AFFORD TO BE
SOMEONE TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES AS AND AS AS SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE SYSTEM.
QUALITY TRAINING AND
CONSISTENCY. IS WHAT
CONSTITUTES HIGH QUALITY
CHILDCARE. FOR THOSE REASONS
COLLEAGUES I'D ASK THAT YOU RE
EVALUATE YOUR ATTITUDE ABOUT
THIS BILL AND SUPPORT A B.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL MR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. BATES
NO WELL I FOR JUST. NO BRADFORD
I HAVE A YELLOW I CHANG. DOLLY
NO DON. I THERE ARE SO I TELL
JOHNNY. GLAZER. CONSOLIDATES I
GROVE NO HERTZBERG I HILL. WITH
SO I TADO. I JACKSON I JONES.
LEYVA I REQUIRE. MITCHELL HI
MORNING HI MORE LOCK NO AROUND.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN. FOURTEEN
TINO. I ROTH I REVIEW. SKINNER
STERN. STONE NO I'M BURKE HI
MIKE HOW SKI. HI WE- WELL. NO
SENATOR MOVING THE CALL. NOPE
WE'LL GO WE'LL DO IT NEXT TIME
AROUND WE'RE ALL EVERYTHING'S
ON CALL MEMBERS SO IF YOU MISS
YOUR TIME WHEN WE TAKE THINGS
OFF CALL WE WILL GET YOU THEN
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY. EIGHT SENATOR BRADFORD.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AN ACT
RELATING TO EXONERATED
PRISONERS SENATOR BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
STAND HERE TO PRESENT A V.
SEVEN ALL ONE ON BEHALF OF
SOMEONE WOMAN WEBER WHICH DEALS
WITH EXONERATED FALSELY ACCUSED
PRISONERS AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
PROVIDES A METHOD TO ASSIST
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO BEEN
WRONGLY WRONGFULLY FULLY
CONVICTED. AND PROVIDING
HOUSING ASSIST TO WHILE MILNE
TO ACCESS UP TO FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
HOUSING EXPENSES AS THEY RE
ENTER SOCIETY WHICH WAS
UNJUSTLY TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM
THEIR FREEDOM I SHOULD SAY THIS
BILL SPONSORED BY THE
EXONERATED NATION. IN
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SUPPORTED BY
SEVERAL SEVERAL SEVERAL GROUPS
SUCH AS THE ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS ACLU AND
TENNIS TOGETHER THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE FOR
INDIVIDUALS AGAIN WHO HAVE HAD
THEIR FREEDOM A JUSTLY TAKEN
AWAY FROM THEM AND HAD WE TALK
ALL THE TIME ABOUT THE
INCREASED HOMELESSNESS IT'S ME
THE FOLKS WERE HOMELESS IN WHO
WERE FALSELY ACCUSED. CONVICTED
AND THEY'RE REAL WITH NO. SO
THIS. TO HELP FOLKS WITH STOPS
HIMSELF AND BE PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE THAT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHIE LETTER
HI ATKINS. BATES WELL I FOR
JUST. I BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM
I CHANG. I DOLLY I DON. I DO
ALSO I GOT JOHNNY I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES. I GROWS.
HERTZBERG HI HILL. I WAS SO I
TADO I JACKSON I JONES. I LABOR
I WIRE HI MITCHELL I MORNING. I
MORE LOCK I MORROW. I NIELSEN.
I PAN. PORTS AND TINA HI ROB I
REVIEW. SKINNER I STERN. STONE
I AMBER. HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER I WOKE. HI SENATOR MOVES
A CALL MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEMS TWO THIRTY
SENATOR GLAZER ARE YOU PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
BROTHER READ PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SURVIVED AS AN
ACT RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION CENTER GLAZER THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF HIS FAMILY
MEMBERS SURVIVE TASTE AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. ALL OF US KNOW
THAT THE COST OF COLLEGE IS A
HUGE IMPEDIMENT TO ONE'S
ABILITY TO AT A HIGHER
EDUCATION AND A PART OF THOSE
COSTS ARE THE COSTS OF HOUSING.
AND WHAT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
ENSURES THAT HOUSING COSTS FOR
PROSPECTIVE STUDENT HOUSING
COSTS. OUR FIGURED OUT
ACCURATELY AND POSTED. ON THE
WEBSITE OF THE INSTITUTION THAT
THEY'RE CONSIDERING GOING TO
AND IT REQUIRES THAT THE- THE
USE OF FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
FAIR MARKET RENT. DOCUMENTATION
SYSTEM. TO STANDARDIZE THAT
COST OF HOUSING FOR EACH
INSTITUTION FROM DIFFERENT
GEOGRAPHIC UP PLACES. WE ALL
WANT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TO HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY GO TO COLLEGE
THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND COSTS.
AND THEY ARE DIFFERENT BY
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL IS AN
EXCELLENT WAY TO STANDARDIZE
THAT UNDERSTANDING. RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CENTER BORDERS I
DO APOLOGIZE I COMPLETELY
MISSED YOU PLEASE PROCEED NO
FROM WHAT THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO DO
OFFER SUPPORT TO MY COLLEAGUE.
WHOSE FOR JOGGING THIS I THINK
THIS. IS ONE OF THE MOST
UNDERESTIMATED. CONSIDERATIONS
THAT WE HAVE FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION THE INDEBTEDNESS AND
I THINK IT GOES INTO THE WHOLE
NOTION OF FAIR PLAY THAT OUR
STUDENTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MUCH THEIR
EDUCATION SHOULD COST IN ALL
THE ANCILLARY COSTS THAT GO
ALONG WITH HOUSING IN TEXT
BOOKS AND SO ON AND SO FORTH
IT'S NOT LIKE IT WAS BACK WHEN
WE WERE YOUNGER WERE SUMMER
JOBS CAN ALLOW US TO GO TO
SCHOOL. THE TUITION COSTS THE
SOARING INFLATION THAT GOES
ALONG WITH IT. IS JUST TOO
GREAT ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS.
THE USER BORDERS SENATOR NELSON.
BETTER PRESENT LADY IS GERMAN
SENATE I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT.
MY DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUE FROM
MERENDA ACTUALLY SERVED ON THE-
BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
AND HE KNOWS THIS ISSUE VERY
WELL. IN ITS COMES TO MIND AS I
SPEAK WITH YOU HEAR ABOUT THIS
IN SUPPORT. A FELLOW NAMED
STEVE DIXON. IT WAS A HUMBLE
STATE GRADUATE A PRESIDENT OF
THE UNIVERSITY AND THEN LATER
SERVED ON THE TRUSTEES WITH MY
COLLEAGUE WHO'S BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD TODAY. AND HE HAD
EXPRESSED TO ME SOME OF THE
RIGORS OF THE JOB THAT HE HAD.
IN THE POSITION OF PRESIDENT OF
THAT UNIVERSITY. AND OF THE
STUDENTS THAT ATTENDED THERE.
AND GET ON AS A CS YOU GRADUATE
MYSELF. THINGS HAVE CHANGED A
BIT. IT IS A MORE COMPLICATED
SOCIETY AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
OUR STUDENTS FACE NOW GREATER
IN MANY WAYS THAN BEFORE. I
LOOK BACK ON THOSE TIMES WHERE
I WAS THE TENDING AND STAN
MUSTA HAD A PRETTY EASY. THIS
WILL BE OF HELP TO THEM IT IS
WORTHY OF OUR YES VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER NELSON MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THIS TIME SEEING NONE CENTER
GLAZER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
THINK THE- NUMBER FROM TO
HANNAH AND FROM FRESNO FOR
THEIR GRACIOUS COMMENTS. A
TODAY AND I WAS TOUCHED BY THE
OBSERVATION ABOUT TRUSTEE STEVE
DIXON. WHO WAS A GREAT STUDENT
LEADER AND WHOSE HONOR I
PRESENT THIS BILL ON HIS BEHALF
AS WELL AS A FAMILY MEMBERS OF
ARTISANS STUDENTS ASSOCIATION
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
EITHER. THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ADKINS FATES I FELL I FOR JUST
I BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW. I
CHANG HI DOLLY I DON. I THERE
ARE SO FIVE TELL JOHNNY I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HURTS BURN. HI HILL I WAS SO I
TADO I JACKSON. JONES I LABOR I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL I MORNING I
MORE LOCK I MORAL. I NIELSEN.
HI PAM. POURTANT TINA HI ROB I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN HI
STONE I AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI.
HI WINNER HI WELL. HI SENATOR
MOVES A CALL. SENATOR GLAZER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO BACK TO
FOLLOW HIM FIFTY ONE. VERY GOOD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
AN ACT RELATING TO PHARMACY
SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS MEASURES
BEING PRESENTED ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. IT WOULD
ENABLE INTERMITTENT CLINICS
THAT ARE OPEN TWENTY TO FORTY
HOURS A WEEK TO PURCHASE DRUGS
AT WHOLESALE FOR ADMINISTRATION
OR DISPENSING THE PATIENTS THIS
BILL CONFORMS THE NUMBER OF
HOURS AN INTERMITTENT CLINIC
CAN REMAIN OPEN IN THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSION CODE. THE MEAT
THAT TO RECENT CHANGES MADE TO
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT
VOTE CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. WELL I FOR JUST. I
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM. FIVE
CHANG HI DOLLY I DON. FIVE THE
ROSTER. I TELL JOHNNY. GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HURTS BERG.
HELLO HI WITH SO I TADO. I
JACKSON HI JONES HI LEAVE US.
HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL FIVE
MORNING. I MORE LOCK I MORROW I
NIELSEN I PAN. POURTANT TINA. I
BROUGHT I REVIEW. I SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE HI AMBER. I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER. I WOKE. HI
MEMBERS WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE SO
WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE ROLE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. BATES I. CAL JOHNNY.
HERTZBERG I IN. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. ATKINS
CAL JOHNNY. PAM. ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM TO THIRTY ONE
SENATOR PAM NOT AT HIS DESK BUT
I LET HIM TO THIRTY TO SENATOR
BILL ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. THE JOB. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOLERA AND ACTS
RELATING TO EDUCATION DATA.
CENTRE BELL. MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THIS BILL OR WILL HELP
CLOSE THE READING THIS GAP FOR
MITCHELL AND DENNIS THE IN UPON
A ROMAN IN KINDERGARTEN SO IT
WILL HELP INSURE THAT WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE IN A LINE DATA
SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE WILL EXPAND
ACCESS TO EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS RECEIVE YOU
NOW TO SUPPORT. IRISH AND I
VOTE ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING NO MIKE'S UP
MISSED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS. BATES. WELL I FORGES
I BRADFORD. I HAVE A YELLOW I
CAN I DALLY I DON. HI THERE
ALSO. KALYANI HI LASER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HI HILL I WAS SO. I TADO HI
JACKSON HI JONES HI LISA I WIRE.
HI MITCHELL. I MINING I MORE
LOCK I MOREAU. I NIELSEN. PAM
THEY DON'T WORK POURTANT TINA.
HI ROB HI REVIEW. SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE. I AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL. HI HI
SENATOR BELL MOVES THE CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
FORTY SENATOR ALSO YOU'RE
PREPARED YES YOU ARE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ
. TWO
FORTY FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL AT
NINE SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAN AS AN ACT RELATING
TO VICTIMS OF CRIME SENATOR US
SO THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT A B. NINE
SEVENTEEN WHICH UPDATES THE
TIMELINE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND CERTIFICATION
ENTITIES TO PROVIDE THE PROPER
DOCUMENTATION TO VICTIMS OF A
CRIME FOR THE PURPOSES OF
OBTAINING A U. VIS A AND THE T.
VISA CERTIFICATION THIS BILL
REQUIRES A CERTIFYING ENTITY TO
PROCESS VICTIM CERTIFICATION.
FOR PURPOSES OF A U. VIS OUR
TV'S WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THE
REQUEST RATHER THAN NINETY
UNLESS THE NON CITIZEN IS IN
REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS IN WHICH
CASE THE CERTIFICATION MUST BE
PRESENTED IN SEVEN DAYS RATHER
THAN THE CURRENT FOURTEEN THIS
BILL SEEKS TO REDUCE THE CRIME
CERTIFYING. THE REDUCE THE TIME
CERTIFYING OFFICIALS HAVE TO
PROCESS A VICTIM CERTIFICATION
REQUEST AND ALLOWS ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING CRIME VICTIMS IN
IMMIGRATION PROCEEDINGS TO
REQUEST VICTIM CERTIFICATION
FROM CERTIFYING OFFICIAL. THIS
ENHANCES THE OVERALL PUBLIC
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS TO
INSURE THAT IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
VICTIMS OF CRIME AND TO
COOPERATE WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN GOOD FAITH
RECEIVE. THE NEEDED
DOCUMENTATION THAT PROTECTS
THEM FROM DOOR DEPORTATION THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE. NINE THAT
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES WELL.
I FORGES. BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM I CHANG. DOLLY GOD. I THE
RUSSELL I TELL JOHNNY. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I
HELLO I WAS SO. I TADO. JACKSON
TADO I'D JACKSON I JONES NO
LLEVA. I REQUIRE HI MITCHELL
FIVE MONEY. I MORE LOCK. MERLE
NO NIELSEN. HI PAM. POURTANT
XENA HI ROB. HI RUBIO. SKINNER
I STERN I STONE. NO I'M BURKE.
HI MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
HI. SENATOR ALSO MOVES THE CALL
I WOULD TAKE A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO THINK
CONNIE CENTER LABOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ACTUALLY HAVING
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR FOR ONE
VOTE TODAY ACTUALLY WORK YOU
SHOULD BE OCCUR MORE OFTEN WITH
THAT WE'RE MOVING ON TO PILE
ITEMS TWO FORTY THREE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE HE ARE YOU PREPARED.
BY CASKEY PASSES ON FILE MOVING
NOW TO FILE ITEMS TWO FORTY
FOUR SENATOR BRADFORD. PAST
TEMPORARILY. BY THIS POINT I'M
GONNA CALL OUT THE NEXT FIVE
ITEMS THAT WE PLAN TO TAKE UP
MEMBERS FILE ITEM TWO FORTY
SEVEN. TWO FORTY NINE. TWO
FIFTY. TWO SIXTY TWO AND FILE
ITEM TWO SIXTY THREE. SO FILE
ITEM TWO FORTY SEVEN CENTER
GONZALEZ ARE YOU PREPARED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND ACTUALLY DID
A MEDICAL CENTER GONZALEZ S.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AT TEN OH FOUR SIX TO
IMPROVE DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS FOR CHILDREN AGED
ZERO TO THREE UNDER THE EARLY
AND PERIODIC SCREENING
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT. A
BENEFIT UNDER MEDICARE AS YOU
KNOW APPROXIMATELY 85% OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS IN THE FIRST
THREE YEARS OF LIFE THESE YEARS
ARE WHEN EACH OTHER'S BUILDING
THE DEVELOPMENTAL ARCHITECTURE
ESSENTIAL FOR HIS OR HER
LIFELONG LEARNING BEHAVIOR AND
HEALTH. EARLY IDENTIFICATION
AND PREVENTION WORKS WHICH CAN
IMPROVE A CHILD'S LONG TERM
OUTCOME AND MINIMIZE THE NEED
FOR COSTLY HEALTHCARE SPECIAL
EDUCATION JUVENILE JUSTICE
PUBLIC WELFARE SERVICES IN THE
FUTURE. WHICH IS WHY INSURING
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS IS
CRUCIAL IS IT PUBLISHED HERE
THIS OF THE DEPARTMENT. OF
HEALTH SERVICES TYPE OF THE
DELIVERY. AVENTIS SERVICES TO
CHILDREN IN MEDIC HEALTH FOUND
THAT DH CS IS COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT ALL CHILDREN IN
MEDIC CAL RECEIVE ALL BRIGHT
FUTURE SERVICES BUT HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE. DEMONSTRATE
A BOWL. OF PROGRESS. TO THE USE
OF THESE A PREVENTIVE SERVICES
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS WE
CANNOT KEEP POSTPONING THE
COMPLIANCE OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS. A B. TEN OH FOUR
SIX TO ENSURE INCREASED EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DELAYS OR DISORDERS AMONG YOUNG
CHLDREN AS RECOMMENDED BY
PEDIATRICIANS THIS IS SUPPORTED
BY THE COUNTY. HEALTH
EXECUTIVES. A SET OF
CALIFORNIA'S ASSOCIATION.
CHILDREN NOW FIRST FIVE L. A.
AMONG MANY OTHERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY OF DISCUSSION
DEBATE SITTING NINE MAN
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
FIVE ARE TWO LETTER I ATKINS.
BATES I FELL. HI GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW. I CAN
I DOLLY. I DON. HI RUSSEL. I
TELL JOHNNY I LASER I
CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH I HURTS
FOR. I HILL I WAS SO I TADO. I
JACKSON I JONES HI LISA. I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL I MONEY. I
WARLOCK I GROW I NIELSEN I CAN.
POURTANT TINA. I ROTH I REVIEW.
SKINNER. I STERN I STONE. I
AMBER HI MY CASKEY I WINNER. I
WILL HI THERE GONZALEZ MOVES
THE CALL. NOW MOVING ON TO
FIGHT IT TO FORTY NINE CENTER
GONZALEZ ARE YOU READY BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERCOOLLY AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES CENTER
CONSULTS THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TEN SIXTY
EIGHT RELATING TO CHILDREN AND
FAMILY TEAMS. IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM
HAS LONG STRUGGLED WITH THE
BEST WAY TO INCLUDE ALL THE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF A CHILD'S
NEEDS WHEN MAKING A DECISION
CHILD AND FAMILY TEAMS CFT S.
AS IT'S COMMONLY KNOWN BRING
TOGETHER THE CARE GIVER THE
CHILD THE CHILD WHERE FOR.
WELFARE AGENCY ANYONE ELSE
NEEDED FOR SUPPORT OR- MAKING
DECISIONS ARE BEING THE CHILD'S
PLACEMENT AND SERVICES A B. TEN
SIXTY EIGHT STRENGTHENS THE C.
F. T. PROCESS BY CREATING
NOTICE REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
CHILD PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS.
ENSURES THAT THE EDUCATIONAL
RIGHTS HOLDER IS INCLUDED IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS FOR
THESE DECISIONS AND CLARIFIES
THAT CFT SUMMARIES MAY BE
INCLUDED FILES FOR COURT
REFERENCE THESE CHANGES WILL
CREATE A STRONGER AND MORE
EFFECTIVE CFT PROP AS THERE IS
NO. OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. THANK
YOU THE SOLACE. THE DIGITAL
DEBATER DISCUSSION CENTER
NELSON BETTER PRESENT LAYS DOWN
THE SENATE I RISE IN SUPPORT
AND I KNOW THESE FOSTER
CHILDREN ARE A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO THE CELLAR AND COOLLY.
TO ME AND I BELIEVE ALL OF YOU.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO WERE MADE
REALLY PULL HEARTSTRINGS. AND
JUST BE WITH THESE FOSTER YOU.
AND SEE HOW THEY HAVE COPED
WITH THE CHALLENGE THEY'VE HAD
TO DEAL WITH IN THEIR LIVES. IT
IT RETAIL IT TEARS AT THE
HEARTSTRINGS. AND CAUSES YOU TO
WANT TO DO MORE. EVERYTHING YOU
TOO CAN. EASE THEIR PATHWAY TO
ADULTHOOD AND PRODUCTIVE BLACKS
BECAUSE THE MOON THEY SUFFERED.
IS A DEEP. IT WAS NOT SELF
INFLICTED. SO ANYTHING WE CAN
DO TO MAKE THEIR LIVES A LITTLE
HAPPIER. A LITTLE MORE FULL. WE
MUST DO SO THIS BILL WILL
ACCOMPLISH THAT PURPOSE I DO
URGE AND I VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SAY NUNS CENTER
GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS SENATOR
NELSON AND I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK ME I BOUGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES I FELL I FORGES.
NO BRADFORD. I HAVE A I DON'T I
CHANG. I DOLLY I DON. I ASSUME
I TELL JOHNNY. I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH. I HURTS
BERG. HI HILL I WAS SO. HI TADO
HI JACKSON I JONES HI LISA. I
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. I MORNING.
I MORE LOCK FIVE MORALE. I
NIELSEN. HI PAM. POURTANT TINA.
I ROTH I REVIEW. I SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE I BURKE I LIKE
HOW SKI. I WINNER I WILL HI.
FOR JUST NOTRE I'D BETTER
CONSULT US MOVED TO CALL MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
SENATOR. CENTER WINNER YOU
PREPARED. SAYING THAT THE
CENTER'S PREPARED YES DENNIS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL RECORDS
CENTER WINNER THE FLOOR SHORES
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT OUR
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT A
TWO TEN SEVENTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER TELLING. WHICH REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
AUTOMATE DISMISSALS OF
CONVICTIONS AND ARREST RECORDS
FOR ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS
TO CLEAR ARRESTS. THAT DID NOT
RESULT IN A CONVICTION AND THE
CLEAR CONVICTIONS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR DISMISSAL THROUGH
A COURT PETITION. UNFORTUNATELY
MANY PEOPLE WITH CRIMINAL
RECORDS ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS
JOBS AND HOUSING. UNDER
SUBSEQUENTLY UNABLE TO AFFORD
AFFORD LAWYERS TO CLEAR THEIR
RECORDS WHICH CREATES A-
VICIOUS CYCLE AND DRIVES
RECIDIVISM. THIS BILL WILL
FACILITATE THE PROCESS AND HELP
PEOPLE OBTAIN THE RELIEF TO
RETURN TITLED AND TO MOVE ON
WITH THEIR LIVES. BY THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION HAVE
RECENTLY REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION. TO THIS COMMON
SENSE MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE A. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE THAT
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. WELL
I PORGES NO BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM. I CHAIN NO DOLLY NO DON.
HI THERE ALSO I TELL JOHNNY.
PLEASE I CONSOLIDATES I GROW NO
HERTZBERG. HI HELLO I WAS SO I
TADO. JACKSON JONES NO LLEVA. I
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORE LOCK MOREAU. NO NIELSEN.
PAN POURTANT TINO. I ROTH I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN I
STONE NO AMBER I LIKE HOW SKI.
I WINNER I WILL NO CENTER
WINNER MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME WE ARE GOING TO GO
BACK TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES OF IT BE AN APPROPRIATE
TIME TO PULL A BILL FOR CONSENT
SENSIBLY TO INACTIVE FILE OR
MOVIE BACK. BACK FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE. MR MAJORITY
LEADER THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT A NUMBER OF ITEMS
HERE I'LL GO SLOW AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING THE BILLS TO
AN ACTIVE. FILE ITEM NINETY
FOUR BABY FIVE TO THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR ONE NEXT
FILE ITEM TWO TWO FIVE AB SIX
THIRTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
SURE ON THIS. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHORS PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING FOUR MEASURES UP FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM
THREE FIFTY FIVE EIGHTY B. FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW. FILE ITEM THREE SEVENTY
NINE AB A LEVIN THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW. FILE ITEM
THREE NINETY TWO. SOME ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN FILE ITEM
THREE NINETY FOUR AB. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY BY SOME REMEMBER CORREO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PRESENT.
CENTER MCGUIRE. THERE YOU GO.
GAME YOU WANT. ALL RIGHT LOOK
AT THAT. MISTER PRESIDENT WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO REMOVE FILE
ITEM THREE SEVENTY NINE MAYBE
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE OFF OF
CONSENT THERE PENDING
AMENDMENTS. YES GO NOTE DALLY.
HE WAS PRESENT AT THE REQUEST
THE AUTHOR I'D LIKE TO REMOVE
FILE ITEM THREE SIX SEVEN A. B.
SEVEN SIX TWO FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT FILE TO THE- FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU SIR. ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. CASING
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE IT
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK. TO WHERE
WE WERE. YEAH WELL. RIGHT.
ARIGHT FILE ITEM TWO SIXTY TWO.
AND THAT IS CENTER ARCHULETA
ARE YOU PREPARED SIR. OKAY VERY
GOOD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SOLACE AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. THAT
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT A B. TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN
TODAY IS. ON BEHALF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE. A B.
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN WILL EXPAND
CURRENT SALES TAX EXEMPTIONS TO
DISABLED VETERANS WHO ARE
PURCHASING ADAPTIVE AUTOMOTIVE
EQUIPMENT. PHYSICALLY DISABLED
VETERANS DEPEND ON THE
EQUIPMENT TO GET THEM IN AND
OUT OF THEIR AUTOMOBILES SAFELY.
AND TO OPERATE THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ITSELF. UNDER CURRENT
LAW IT IS UNCLEAR IF THE SALES
TAX EXEMPTION APPLIES TO
VETERANS WHO ARE DISABLED
BECAUSE OF THE SEVERE BURNS AND
THIS IS THE ISSUE BECAUSE- SOME
OF THE VETERANS WHO WERE.
ATTACKED AND LOST FINGERS AND
LIMBS UP THE BURN IS NOT. AN
ISSUE. SO WE'D LIKE TO MAKE IT
THE ISSUE THIS BILL WOULD
EXPAND CURRENT SALES TAX
EXEMPTION LANGUAGE TO ENSURE
THAT THIS GROUP OF VETERANS IS
INCLUDED. A B. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN WOULD REMOVE FINANCIAL
BARRIERS TO ADAPT. AUTOMOTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND HELP MORE
VETERANS ACCESS THESE IMPORTANT
DEVICES THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND MAINTAIN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE VETERANS GROUPS
AND ALL THOSE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOAT. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE NONE OF SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ATKINS. BATES I WELL I FORGES
I BRADFORD. I COME BY ADAM HI
CHENG I. DALLY. DOT I ASSUME I
GOT JOHNNY. I GLAZER. I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. I HURTS FOR
HI HILL I WAS SO. I TADA HI
JACKSON I JONES I LIVE UP. I
REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL. I MORNING
I MORE LOCK I MOREAU. I NIELSEN
I CAN PORTS AND TINA I ROTH I
REVIEW I SKINNER. I STERN. I
STONE. HI AMBER. I WAKE OWSKI I
WINNER. I WILL HI HI. CENTER AT
ARCHULETA PUTS THE BILL ON CALL
BUT NEXUS CAN BE FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY THREE BY A SENATOR
SKINNER BEFORE SHE STARTS
THOUGH I'D LIKE TO LIST OUT THE
NEXT FIVE BILLS ARE BECOMING UP
FILE ITEM. TWO SIXTY FOUR TO
SIXTY FIVE FILE ITEM. TWO
SEVENTY SIX TO EIGHTY FOUR AND
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN WITH THAT IT
IT APPEARS AS CENTER SCANNERS
PREPARED SO. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOLERA AN ACT RELATING
TO IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
CENTER SKINNER FLOOR SHORES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
PROHIBITS OUR CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT FROM FACILITATING OR
ALLOWING PRIVATE SECURITY
GUARDS TO ARREST INTERROGATE OR
TRANSPORT INDIVIDUALS FOR
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES. ICE HAS BEEN RELYING
UPON THE USE OF PRIVATE
SECURITY GUARDS TO ENFORCE.
VARIOUS DEGREES THAT HAVE BEEN
ISSUED RECENTLY AND ISIS BEEN
USING THESE PRIVATE SECURITY
GUARDS TO DETAIN IMMIGRANTS
NEAR OR ACT OUR PRISON
FACILITIES. THE BILL ALSO
CODIFIES A REGULATION THAT WAS
ADOPTED BY OUR CDC ARE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH
PROHIBITS THE DETENTION OF
INDIVIDUALS BEYOND THEIR PRISON
TERM. AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
SCANNER. ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
BATES. NO WELL I FORGES. NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. I
CHANG NO DOLLY NO DON I THERE
ARE SO I TELL JOHNNY I LASER. I
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
I HELLO I WAS SO I TADO. I
JACKSON. JONES NO LLEVA. I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL. MONEY I
WARLOCK. ZERO NO NIELSEN. NO
PAN POURS INTO YOU KNOW. HI
RALPH I REVIEW I SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE. NO I'M BURKE. I
WAKE CASKEY I WINNER. I WILL NO.
CENTER SKINNER MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
SIXTY FOUR. INSTANT CENTER HER
TADO PASSES ON FILE. MOVING ON
TO FILE I'M TWO SIXTY FIVE
CENTER COPYRIGHT. META
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOHN SAWYER AND
ACTUALLY RELATING TO CANNABIS
CENTER FLOOR SHORES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT A B. TWELVE
NINETY ONE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGINALD JOINT
JONES SAWYER CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW REQUIRES THAT A CANNABIS
BUSINESS WITH TWENTY OR MORE
EMPLOYEES ENTER INTO A P. LABOR
PEACE AGREEMENT. CURRENT LAW
ALSO REQUIRES THAT WHEN A
CANNABIS BUSINESS HIRES ITS
TWENTIETH EMPLOYEE THAT
BUSINESS MUST ENTER INTO A
LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT BUT THE
LAW ONLY SPECIFIES THAT THEY
WERE CURRENT CHOIR MEET NEEDS
TO BE MET QUOTE AS SOON AS
REASONABLY PRACTICABLE. AB
TWELVE NINETY ONE WILL REQUIRE
CANNABIS LICENSE APPLICANTS
WITH LESS THAN TWENTY EMPLOYEES
TO STATE IN THEIR PPLICATION
THAT THEY WILL ENTER A LABOR
PEACE AGREEMENT WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF HIRING THEIR TWENTIETH
EMPLOYEE THIS MEASURE WILL
PREVENT ARBITRARY ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST CANNABIS BUSINESSES
WILL PROVIDE EMPLOYEES WITH
CLARITY ON WHEN IN IN IN IN
PLAYER IS FAILING TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED. NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS BATES.
NO WELL I PORGES NO BRADFORD. I
HAVE A I CHANG HI DOLLY. DON I
THEY'RE AWESOME. I GOT JOHNNY I
LASER I CONSOLIDATES I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL HI WITH SOME
I TADO. I JACKSON I JONES.
LEYVA I REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL I
MONEY. I MORE LOCK NO MORAL. NO
NIELSEN NO PAM. PORTS AND TINA.
I RALPH I REVIEW. SKINNER I
STERN I STONE. NO BURKE I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL. HI
SENATOR MOVES THE CALL NOW
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TO SEVENTY SIX SENATOR THE
CHOIR. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADWARE CURRY AN ACT RELATING TO
MEDI CAL. CENTER THE FLOOR SURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A PRESENT
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TODAY THIS
IS A REALLY GOOD BILL BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN AND WE ARE CURRY
TV FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR. IT
CLARIFIES THE HEALTHCARE
SERVICES PERFORMED OUTSIDE AT
THE MEDICAL CENTER CLINICS FOUR
WALLS DURING EMERGENCY
SITUATION MUST BE REIMBURSABLE
WHETHER IT'S IN A SHELTER A
PATIENT'S HOME BY PHONE OR
THROUGH TELEHEALTH. THIS ALL
CAME ABOUT FROM THE TUBS FIRE
IN. TWO THOUSAND SAYS SEVENTEEN
WHEN SANTA ROSA COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER. FOURTEEN HUNDRED
AND TWELVE TELEPHONING VISITS
TO THEIR PATIENTS THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WHICH SHE IS GRATEFUL FOR HAS
NO OPPOSITION RESPECT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL.
THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NO MY EX
RAISED. MISTER SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. I ARCHULETA BY
ATKINS EIGHT HI BILL HI PORGES.
HI BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I CAN BE
AT ALL. I CHANG HI DELHI. DOT
I'D RATHER I GOT JOHNNY. HI
GLAZER I GOT JEALOUS I GROW. I
HEARD BERG I HILL I WHISTLE I
TADO I JACKSON BY JONES. I LIVE
A I'M ACQUIRED BY MITCHELL. BY
MORNING BUY MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL. HI NELSON HI FI PAN. DO
YOU KNOW I. RALPH BY RUBIO. BY
SKINNER BY STERN. BY STONE BY
OBERG POWER CASSIE HI WINNER I
WILL HI THEY REQUIRE MOVES THE
CALL NUMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO EIGHTY FOR SENATOR HER
TADO. ARE YOU PREPARED FILE
ITEMS TWO EIGHTY FOUR. PASS ON
FILE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN CENTER BRADFORD.
BE PREPARED PASS ON FILE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TO NINETY SIX
GONZALEZ. RE PREPARED TO
PRESENT FELL INTO NINETY SIX.
HOW IS PORGES. I HAVE TO GET
STRONGER GLASSES OBVIOUSLY.
SENATOR BARGES MISTER SECRETARY
PRESS ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BY THIS IN THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AND
ACTUALLY IN THE PUBLIC RECORDS
THEY'RE GORGEOUS THANK YOU AS
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
BILL AB EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WHICH
CLARIFIES THAT A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO
PHOTOGRAPH OR OTHERWISE COPY IS
CLOSE WILL PUBLIC RECORD WITH
THEIR OWN EQUIPMENT AT NO
CHARGE SO LONG AS THE EQUIPMENT
IS NOT MAKE PHYSICAL CONTACT
WITH THE RECORD. THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT GIVES THE
RIGHT TO INSPECT RECORDS THAT
ARE IN THE CUSTODY OF STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES. IT
TOOK TEN COPIES OF SUCH RECORDS
FROM THE AGENCY. BUT SOMETIMES
THIS RIGHT OF THE PUBLIC IS
FRUSTRATED CUSTODIANS OF PUBLIC
RECORD SOMETIMES TELL THE
PUBLIC THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
PHOTOGRAPH PUBLIC RECORDS AND
MUST WAIT TEN DAYS. AND PAY THE
AGENCY TO MAKE COPIES. EXISTING
LAW DOES NOT SPECIFY THE PUBLIC
HAS A RIGHT TO COPY THE
RECORDS. THEY ARE ENTITLED TO
INSPECT. THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION BROADCASTERS AND
FIRST AMENDMENT COALITION AND
HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION IN
NOT EVEN A SINGLE NO VOTE
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'LL VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES HI
BILL I PURCHASED MY BRADFORD I
CAN BE AT ALL I CHAIN I DELI.
DOT. HI THERE ALSO I GOT JOHNNY
I GLAZER I GONZALES HIGH GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG I HILL HIGHWAY SO
I OR TITLE. I JACKSON BY JONES
I LIVE A- I'M ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL. MONEY I MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL I KNOW SOON I PAN.
FORTINO HI ROSS. RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. I STERN BY STONE. I
AMBERG OUR COUNTY I WINNER HI
WILL HI. THEIR BARGES MOVES THE
CALL LIKE TO GO BACK TO FIND
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN MY APOLOGIES
TO SENATOR DOOR ALSO FOR
SKIPPING OVER THAT AND SHE'S
PREPARED SO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SOME OF BILL SIXTY
FIFTY EIGHT BY A SEVEN MEMBER
CORIO AN ACT REALLY INTO
TEACHER CREDENTIALING CENTER
ALSO THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU ARE YOU DOING THAT
EXCELLENT JOB COLLEAGUE. I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT A. B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH REALLY WOULD
REQUIRE THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING. THIS
TABLET SURE WORKGROUP TO STUDY
ISSUES RELATED TO ADULT
EDUCATION TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. THE WORK GROUP
WILL COLLABORATE WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES WHO HAVE DIRECT
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE OF THE
ADULT EDUCATION LANDSCAPE.
INCLUDING ADULT EDUCATION
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
WORKING WITHIN BOTH THE K. TO
TWELVE AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEMS. TOGETHER THE
WORKGROUP MEMBERS WILL CRAFT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO ADDRESS
INEQUALITIES AND AN AREA AND
AREAS OF IMPROVEMENT WITHIN
ADULT EDUCATION TRAINING HIRING
AN INSTRUCTION. ACCORDING TO A
STUDY BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THIRTY TWO MILLION
ADULTS AND THE UNITED STATES
CAN. READ. WITH CONTINUED
SUPPORT AND ATTENTION TO ADULT.
AND OPEN DOORS TO MORE JOBS AND
CAREERS THIS BILL ENJOYS BI
PARTISAN SUPPORT. HAS RECEIVED
NO. NO. ALSO ANY FURTHER DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. I ARCHULETA. INS HI BATES.
HI BILL HI BURGESS BY BRADFORD
I COME HERE ALL HI CHENG I.
DALLY. DOT ALSO. I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER I GONZALES I GROVE.
PIRATES WORD I HILL. WITH SO.
HI DATO HI. JACKSON. HI JONES
BY LABOR TIME ACQUIRE. HI HILL
HI. MITCHELL BY MORNING. HI
MORE LOCK I'M REAL. RELY NELSON
HI PAN POOR DINO HI ROB I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER. BY STERN BY STONE.
NUMBER HI KATHY I WINNER HI
WILL. HI SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY TWO SENATOR
WELK MATTERS MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SOME OF THOSE SIX
ELEVEN BY SOME MEMBERS ARE IN
AN ACT RELATING TO SEXUAL ABUSE
OF ANIMALS. SENATOR WELK THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
ARE RICE PERCENT AB SIX ELEVEN
BY SIMPLY MEMBER IN HIS AREA
AND THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES IN THAT BECAUSE IT
THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S BEEN I CAN
SEND ITS ENTIRE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY UP UNTIL THIS MOMENT.
SO IN THE- IN AN EFFORT TO HAVE
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY I'M
GOING TO DO HIS FULL SCRIPT. AB
SIX ELEVEN WHAT EXPANDING
CLARIFY CURRENT LAW PROHIBITING
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT AND ANIMALS.
THIS BILL EXPANDS THE INTENT OF
THE LAW TO COVER ANY ACT
COMMITTED FOR DO YOU SIR FOR
FINANCIAL GAIN. THUS
PROHIBITING THE SELLING OR
RENTING OF ANIMALS FOR SEX. IT
ALSO CLARIFIES THE PROHIBITION
OF ENGAGING IN SEXUAL CONTACT
WITH ANIMALS TO INCLUDE ANY
PART OF THE BODY OR AN OBJECT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL OR
REQUIRE THE COURT TO ORDER THE
CONVICTED PERSON TO REFRAIN
FROM CONTACT WITH THE ANIMALS.
I'M SORRY I CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
THIS MEASURES. THESE MEASURES
IN PART NOT ONLY TO PROTECT
HELPLESS ANIMALS BUT ALSO TO
PROTECT OTHER VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS YES ANIMAL SEXUAL
ABUSE IS THE SINGLE STRONGEST
PREDICTOR OF INCREASE. I'VE
INCREASED RISK FOR COMMITTING A
CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED OBVIOUSLY BROUGHT
SUPPORT AND I HOPE YOU ARE
MOVED TO VOTE I ON THIS BILL Q.
THANK YOU SIR NUMBERS QUESTION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. BAIT. HI
BILL HI PORGES. HI BRADFORD. I
COME HERE ALL. HI CHENG BY
DAILY I DIED. I DURAZO. I GUESS
JOHNNY BY GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I
GROW. I HURTS BERG. HI HILL I
WHISTLE. BY OUR TITLE HI
JACKSON BY JONES BY LABOR I AM
A CHOIR HI MITCHELL. BY MORNING
HI MORE LOCK. I'M A REAL.
MERRELL HI NELSON IPN. PORTENO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN BY STONE. BY AMBERG. OUR
COUNTY BY WINNER HI WILL HI
CENTER MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWO NINE NINE SENATOR HILL MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOR A FOUR BY A SEMI
MEMBER MARK STONE AN ACT REALLY
IN THE CAMPUS. SENATOR HILL
THANK YOU AND I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT A B. FOUR ZERO FOUR
WHICH ALLOWS CANNABIS TESTING
LABORATORIES TO AMEND ITS
CERTIFICATE OF ANALYSIS TWO
CORRECT MINOR ERRORS AND TO
REQUEST PERMISSION FROM THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL TO
RETEST PRODUCTS IN INSTANCES
SUCH AS EQUIPMENT MALFUNCTION
OR STAFF ERROR LEADING TO
INACCURATE RESULTS RESULTS OF
TESTS FOR TOXIC CHEMICALS IN
PSYCHO ACTIVE CONTENT IN
CANNABIS PRODUCTS MUST BE
CERTIFIED ON CERTIFICATES OF
ANALYSIS. C. O. H. THAT
ACCOMPANY THE PRODUCTS THROUGH
THE COMMERCIAL PROCESS PER
BUREAU REGULATIONS THESE C. O.
A.'S CANNOT BE AMENDED EVEN TO
CORRECTED KNOWN ERRORS MEANING
A TYPO OR DATA ENTRY ERROR ON
THE PART OF THE TESTING
LABORATORY CAN IRREPARABLY
DISQUALIFY ENTIRE BATCHES OF
OTHERWISE MARKET READY CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FROM DISTRIBUTION
BUREAU REGULATIONS ALSO
PROHIBIT RETESTING CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FOR ANY REASON EVEN IF
THE TESTING LABORATORY IS AWARE
OF INACCURATE RESULTS DUE TO
EQUIPMENT MALFUNCTION STAFF
ERROR OR OTHER SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES A BEFORE OKAY.
WHAT MAKES HIM WAIT FOR CHANGES
TO THE CAMPUS TESTING PROCESS
TO ALLOW FOR CORRECTION OF A
RONI ITS RESULTS YOU DO THROUGH
THE MEN OF SHE WAITS FOR
RETESTING OF BUREAU DEEMS
AMENDMENT OR RETESTING
APPROPRIATE. THIS MEASURE HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU
CENTER HILL. ANY ADDITIONAL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ALAN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES HI BILL HI PORGES.
BRADFORD HI KELLY HERO I CHING
I DELI I DOG. ARE THERE ALSO. I
GOT JOHNNY I GLAZER I GONZALEZ
I GROWTH I HURTS BERG HI HILL I
WISH SO I TADO. I JACKSON HI
JONES. I LABOR I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. BY MORNING BUY MORE
LOCK ARM RELL BY NELSON BY
PAYING FOR TO DO YOU KNOW I
ROTH BY RUBIO BY SKINNER BY
STERN BY STONE I AMBERG ABA
COUNTY. BY WINNER I WILL HI HI.
SIR HILL MOVES A CALL OR NEXT
FILE ITEMS WOULD BE THREE
HUNDRED. THREE OH TWO THREE OH
SIX AND THREE THIRTY. WHILE
ITEM THREE HUNDRED ENTER
HERSHBERGER YOU PREPARED HE IS
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOR TWENTY BY A
SEMI MEMBERLACKEY AND ACTUALLY
IN THE CANNABIS AND CLEARING
THEIR THROATS TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MR MAJORITY LEADER
THE FLOOR SURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEVENTEEN YEARS BEFORE THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. VOTED TO LEGALIZE
CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA BUY A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT MARGIN FIFTY
SEVEN POINT 13% OF THE VOTERS
ALMOST EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE WE
IN THIS STATE LEGISLATURE
CREATED THE CENTER FOR
MEDICINAL CANNABIS RESEARCH.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE WAS THE
YEAR. HE WAS TASKED WITH
CONDUCTING SCIENTIFIC STUDIES
TO DETERMINE THE SAFETY AND
EFFICACY OF BOTH CANNABIS AND
SYNTHETIC CANNABIS. NOW AS A
RESULT WE'VE HAD THIS APPROVAL
SENATOR I ACCEPT REMEMBER
LACKEY WITH A B. FOR TWENTY IS
SEEKING TO BROADEN THE SCOPE OF
RESEARCH AVAILABLE TO THE
CENTER TO ALLOW THEM TO BOTH
CULTIVATE THEIR OWN CANNABIS.
AS CONSISTENT WITH THE CURRENT
LAW CENTURY THE BILL ALLOWS THE
CENTER TO CONTINUE PERFORMING
NECESSARY RESEARCH ON THE
POSITIVES OR NEGATIVES EFFECTS
OF PURE CANNABIS AND
ASSOCIATING COMPOUNDS THIS WILL
GIVE THE RESEARCHERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MORE FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE HEALTH IMPACTS
IT PASSED OFF THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR SEVENTY TWO. TWO ZERO ASK
YOUR EYE BOAT. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG ANY ADDITIONAL DBATE
OR DISCUSSION. THING NINE
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES HI BILL I BURGESS I
BRADFORD. I CARRY IT ALL HI
CHENG I. DELI I DONT. HI THERE
ALSO. HI GO JOHNNY HI GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE. I HEARD HEARD.
I HILL I WHISTLE HIGHER TOTAL.
I JACKSON HI JONES. BY LABOR
I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL MY
MONEY I'M MORE LOCK I'M A REAL.
NELSON PAN POURTANT TINA. HI
ROSS HI RUBIO I SKINNER. BY
STERN BY STONE HI AMBER OUR
COUNTY HI WINNER BY WILL BY.
CENTER HERTZBERG MOVES THE CALL.
NO MEMBERSHIP MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THREE OH TWO CENTER WHY
CASKEY. PASS ON FILE MR
CONSISTENT ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THREE OH SIX AN IRAQI
IS PREPARED MR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER LOSE
REVERSE AN ACT RELATING TO
STUDENT DEBTS SENATOR ROBB
FAMOUS PRESIDENT THIS BILL
PROHIBITS POST SECONDARY
SCHOOLS FROM REFUSING TO
PROVIDE A TRANSCRIPT IN ORDER
TO COLLECT A DEBT. PRACTICE CAN
INHIBIT STUDENTS FROM ADVANCING
THEIR CAREERS ACTUALLY PAYING
OFF THE DEBT. ADDITIONALLY THE
PRACTICE CAN DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARMER STUDENTS OF COLOR LAST
YEAR YOU MAY RECALL THIS
LEGISLATURE DECIDED THE
WITHHOLDING TRANSCRIPTS TO
COLLECT THAT IS HARMFUL TO
STUDENTS IN THE K. THROUGH
TWELVE SYSTEM. THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT GOAL AND
SIMPLY EXPANDS THAT SAME RULE
TO HIGHER EDUCATION
RESPECTFULLY ESTHER I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH. ANY
FURTHER. DATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL ALAN I ARCHULETA
I HAD KITTENS BATES. HI BILL HI
BURGESS BY BREVARD I CAN DO. I
CHAIN HI DELI BY DODD. HI THERE
ALSO. YOUR OTHER I GOT JOHNNY
HI GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROW BY
HERZBERG HI HILL I WAS SO TIRED
TADO. I JACKSON. HI JONES BY
LABOR I'M ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL
BY MORNING BUY MORE LOCK I'M A
REAL I KNOW SOON. PAN POURTANT
DINO HI ROB HI RUBIO I SKINNER.
BY STERN I STONE BY NUMBER I
LIKE CASKEY HI WINNER I WILL HI.
CENTER PUTS IT ON CALL MOVIE
DEFILE ITEM THREE THIRTY
SENATOR MITCHELL AND SHE IS
PREPARED MR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SOME OCCUR RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY TWO BY A SEMI MEMBER
GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO DIAPER
NEED AWARENESS WEEK SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU SIR
COLLEAGUES A C. R. ONE TWENTY
TWO RECOGNIZES THE WEEK OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY THIRD THE
TWENTY NINTH OF THIS YEAR AS
DIAPER NEED AWARENESS WEEK.
DIAPER NEED OCCURS WHEN THE
FAMILY DOES NOT HAVE A
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF DIAPERS TO
KEEP CHILDREN CLEAN DRY AND
HEALTHY. ONE IN THREE FAMILIES
EXPERIENCES A DIAPER NEED AT
SOME POINT WHILE THEIR CHILDREN
ARE LESS THAN THREE YEARS OF
AGE AND NEARLY HALF OF ALL
FAMILIES WILL DELAY CHANGING A
DIAPER IN ORDER TO EXTEND THEIR
SUPPLY. I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY
OF YOU HERE REMEMBER WHAT YOU
PAID FOR DIAPERS A MONTH. AW.
IN THAT FOR MANY OF YOU IT WAS
DECADES UPON DECADES AGO. SO
LET ME JUST REMIND YOU. DIAPERS
CAN COST UP TO ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER CHILD OR MORE
DEPENDING UPON WHERE A FAMILY
IS ABLE TO PURCHASE THEM.
DIAPER NEED ALSO CREATES A
BARRIER WHEN PARENTS ARE GOING
TO WORK BECAUSE CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS REQUIRE FULL DAY
SUPPLY OF DIAPERS FOR THE
PAYMENT WHICH CAN BE UP TO TEN
DIAPERS PER DAY. WHILE SOME
FOOD BANKS IN CLINICS PROVIDE
SMALL AMOUNTS OF DIAPERS WHEN
THEY CAN THEY'RE DIFFICULT ITEM
TO KEEP IN STOCK. A LESS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AFFILIATED
WITH THE DIAPER BANK. DIAPER
BANKS ARE CRITICAL FOR GETTING%
THIS NECESSARY HEALTH SUPPLY IN
THE HANDS OF FAMILIES DURING
TIMES OF NEED. AGAIN COLLEAGUES
THE WHOLE GOAL OF THE
RESOLUTION IS TO RAISE
AWARENESS. OF THE PROBLEM AND
ENCOURAGE ALL CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT RGANIZATIONS LIKE
DIAPERS THANKS TO HELP
ALLEVIATE. THE DIAPER NEEDS I
ASKED FOR AN I. BOAT. THANK YOU
SIR MITCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ALAN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
EIGHT HI BILL HI BURGESS I
BRADFORD I CAN BE AT ALL. HI
CHAIN HI DOLLY I DOG. HI THERE
ALSO I GOT JOHNNY. GOD DURING.
HI GLAZER I GUNS ALICE I GROW.
I HURTS WORD. HI HILL I WHISTLE
HIGHER TITLE I JACKSON I JONES
I LIVE A I'M ACQUIRE. MITCH HI
MITCHELL HI MONEY BUY MORE LOCK
I'M REAL. BY NELSON. PAN POOR
DINO HI HI ROB I RUBIO. HI
SKINNER I STERN BY STONE. BY
IOWA CASKEY OUR WINNER. I WILL
HI CENTER MITCHELL MOVES THE
CALL THE MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD
JUST INTELLIGENCE FOR SECONDARY
BE RE SHUFFLING THE DECK AND
WILL. RECEIVE MOMENTARILY
. ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WORK WE'RE GOING
TO GO BACK TO BILLS THAT WE
MISSED EARLIER TODAY THAT THE
ONE THAT'S UP FIRST IS FILE
ITEM NINETY FIVE CENTER WHITE
HOUSE SKI BUT IS THAT OUT FOR
AMENDMENTS. OR ARE YOU PREPARED.
PASS ON FILE THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT UP FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
SIX. THAT'S. SO WHILE I'M ONE
THREE SIX AUTHOR IS I MEAN THE
FLOOR MANAGER SIR REQUIRE AND
HE'S PREPARED SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SUM OF
BILL FOUR SIXTY THREE BY SOME
MEMBERS AROUND AS AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
THE PRESIDENT THERE ARE DOZENS
OF MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
THAT ATTENDED A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THE BACKBONE OF OUR
POST SECONDARY SYSTEM. SIXTY
THREE IS ON BEHALF OF THE SIN
OF RESTAURANT IS IN HIS FOCUS
ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS. THERE
AN ESTIMATED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND ADJUNCTS PART TIME
INSTRUCTORS COMPARED TO
NINETEEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
INSTRUCTORS. IN OUR
COMMUNICATIONS AND BECOME
INCREASINGLY RELIANT ON THOSE
PART TIME ADJUNCT FACULTY FACE
CANDIDLY LOW PAY AND FEW
BENEFITS. IN MINIMAL JOB
SECURITY EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
THREE REQUIRES COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO CREDIT PART TIME
FACULTY EMPLOYEES WITH THREE
POINT THREE FIVE HOURS WORK FOR
EACH HOUR LECTURE OR CLASSROOM
TIME. THIS IS GOING TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY MEMBERS TO
QUALIFY FOR THE FEDERAL PUBLIC
SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM. THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND COMMITTEE IN THE
SENATE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN
ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THREE NINE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN.
HI ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. BATES
NOBEL. HI BARGES. NO BRADFORD
HI CARRIE ERROL. HI JANE HIGH
DELI NO DA I DOURADO I GOT
JOHNNY I GLAZER BY GONZALEZ HI
GROVE. NO HERTZBERG BY HILL I
WAS SO BUYER TO AUTO. HI
JACKSON. HI JONES NO LLEVA. I
AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL. BY
MORNING BUY MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
NOTE NELSON NO PAN. PORTER TINA
HI ROSS BY RUBIO. I SKINNER. I
STERN BY STONE NOVEMBER. HI
KATHY HI WINNER I WILL. CENTER
PUT CENTER MOVES THE CALL NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWO OH FIVE SENATOR STERN AND
HE'S PREPARED MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETY SIX BY A SEMI MEMBER
COOLLY AN ACT RELATING TO
CLIMATE CHANGE MAKING PROVISION
THEREFORE CENTER STERN. I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
WITHIN EIGHTY TO NINETY SIX.
WHICH IS TABLETS AS A CLIMATE
INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
BUT THE IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
MEASURE TO UNDERSTAND IS. WE'VE
BEEN LEAVING A LOT OF PRIVATE
AND FOUNDATION CAPITAL ON THE
SIDELINES WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
CLIMATE INNOVATION STRATEGY
THEY'RE VERY LARGE GLOBAL
FOUNDATIONS AND OTHER INTERESTS
THAT. WANT TO PARTNER WITH THE
CITY CALIFORNIA ON CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT DON'T HAVE MUCH OF A
MECHANISM TO DO SO THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY ALLOW FOLKS ON.
WITHOUT GOING INTO ANY OF OUR
EXISTING FUNDS. TO FIND A
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL
PROGRAM THROUGH THEIR TAX FORMS
AND TO RECEIVE THAT THAT
BENEFIT THROUGH THE TAX CODE WE
THINK IT'S A LOW COST WAY TO
FUEL OUR CLIMATE ACTION
WORLDWIDE. AND IT'S RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVEAU. THANK YOU SENATOR. HE
DASCHLE DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR MORE OFF. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS I'M JUST VERY
SORRY THAT THERE LANGUISHING ON
A- FARM FORM FIVE FORTY LESS
THAN 2% OF FILERS ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THEM. WE NEED TO
TURBO CHARGE THIS PAGE OF THE
FIVE FORTY BY OPENING UP SMALL
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO ALL
REGISTERED CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THOSE THAT
JUST ARE ABLE TO GET A
LEGISLATOR TO PUT THEM ON THE
GROWING LIST OF SOME TWENTY
SEVEN TO TWENTY NINE BUT NO
ONE'S LOOKING AT NO ONE'S DOING
ANYTHING WITH SO CONSEQUENTLY.
I'M VOTING IN OPPOSITION TO
MESSAGE THE NEED FOR A RE
EVALUATION OF THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION PROGRAM THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR.
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS
CENTERS YOU MAY CLOSE DUE
RESPECT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY'S POINT OF VIEW
HERE AND FRANKLY THIS IS NOT
EVEN GOING TO BE ENOUGH BUT WE
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
INCREMENTAL STEP. FATTER SPEC
CLASS FOR IBM. THANK YOU SIR.
ALL MEMBERS ARE IN THE CHAMBER
SO WE WILL GO THROUGH THE ROLE
TWICE AND THEN WE WILL CLOSE IT
OUT. MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALAN. HI OUR STELLA I
ATKINS BATES HI BILL I
PURCHASED BY BRADFORD HI KELLY
YELLOW. CHANGE BY DAILY. I DODD
ARE THERE ALSO. I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROW. HI
HERTZBERG. HI HILL I WAS SO. HI
TADO. BY JACKSON. HI JONES NOS
LEVA I'M ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL BY
MONEY BUY MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NO NO ST. NIELSEN NO PANTS HI
FORTINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO.
SKINNER. HI STERN I STONE. NO
BERG HI KATHY. WINNER. HI WILL
HI. MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS COVER
GYRO BY. RUBIO. WHITE HOUSE
REVIEW I WHAT COUNTY. HIGHS
THIRTY THREE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO OH SEVEN CENTER
STERN IS PREPARED TO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE OH THREE BY A SEMI
MEMBERS AROUND THIS AND
ACTUALLY TO MENTAL HEALTH
CENTER STERN. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS CURRENTLY
THERE IS VERY LITTLE STATUTORY
GUIDANCE ABOUT PROCEDURES THAT
A COURT CAN USED TO ISSUE A
TRIAL CONTINUANCE OR DELAY IN
THE BEGINNING OF A TRIAL. TO
EVALUATE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS PROBABLE CAUSE
ALLEGATIONS FROM A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL THAT'S LED
TO UNNECESSARY DELAYS. A LACK
OF CLARITY IN THE CURRENT
JUDICIAL SYSTEM AND THERE'S
ALSO BEEN A PROBLEM WHERE NO
REQUIREMENTS ARE HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED FOR THE PARTY
REQUESTING CONTINUED. CONTINUES
TO PROVIDE THAT JUSTIFICATION
OR FOR THE COURT TO JUSTIFY ITS
DECISION ISSUE ONE. THIS CAN
LEAVE APPELLATE COURTS WITH AN
INCOMPLETE RECORD TO LATER
EXAMINE WHETHER CONSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATIONS OCCURRED DENYING
JUSTICE BOTH. TO BOTH PARTIES
AND IN THE MEDICATION ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE OH THREE WILL
ADDRESS THIS BY. PROVIDING SOME
STATURE KIND ON THE MATTER
THESE PROCEDURES INCLUDE A
REQUIREMENT THAT A MOTION FOR
CONTINUANCE BE MADE WRITING. A
REQUIREMENT THAT IT CONTINUED
TO BE GRANTED UPON GOOD BECAUSE
IF THEY CONTINUE TO ADD TO THAT
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE POOR
PROVIDE JUSTIFICATION FOR
DECISION ON THE RECORD. THIS
WILL HELP KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES
FOR FIVE STILL BE PROPER UNDER
THE LAW AND HOPEFULLY. CLEAR UP
SOME AMBIGUITY IN THE CURRENT
APPELLATE. IT WAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES RATHER JUST LAY THE
PROCESS AND IS SPONSORED BY AT
THE LA DA JACKIE LACEY WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN CENTER
NIELSEN. THIS PRESENT LET IT IN
THE SENATE WITHOUT ANY.
OPPOSITION IS THIS MOVE IT MAY
SEEM THAT IT STUNNED MORE THE
OF EXTENDED DEBATE BUT IT
REALLY YES THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. I WAS A PART
OF THE TEAM THAT PUT TOGETHER
THE SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
LAW MANY YEARS AGO. AND EACH
YEAR THEREAFTER FOR ABOUT THREE
OR FOUR YEARS WE MODIFIED THAT
STATUE WERE ADDED TO IT TO PLUG
WHAT WE THOUGHT WOULD BE
LOOPHOLES. THAT PROVED TO BE
FORTUITOUS WHEN THAT CASE
REACHED THE US SUPREME COURT.
THOSE STATUTES WERE NOTED. THIS
ISA BIT OF A LOOPHOLE THAT
ATTORNEYS HAVE EXPLOITED. NOW
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE REALLY
WORST OF THE WORST. SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS. TWO PRIOR
OFFENSES AND A HISTORY OF BEING
VERY DANGEROUS. THIS WILL HELP
THERE WAS CIVIL COMMITMENTS BE
PLACED ON SUCH INDIVIDUALS TO
KEEP THEM IN CUSTODY HAS AN IN
TREATMENT. FOR UP TO TWO MORE
YEARS DYER GINGIVAL. THANK YOU
CENTER CENTER STERN YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECT FAST FOREVER
THANK YOU WITH THAT MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES HI
BILL I BURGESS HI BRADFORD.
ZERO I CHAIN I DELI HI DON I
DOURADO. I GUESS JOHNNY MIKE
LASER EYE GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HURTS BERG BY HILL I WAS SO
TIRED TITLE I JACKSON BY JONES.
I LIVE A. I AM A CHOIR HI
MITCHELL BY MORNING. I'M MORE
LUCK. I'M A REAL BY NELSON.
PANTS I FORTINO HI ROSS I RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN I STONE. I
AMBERG OUR COUNTY HI WINNER I
WILL HI BY. THIS IS SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
BRADFORD. HI NEAL NELSON.
NELSON YOU JUST PROVED IO.
RUBIO I CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS
ONE TIME MORE TIME ATKINS.
NIELSEN. PRICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
IT NOW TO FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
ONE SENATOR PANDAS PREPARED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SOME OF THE SEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
A SEVEN MEMBER KALRA AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTHCARE COVERAGE
DR PEN THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
SENATORS EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE BY SUMMER CAR EXPERIENCE
HEALTH INSURANCE RATE REVIEW
PROCESS TO THE LARGE GROUP
MARKET. AND ENHANCES THE
PROCESS TO PROVIDE CONSUMERS
AND REGULATORS A CLEAR PICTURE
OF OUR HEALTHCARE COSTS
TRANSPARENCIES CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WILL HELP TEN
MILLION EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. GET MORE FORMAL
HEALTH BENEFITS THE AUTHOR HAS
ACCEPTED DOOM A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE THE WORKLOAD ON BOTH THE
REGULATORS AND THE HEALTH PLANS
AND SPECIFICALLY FOR BOTH
EXPERIENCED RATED AND COMMUNITY
RATED LARGE GROUPS THE
DEPARTMENT SHALL DETERMINE
WHETHER THE METHODOLOGY FACTORS
ASSUMPTION YOU TO DETERMINE
RATE. REASON. FOR THE FIGHT
STARTING ON JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THOSE LARGE GROUP
PURCHASES WITH TWO THOUSAND OR
MORE COVERED LIVES THEIR
EXPERIENCE RATED WOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO REQUEST A RATE
CHANGE REVIEWED BY THE
DEPARTMENT'S. CALIFORNIA'S HAD
A ROBUST HISTORY OF REVIEW FOR
BOTH THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL
GROUP MARKETS FOR HEALTH
INSURANCE SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN.
AND THIS REVIEW HAS SAVED
INDIVIDUALS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES OVER TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
SINCE THAT LAW WAS ENACTED.
THEREFORE WE USED THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS MICHAEL ALLOWING
GREATER SCRUTINY. AND ON WHAT'S
DRIVING UP PREMIUMS AND PROVIDE
NECESSARY RELIEF FOR MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE SEEKING
TO PURCHASE HEALTH CARE.
COVERAGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN.
ANY ADDITIONAL DESCRIPTION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN I
ARCHULETA BY ADKINS BATES. NO
BELL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD HI
KELLY HERO. CHANGE. NO DAILY NO
DODD. DOURADO HI I GOT JOHNNY.
GLAZER GONZALES HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. HI HILL I WAS SO. I
HER TITLE. JACKSON BY JONES NOS
LEVA I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY BUY MORE LUCK A REAL.
NO NELSON. NELSON. NO PAN HI
PORTS DINO HI ROB. REVIEW BY
SKINNER. BY STERN BY STONE NO
NUMBER. BY KATHY I WINNER HI
WILL NO. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
CAPPIELLO. NO. DODD HI DOES
JOHNNY GLAZER TACO. BUY MORE
LOCK NO ROTH NUMBER NUMBER GUY.
HI IS TWENTY FOUR KNOWS TWELVE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO FORTY THREE
SENATOR WHY CASKEY. PASS ON
FILE. MOVIE I DEFY LINE TO
FORTY FOUR CENTER BRADFORD.
PASS ON FILE. OKAY NOW MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE AND TWO SIXTY
FOUR SENATOR HER TITLE. NOT AT
HER DESK A PASS ON FILE. A
FINAL ITEM TWO EIGHTY FOR
SENATOR TADO. PASS ON FILE.
WANT TO CHECK. ALL RIGHT GONNA
TRY IT AGAIN MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE A. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY CENTER WHY CASKEY
BEFORE FILING ONE FIFTY FOUR
EXCUSE ME THANK YOU. YOU ARE
READY. MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ
A SOME ABLE ELEVEN THIRTY BY A
SEMI MEMBER LEVIN AN ACT
RELATED INFORMATION PRIVACY
THERE WHY CASKEY THE FLOOR IS
YOURS CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO MAINTAIN REGIONAL
SECURITY MEASURES TO PROTECT
SENSITIVE PERSONAL INFORMATION
FROM DATA BREACH. TO BEGIN WITH
IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU COLLECTED
THEN YOU HAVE TO PROTECT IT
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT COVER SOME
GOVERNMENTAL ISSUE THE ID'S
LIKE A PASSPORT OR A PERSON'S
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE. UPDATES THE
LAW TO REQUIRE BUSINESSES TO
NOTIFY INDIVIDUALS WHENEVER
THEIR PASSPORT NUMBER OR THE BY
MATCHING INFORMATION HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED IN THE DEBT DATA
BREACH. AND IT REQUIRES THEM
REPEATING IT CURRENT LAW TO
MAINTAIN REASONABLE SECURITY
MEASURES. TO PROTECT THESE
TYPES OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
THIS BILL WOULD CATCH
CALIFORNIA UP WITH TWELVE OTHER
STATES SAID IT ALREADY PROTECT
BIOMETRIC INFORMATION UNER
THEIR STATE LAWS IN THIRTEEN
OTHER STATES. THAT PROTECT PASS
INFORMATION WITH THAT I URGE
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ALAN.
HI ARCHULETA I ADKINS BATES
NOVELL HI BURGESS NO BRADFORD I
COME HERE ALL. CHANGE NO DELHI.
NO DODD. TORONTO I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZE DOES JOHNNY KNOW GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI GROVE NO HERTZBERG
HI HILL. I WAS SO BY HER TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI JONES. NO LABOR
TIME ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL BY
MONEY I'M MORE LUCK NO MORALE
NO NELSON NO PANTS. FIVE
FOURTEEN PM. HI ROSS. RUBIO HI
SKINNER. BY STERN I STONE
NOVEMBER FIVE ACCOUNTS HE I
WINNER I WILL NO. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS CAPPIELLO DODD
HI GLAZER. ROTH BROTHER. FIVE
TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TWELVE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO SENATOR
WINNER. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
CHAN AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CENTER WINNER I
THINK MISTER PRESIDENT I RISE
TO PRESENT AT FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF A SOME
REMEMBER CHAN WHICH IS A
DISTURBED BILL THAT WILL HELP
THE CITY OF BREA REVERTS HAWKS
DOLLARS BACK TO ITS PARAMEDIC
PROGRAM. OF THE BILL RESTORES
PARAMEDIC TAX REVENUES TO FUND
THE CITY'S PARAMEDIC PROGRAM
WHICH IS WHAT VOTERS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED ANY OUTSTANDING
OBLIGATIONS WILL THEN BE
COVERED BY OTHER SOURCES OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO THE CITY
OF THIS BILL IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN. SUPPORT
IN BOTH HOUSES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THE SENIOR CENTER WEINER ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
CENTER CHANG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT CALLING TODAY I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AS NOTED
THIS BILL WOULD RESTORE PORTION
OF THE CITY OF BRASS PROPERTY
TAXES TO BE USED AS VOTERS
INTENDED AND HIRE AND TRAIN
QUALIFIED PERSONNEL TO PROVIDE
PARAMEDIC SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY. AS A SENATOR WHO IS
PROUD TO REPRESENT CITY BREA I
ASKED YOU TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING A B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SENATOR CHANG.
ANY OTHER DEBATERS QUESTION
SAYING NINE. SIR WE YOU MAY
CLOSE. MR FAST FOR AN IRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL I BURGESS
HI BRADFORD I COVER YELLOW HI
CHENG I. DELI HI DOT I DRAW SO
I GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER. BY
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH. I HURTS
BERG HI HILL I WAS SO. HIGHER
TOTO I JACKSON. HI JONES BY
LABOR I'M ACQUIRE. BY MITCHELL.
HI MONEY BUY MORE LOCK. I'M A
REAL I NELSON HI PAN. I PORTED
TINO. HI ROSS BY RUBIO. I
SKINNER BY STERN. BY STONE.
STONE. NUMBER OUR CASKEY BY
WINNER I WILL HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN NO.
ATKINS STONE. PRICE THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ONE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS. WE ARE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT
CENTER MCGUIRE ARE YOU PREPARED.
PASS ON FILE OKAY. MOVING ON
NOW TO FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY
NINE SENATOR SCANNER. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME OF
THE LINE FOURTEEN BY A SEMI
MEMBER HOLDEN AND EQUANIMITY
CAL. THE CENTER SCANNER. THANK
YOU I MISSED PRESIDENT MMBERS
UNDER CURRENT LAW IN
INDIVIDUALS MEDI CAL BENEFITS
ARE TERMINATED AFTER ONE YEAR
OF BEING INCARCERATED AB NINE
FOURTEEN STOPS THIS PRACTICE
INSTEAD THE SPENDING THE
BENEFITS WHILE THE PERSON IS
INCARCERATED WHICH- ONCE THEY
ARE. NO LONGER. SERVING TIME IT
IS. EASIER IF THEY ARE STILL
ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE ALL TO RE
ENROLL AND THUS CONTINUE
WHATEVER NECESSARY HEALTH
COVERAGE THAT THEY NEED CLEARLY
WE KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR FOLKS
EITHER IN COUNTY JAIL OR
INCARCERATION HAVE CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS ADDICTION OTHER
MEDICAL NEEDS THAT. CONTINUING
THEIR MEDICARE BENEFITS ONCE
THEY ARE OUT OF BEING HELD WILL
NOT ONLY ASSESS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BUT HELP OUR-
PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. WITH THAT I ASK FOR AND
I VOTE THE BILL PASSED THE
FLOOR IN THE ASSEMBLY SEVENTY
FIVE TO ZERO. THANK YOU SENATOR
SCANNER ANY ADDITIONAL DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
ALAN. I ARCHULETA. BY ATKINS.
BATES BELL. BY BURGESS. HI
BREVARD I CAN BE ERA HI CHENG
I. DELI. MY DAUGHTER. EITHER
ALTHOUGH I GOT JOHNNY. GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ I GROVE. HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL BY WITH A
HIGHER TITLE HI JACKSON. HI
JONES I LIVE A- I'M ACQUIRE. HI
MITCHELL BY MONEY BUY MORE LUCK.
MORALE. HI NELSON. PAN. I
PORTANT DINO BY ROSS BY RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN BY STONE I
AMBERG. PILOT CASKEY BY WINNER
I WILL HI. YOUR SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
BATES HI. GAIL JOHNNY HI MORE
LOCK BY NELSON. HIGHS THIRTY
NINE OH ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
FORTY ONE SENATOR WEINER ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT. YES MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SUM OF
ALL NINE TWENTY SEVEN BY A SEMI
MEMBER JOHN SAWYER AN ACT
RELATED CRIMES THAT WINNER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT COLLOR'S
ARISE TO PRESENT EIGHTY NINE TO
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOING SAWYER. BY THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE A FINDING OF
THE DEFENDANT'S ABILITY TO PAY
BEFORE ASSESSING A PERSON WITH
A FINE OR FEE THEM THERE ARE
MORE THAN TEN BILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF OUTSTANDING FINE AND
FEED IN CALIFORNIA WHICH COULD
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES THAT OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM ASSIGNS A LARGE
AMOUNT OF FINES AND FEES TO LOW
INCOME DEFENDANTS WHO ARE.
UNABLE TO PAY AND GROUP. HI
THIS BILL CREATES A PRESUMPTION
THAT VERY LOW INCOME PEOPLE
THOSE TWO ARE I NEED SPACE
ASSISTANCE AND THE HOMELESS
WOULD LIKE I AM ABLE TO PAY
FINES AND FEES IT ALSO KEEPS
THE COURTS WORK LOAD MINIMAL BY
PUBLISHING A SERIES FACTORS TO
CONSIDER WHEN EVALUATING
ABILITY TO PAY. THIS BILL IS IN
LINE RETURN JUDICIAL DECISIONS
IN THE AREA INCLUDING A CASE
AND THE SECOND CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS. AND THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT'S DECISION IN
TIM'S PURSES INDIANA IF THE
BILL IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
CHANG I DELI. DONE BY DOT. BY.
DRAWS A. I GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER
BY GONZALEZ I GROVE. HERTZBERG
HI HILL HI WITH SO. HI DATO.
JACKSON HI JONES NO LLEVA I AM
A CHOIR HI MITCHELL. MITCHELL
MITCHELL LIE MORNING HI MORLOCK
HI. NO NELSON NO PAN HI FORTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO BY SKINNER I
STERN. STONE NO. NUMBER I LIKE
HEALTHY BY WINNER I WILL HI.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS ATKINS. DALLY GROWTH.
TADO I. STERN. HIGHS THIRTY ONE
KNOWS FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
FORTY TWO SENATORS SCANNER. ARE
YOU PREPARED AND SHE IS MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SEARCH
GET ARENA TEMPORARILY PASS ON
YOUR BILL. SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEMS TWO FIFTY FOUR
SENATOR WINNER YOU PREPARED.
OKAY MISTER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THEM TO FIFTY FOUR.
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO BY A SEMI
MEMBER CHOLERA AND THAT CLAIM
TO LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS
CENTER WINNER I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
RESIGN HE BE ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY SOME
REMEMBER KARA WHICH WILL HELP
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PLASTIC
WASTE IN OUR ENVIRONMENT BY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF. BY
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF SMALL
PLASTIC BOTTLES OF SOAP SHAMPOO
AND THE LIGHT. PROVIDED TO
HOTEL GUESTS THE BILL IS IN
LINE WITH INDUSTRY EXISTING
GOALS AND IT HAS THE SUPPORT OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND
LODGING ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER WINNER THE
USUAL DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. I
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS. EIGHT NO
BELL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD I
CARRY IT ALL. JANE. DELHI NO
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I GOT
JOHNNY. GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
GROVE. NO HERTZBERG. HILL HI
WITH A HIGHER TITLE. NO JACKSON
HI JONES. NO LABOR. I'M ACQUIRE.
HI MITCHELL BY MONEY I'M MORE
LUCK. WELL NO NO SIN NO PAN HI
ACCORDING TO KNOW. HI ROSS BY
RUBIO. SKINNER. HI STERN BY
STONE NOVEMBER. OUR COUNTY HI I
WINNER BY WILL NO. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS CARRIERA. CHANG.
NO DOES JOHNNY. GLAZER HI HERTZ
WORK. MORE LOCK. RUBIO HI. HI
IS TWENTY FOUR NOS ELEVEN
MEASURE PASSES NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
NINETY SIX SENATOR UMBERG. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ME SOME
ABOUT TWELVE TWELVE BY A SEMI
MEMBER LEVIN AND KNACK RELATING
TO PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT.
CENTER AMBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB TWELVE
TWELVE BY A SEVEN MEMBER LEVIN
WOULD REQUIRE CALTRANS THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
TO PRODUCE A LIST OF PRIORITY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS FOR
FUNDING CONSIDERATION BY PUBLIC
PENSION RETIREMENT BOARDS AND
REVISE IT TO THEM. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THESE AGENCIES
PROVIDE FURTHER PROJECT
INFORMATION TO THE BOARD UPON
REQUEST IT'S A GOOD BILL URGENT
I BOUGHT. THANK YOU SENATOR IN
ADDITIONAL. CENTER MORE LOCKER
SEE YOUR MAKE UP. THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR SIR. I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE FLOOR MANAGER.
THERE ARE BIRDS YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE A QUESTION THERE'S A FIFTY
FIFTY CHANCE OF AN ANSWER SO. I
AM. I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY WHY
DON'T WE JUST REQUIRE A PURPLE
IS A PREPARATION OF A
PROSPECTUS VERSUS A LIST. THAT
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION FOR
WHICH I DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER.
THEN DO WE HAVE ANY. BUT PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL THAT. CALPERS IS
INVESTED WITH THE STATE WE HAVE
A TRACK RECORD OF MODEL.
THEY'RE MORE LIKE I'M NOT AWARE
OF ANY BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEY DON'T EXIST. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
VEGAS THAT ARE MORE LIKE THE
DISH OLD DEBATER DISCUSSION
SEEING NONE SENATOR UMBERG YOU
MAY CLOSE. I URGE NO VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES NO
BELL I PORGES BRADFORD I CAN BE
AT ALL BY CHANG. HI DOLLY. NO
DODD. THERE ALSO I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER. GONZALES HI GROVE. NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL I WAS SO
TIRED TITLE I JACKSON. HI JONES
I LIVE A- I'M ACQUIRED BY
MITCHELL. BY MORNING. I AM MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NELSON NO PAN
I POURED INTO YOU KNOW. HI
RALPH I RUBIO. SKINNER STERN I
STONE NOVEMBER. OUR CASKEY BY
WINNER I WILL BY CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BURGESS
NO. DOT. BY GLAZER HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI. ICE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY SENATOR UMBERG ARE
YOU PREPARED AND HE IS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR BY S.
THE MEMBER DAILY AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES SENATOR
UMBERG THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS A JUVENILE COURT RECORD
CREATES BARRIERS AND LIMITS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND THOSE THAT ARE NO LONGER
JUVENILES BUT HAVE A JUVENILE
RECORD SETTING THE RECORD IS
THE BEST WAY TO ENSURE THE PAST
MISTAKES. THAT OCCURRED WHEN
ONE WAS A JUVENILE BUT HINDER
THAT INDIVIDUAL'S FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES CURRENT LAW
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WAVES. OF FEE FOR INDIVIDUALS
UP TO TWENTY SIX TO SEAL THESE
RECORDS. THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THAT FEE FOR PERSONS
OF ANY AGE ARE DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. I
ARCHULETA I ADKINS BATES NOBEL
HI BURGESS. HI BRADFORD I COVER
HERO BY CHANG HI DOLLY. DOT I'D
RATHER. YEAH JOHNNY I GLAZER BY
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTS BERG.
I HILL I WAS SO TIRED TADO I
JACKSON. HI JONES. I LIVE A I'M
ACQUIRE. BY MITCHELL. BY
MORNING BUY MORE LUCK I'M A
REAL. NO NELSON. HI PAM. FIVE
FORTINO. ROSS BY RUBIO BY
SKINNER BY STERN BY STONE
NOVEMBER. HI IRA CASKEY BY
WINNER I WILL HI HI. CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. DELHI BY
DOURADO HI YOU KNOW I. HIGHS
THIRTY SIX KNOWS THREE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY CENTER GILL
JOHNNY ARE YOU PREPARED. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SOME OF
THOSE SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO BY A
SEMI MEMBER FLORA AND EXPLAIN
TO REDEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW THE CITY OF MAN TO
GET TO TRANSFER A GOVERNMENT
OWNED VACANT PROPERTY TO A
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES
RESOURCES FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS AND LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE OF THE
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES THE PROPERTY WOULD
OTHERWISE HAVE TO BE SOLD AT
AUCTION. THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
THE CITY TO PROVIDE
HOMELESSNESS THE SOURCES ADDED
A BUILDING THAT IS CURRENTLY
BEEN VACANT FOR FIFTEEN YEARS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR. LITTLE IS A
LITTLE OUT IN HERE SO THOSE IN
THE BACK IF YOU COULD TAKE IT
OUT TAKE IT OUT OF THE CHAMBER.
IN ADDITIONAL DEBATER
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL I BURGESS I BRADFORD I
COME HERE I CHING I DELI I DOG.
I DRAW SO. I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW I
HURTS WERE. I HILL I WAS SO
TIRED TITLE BY JACKSON BY JONES.
I LIVE A I'M ACQUIRE. HI
MITCHELL BY MORNING. I'M MORE
LOCK OUR MORALE BY NELSON BY
PAN HI FORTINO. HI ROSS I RUBIO
BY SKINNER BY STERN BY STONE.
BY NUMBER ALL RIGHT BYE BYE
KELSEY. I WINNER I WILL HI. HI
IS THREE NINE DOES ZERO MEASURE
PAT DOES YOUR PASSES NOW GOING
TO FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR GIL JOHNNY. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLE
FIFTY NINETY BY A SEMI MEMBER
LONG TO REVEAL AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LIVING THERE
GOES YANNI THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT TO FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS AND MODERATE INCOME
HOME BUYERS. WITH THE
SKYROCKETING RENTAL ON HOUSING
CRISIS CRISIS ACROSS THE STATE
THIS WILL BE A WAY TO HELP NEW
HOME BUYERS THE LEGISLATURE
PREVIOUSLY HAD LATE LEGISLATION
AND AFFECT THE PROVIDED THIS
TAX BREAK TO FIRST TIME HOME
BUYERS BUT THAT EXPIRED IN. TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
ADDITIONAL DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION. SEEING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. OUR. I
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS. BATES HI
BILL BY BURGESS. BY BRADFORD I
CARRIER I CHANG HI DOLLY I DONT.
I'D RATHER. I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ I GROVE. HI
HERTZBERG. HI HILL I WAS SO
TIRED TADO. I JACKSON I JONES I
LIVE A. I'M ACQUIRE I'M
MITCHELL BY MORNING I'M MORE
LOCK A REAL. HI NELSON. PAN
FIVE FORTINO HI NELSON. RALPH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER BY STERN BY
STONE. I AMBERG I LIVE A
HEALTHY HI BY WINNER I WILL. HI
HI. CALL CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS
ALKAN'S MORLOCK. NELSON HI.
SIZE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY NINE
SENATOR WEINER. HE IS PREPARED
MR SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN BY A SEMI
MEMBER LOSE THREE OF US AN ACT
RELATING TO HOMELESS CHILDREN
AND YOUTH. CENTER WINNER THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES
I'M PRESENTING A B. SIXTEEN ON
BEHALF OF THE SOME REMEMBER THE
THREE OF US IN THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A COMPREHENSIVE
POLICY APPROACH TO HELP
HOMELESS FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN. SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
CREATES A HOMELESS COORDINATOR
POSITION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO WORK WITH THREE
REGIONAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CENTERS. IN ORDER TO HELP
SCHOOLS ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
HOMELESS CHILDREN AND IT WILL
CREATE A STANDARDIZED PROCESS
FOR SCHOOLS TO IDENTIFY
STUDENTS. WHO MAY BE HOMELESS
AB SIXTEEN INSURERS OF
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO ASSIST
OUR HOMELESS CHILDREN AND
COORDINATE BETWEEN EXISTING
STATE AND LOCAL. EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WITH AT A MINIMUM ONE
IN TWENTY. CURRENCY
HOMELESSNESS WE NEED TO DO MORE
FOR THESE KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES THIS BILL IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
THANK YOU SIR WE ARE ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION. THIRTY NINE THIS
IS THIS BILL AS A CANDIDATE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ARE THERE
ANY OBJECTIONS. SEEING NINE. BY
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO FIGHT AND TO FORTY TWO
SENATORS SKINNER HELLO. WELL
HOLD ON FOR SEX YOU WANT TO SEE
FINER
. WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
CENTER SCANNER I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE A SEVEN MEMBER A
DREAM IS SYRIAN BOTHER A BABY
SIX ELEVEN RIGHT THERE. THANKS
FOR COMING. EXCELLENT DAILY I
WAS HONORED TO BE YOUR FLOOR
MANAGER. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON TO
FILE TWO FORTY TWO CENTER
SCANNER IS READY MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THIRTY ONE BY A SEMI MEMBER
BURNER HER BREATH. AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
BOARDS. CENTER SCANNER THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS AB NINE THIRTY ONE.
WILL HELP US INCREASE THE
REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN. ON
LOCAL NON ELECTED NON SALARIED
APPOINTED PUBLIC BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. IN CITIES WITH
POPULATIONS OVER FIFTY THOUSAND.
IT'S A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
WOMEN'S LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
IT'S SUPPORTED BY THE STATE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS THE EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. AND I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SIR
SKINNER ANY ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. NOBEL I BURGESS
NO BRADFORD. COPYRIGHT CHANG.
DELHI DOT. I'D RATHER I GOT
JOHNNY. GLAZER GONZALES I GROW
NO HERTZBERG. I HI HILL I WAS
JONES LABOR I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL BY MONEY BUY MORE LOCK.
NO MORALE NO NELSON NO PAN. HI
PORCH DINO BY ROSS. RUBIO
SKINNER. STERN. SO SKINNER. I
STERN I STONE. SO NO NUMBER. BY
COUNTY. BY WINNER I WILL.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS. EFFORT HI
COPYRIGHT HI JANE. DOLLY YEAH
JOHNNY GLAZER HI ROTH I RUBIO
BY NUMBER I WILL. HI TWENTY SIX
KNOWS NINE MEASURE KERRY'S. NOW
I HAVE GOOD NEWS FOR YOU
MEMBERS WERE GONNA START BEGIN
LIFTING CALLS. BUT WHILE WE'RE
ARGONAUT ORGANIZING WE GO BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B.
TEN SEVENTY NINE WILL BE
RETURNED TO THE ASSEMBLY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
BILLS WITH FLOOR MENACE WILL BE
DEEMED TO READ AND THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. FILE ITEM
TWO OH NINE. BY LATE IN NINETY
THREE FILE ITEM THREE OH TWO
FILE ITEM TWO NINETY FOUR FILE
ITEM TWO TO FOUR FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FOUR FIVE ONE TWENTY
FIVE WHILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE IN
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR.
TWENTY ONE. BAD HAND WRITING
THERE
. ALL RIGHT MEMBERS ARE
YOU READY WE'RE GONNA LIFT THE
CALLS. FILE I'M TWENTY SEVEN
.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
CAPPIELLO. LATER BY GONZALEZ.
JACKSON JONES. HI MERRELL.
NELSON HI WINNER WINNER I. YEAH
CALL THEM TO MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. ATKINS COPYRIGHT BY
GONZALES. JACKSON BY MORALE. HI.
SIZE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THESE
SOME AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO. YOUR SECRETARY CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
COPYRIGHT BY. GLAZER BY GROWTH
BY JONES HI NELSON. NO IT'S NOT.
PRICE THIRTY NINE KNOWS HERE ON
THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY NINE
KNOWS HERE ON THE ON THE BILL
AND THE SO THE ASSEMBLY AND
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED. NO
MEASURED MEASURE PASSES ITS
THIRD READING YEP YOUR RIGHT
THANK YOU MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY THREE MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ALKAN'S GLAZER HI NELSON.
NELSON I. NICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY OF. SAYS
URGENCY CLYDE RIGHT THERE UP.
IT'S IN THE WRONG PLACE AND
VICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO.
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS GLAZER BY NELSON.
SECRETARY CALLED ME ON THE MAP
NEWS TONIGHT. PRICE THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO. THE MAN THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY NINE MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS
DOT. BY GLAZER BY HERZBERG. BY
NELSON. HI. HI PRICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
TWO. MISTER SECRETARY CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN ATKINS
GLAZER. LASER EYE ALAN HI.
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG. BY JACKSON.
NELSON BY SKINNER. BY STERN.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE FINAL TIME
ATKINS GONZALEZ JACKSON STERN.
PRICE THIRTY FIVE NOSE ONE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS GLAZER BY HERZBERG HI.
PRICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. NO GLAZER HI HERTZ WORK.
HI RUBIO. HI I. PRICE TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
BATES GLAZER. HI HERTZBERG BY
JACKSON. MITCHELL RUBIO BY
STERN. HI BY WINNER. I MID JULY.
I WILL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE FINAL TIME ATKINS BATES NO
JACKSON. HI IS THIRTY ONE NO
SEVEN MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE TWELVE. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS BRADFORD. HI DALLY. HI.
RIGHT OKAY GLAZER HI HERTZBERG.
JONES HI RUBIO I STERN. STERN I.
YEAH MISTER SECRETARY CALLED
OUT TO MEMBERS ONE FINAL TIME
ATKINS HERTZBERG. HI IS THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
SEVEN MISTER SECRETARY CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS VALLEY.
GLAZER BY GROWTH. NO HERTZ BERG
BY JONES NO STERN. BY STONE NO.
YEAH HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT
ON THE URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY
KNOWS EIGHT ON THE MEASURE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR.
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA HI ATKINS.
COVER EURO. CHANG NO THE LASER.
GLAZER MURTADA. ROTH HI RUBIO
HI WINNER. BY. CALL THEM TO
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME ATKINS
COPIER LASER TACO. HI TWENTY
FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY NINE MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS GORGEOUS. BLAZER. I
GROWTH. MITCHELL. MORE LOCK HI
WINNER. HI. MID JULY. HIGHS
THIRTY THREE NOTES FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BASE BY GLAZER BY MORE
LOCK. WINNER WINNER. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY THREE MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS GLAZER. BY WINNER. HI I
TWENTY NINE INSTEAD OF FIVE
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY ONE MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS DELHI. GLAZER GROW
CLOSER I. GROWTH. TADO HI
MCGUIRE BY WINNER. WINNER. THE
PRICE THIRTY NO SEVEN MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY FOUR MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN.
ATKINS ALAN I GLAZER. BY HILL.
BY MIKE WEIR HI RUBIO. SKINNER
I STERN. I WINNER. BY. CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS ONE
FINAL TIME ATKINS. RUBIO REVIEW
BY. HI IS TWENTY EIGHT NOS
ELEVEN MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN BY ATKINS
HILL. BY MCGUIRE BY RUBIO. BY
SKINNER. STERN BY. SKINNER ARI
WINNER HI. NICE THREE NINE NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS. I'M SORRY WHAT YEAH
I'VE I'VE HAD MYSELF ONE FIFTY
EIGHT CALL THAT SOME MEMBERS.
ALAN HI ATKINS GROVE. HILL BY
MCGUIRE. BY MERRELL. HI RUBIO.
BY SKINNER I STERN. HI WINNER
BY. YOUR HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE
MISTER SECRETARY CALLED THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN. HI ATKINS
GROVE. HILL HI JONES. NO
MCGUIRE BY MORNING. MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. RUBIO BY SKINNER. BY
STERN. I STONE. WINNER OF THE
WINNER I. YOU KNOW. HIGHS
THIRTY TWO NO THREE MEASURE
PASSES
. CONTINUING WITH THE LEG
LENGTHS OF THE CALL WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
FOUR MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL I MEAN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN. HI ATKINS
GORGEOUS. DELHI GLAZER. GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG. BY HILL BY JONES.
HI REQUIRE. BY FORTINO. I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER I STERN HI NUMBER HI
WINNER WHERE I. YEAH CALL THE
NUMBERS ONE MORE TIME ATKINS
GORGEOUS. DALLY GLAZER BY. HI
IS THIRTY TWO KNOWS FIVE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY SIX MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN.
HI FALCONS YEAH JOHNNY. HI
HERTZBERG. I HILL I AM ACQUIRE
ALL RIGHT MORALE. NELSON BY.
RUBIO. REVIEW I MORALE NO.
SKINNER. BY STERN HI WINNER BY.
NICE THIRTY A NOSE ONE ON THE
URGENCY EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO
NOS ONE ON THE MEASURE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO A FILE ITEM
TWO HUNDRED MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN BY ATKINS
BRADFORD. BY HILL. I'M ACQUIRE
I RUBIO. I SKINNER. I STERN BY
WINNER HI. PRICE THIRTY KNOWS
NINE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEMS TO ELEVEN MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN. ATKINS DOWN I. BRADFORD
HILL HI. BRADFORD I. THE CHOIR
I PAN HI POURTANT DINO. BY
RUBIO. I SKINNER BY STERN HI
WINNER. BY BY. THIRTY NINE OH
ZERO FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM TO EIGHTEEN. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN HI ATKINS
COVER EURO. TIRADO. BY GROWTH.
HILL. HI JACKSON BY MCGUIRE BY
NELSON BY PAN BY RUBIO. I
SKINNER. BY STERN BY WINNER WE
ARE. CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE FINAL TIME COPYRIGHT BY
GROWTH BY. PRICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
THREE. MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALAN HI JANE.
GOT JOHNNY BY GLAZER. HILL HILL
I. JONES. NO MCGUIRE I TAN HI
RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN HI
WINNER BY. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE FINAL TIME CHANG.
GLAZER GLAZER ARE. PRICE TWENTY
EIGHT NOS TEN MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM. TWO TWO
EIGHT MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BATES HI GROVE. HI PAN. I RUBIO
I STERN. HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE
PRICE THIRTY NINE OH ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. NO MEMBERS
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
THIRTY MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS JACKSON. BY
HI. PRICE THIRTY NINE OH ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY TWO MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS BAIT. HI THERE
ALSO. I GROVE. HI NELSON I
PANNED BY RUBIO BY FIVE THIRTY
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWO FORTY MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE. GORGEOUS
CHANG HI DOLLY. GOD JOHNNY HI
GLAZER. GROVE MORE LOCK. PAN.
BY RUBIO I. ONE MORE TIME
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
BATES GORGEOUS DALLY GLAZER I
GROW MORE LOCK OF NO. MORE LUCK.
HI IS THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR
MEASURE PASSES NOW MEMBERS WILL
BE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
FORTY SEVEN. MISTER SECRETARY.
CALL THE APPS TO MEMBERS ATKINS
PAN. BY RUBIO BY. PRICE THIRTY
NINE OH ZERO MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
FORTY NINE. MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
PAN OUR. PRICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. BATES NO
YEAH JOHNNY NO HER TITLE.
JACKSON HI MORE LOCK NO NELSON
NO PAN. HI. PRICE TWENTY SIX
KNOWS TWELVE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING ON TO FIGHT ITEM.
TWO SIXTY TWO MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS DELHI HI. HI. PRICE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWO SIXTY THREE. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS GROVE.
JACKSON HI MITCHELL. HI MORLOCK.
PAN HI. GROVE NO. PRICE TWENTY
EIGHT NOS TEN THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FIND ITEMS TWO SIXTY FIVE MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS DALLY. NO
JONES NO. PAN HI RUBIO HI.
PRICETHIRTY KNOWS NINE MEASURE
PASSES NOW MOVING ON TO FILE IT
AND TWO SEVENTY SIX MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. DALLY HI.
HI PRICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TO NINETY SIX MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL AND
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE. YEAH I
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS. TALLY.
DELHI DAILY I HI MITCHELL. PAN.
BY ROTH RATHER. MITCHELL I. HI
IS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DELHI PAN. BY STONE.
DELHI I A STONE HI. HIGHS FORTY
NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TO. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS PAN. PRICE THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
NINETY NINE MISTER SECRETARY
CALLED ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
BURGESS PAN. HI. SIZE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THREE
HUNDRED MISTER SECRETARY CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS MERRELL.
NELSON PANTS HI. NELSON I.
THIRTY EIGHT OUR EYES NOSE HERE
ON THE URGENCY THIRTY EIGHT HI
IS NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THREE OH SIX MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS NELSON
ARI PAN. HI. PRICE THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO MEASURE PAT IS NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE AT HIM THREE
THIRTY MISTER SECRETARY CALLED
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS NELSON.
PANTS NELSON I PANNED HIGH.
PRICE THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE ARE
THE FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS PAN HI
WILK. NO WELL NO. HI TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA
RE RETURNED EMOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SENATOR
UMBERG THANK YOU WAS PRESENT I
REQUEST RECONSIDERATION FILING
THEM NUMBER EIGHTY TWO A. B.
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE. THAT
EXTRACTION. THERE'S A MOTION TO
RECONSIDER IS THERE OBJECTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTIONS
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED
HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO.
MISTER SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES.
HI BILL HI BURGESS. BRADFORD BY
KELLY AT ALL. CHANG. HI DAWALY
BY DODD. I'D RATHER. YEAH
JOHNNY. HI GLAZER I GONZALEZ.
GROWTH I HURTS BERG. HI HI HILL
BY WHISTLE I TADO. JACKSON
JONES. I LIVE A. I'M ACQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MORNING. BUT WHAT
TIME MORE LOX AND
RECONSIDERATION HIGH MORALE.
WHICH IS AN ANTI NELSON I PAN.
I PORTANT DINO. HI ROB. I RUBIO.
HI. WHEN THE WOMAN IS. I WANT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO MEMBERS
THAT WOULD THAT WE ALREADY
GRANTED RECONSIDERATION BY
VIRTUE OF KNOWING OBJECTION
OBJECTING SO THIS IS IT IN THE
BILLING CHIEF. SO YOU NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT. BABY. BABY
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE SO WE'RE
VOTING ON A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE NOT ON RECONSIDERATION IF
WE COULD STRIKE IF WE COULD
STRIKE THE ROLE INSTEAD AND
START OVER SO BILLING CHIEF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE. STARTING
OVER ON THE BILLING CHIEF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE. YEAH FILE
ITEM EIGHTY TWO WILL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECONDS TO PREPARE
SOURCE FILE IT ITEM EIGHTY TWO
.
EVERYBODY READY. ALL RIGHT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. HI BILL. HI
GORGEOUS BY BRADFORD I CARRY IT
ALL. HI CHANG. HI DOLLY HI DOT
HAIDAR ALSO I GUESS JOHNNY BY
GLAZER I GONZALEZ. GROWTH. I
HEARD HEARD BY HILL HIGHWAY SO
HI TADO I JACKSON. JONES YEAH
HI LABOR I AM A CHOIR HI
MITCHELL. NO MONEY. MORE LUCK
I'M A REAL HI NELSON HI PAN. HI
FORTINO HI HI ROSS BY RUBIO BY
SKINNER NO OKAY STERN. NO STONE.
I AMBERG I WORK OUT SEE I
WINNER. NO. WILK HI HI. MISTER
SECRETARY CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME ALAN BY. ATKINS
GONZALEZ NO JACKSON NO. MONEY.
SIZE THIRTY TWO NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE GOING
BACK TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES SENATOR SCANNER. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT ON BEHALF
OF THE MEMBER I REQUEST THAT AB
SIXTY NINE FILE ITEM FOR SIX
SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER KING BE
MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DESK WILL NOTE AND ADDITIONALLY
AT THE REQUEST OF THE MEMBER I
ASK THAT. FILE NUMBER THREE
NINE TWO AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER EKMAN BE
REMOVED FROM THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR DULY NOTED
THANK YOU SENATOR SCANNER. ANY
OTHER SENATOR. AT THIS POINT
WILL MOVE TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
PRESIDENT THERE WILL BE A
GOVERNANCE IN FINANCE COMMITTEE
MEETING TOMORROW MORNING FRIDAY
AT EIGHT THIRTY AM ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN THE MAJORITY LEADER
WE'LL BE BRINGING DONUTS. THANK
YOU SIR ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SEEING NONE
MISTER MAJORITY LEADER THERE IS
NO OTHER BUSINESS SO THE DESK
IS CLEAR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU'RE MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
WE HAVE DISPENSED TODAY. YOUR
ATTENTION FOR A MINUTE WE HAVE
TO SPEND SEDATE WITH FIFTY SIX
ASSEMBLY MEASURES AND FOR. AND
FOR SENATE MEASURES FOR A TOTAL
OF SIX OF SIXTY MEASURES
YESTERDAY INCLUDING CONSENT WAS
A HUNDRED AND TWO WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO SO PLEASE AGAIN
REMINDING YOU ALL NEXT WEEK
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
LATE ESPECIALLY. THE FILES
ESPECIALLY HEAVY THAT BEING
SAID THAT THE SENATE WILL BE
ADJOURNED WILL RECONVENE FRIDAY
TOMORROW AT SIX AM OUR HOPES I
MEAN NINE AM. NINE AM EVERYONE
I WANTED. TODAY IN THE SENATE
WILL BE ADJOURNED AND WE'LL
RECONVENE TOMORROW FRIDAY AT
NINE AM